the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
we've reached the midway point at the
super bet chess classic in bucharest
romania with the leaders coasting into
the much deserved rest day the bottom of
the field fought furiously to gain
ground as young fans watch their idols
in awe coming off of a tough loss
american fabiano carawana was relentless
in wearing down a struggling chakriar
mama diara to secure his first win of
the event the players are refreshed and
invigorated with new ideas
day six of classical clashes coming up
next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day six of the
2022 superbad chess classic the first
stop of the grand chess tour behind the
trees in the chishmi jew park lies the
chess zone where local players come here
to play chess backgammon and just simply
relax well our chess players have been
relaxing during the rest day as well and
are ready to get back into the action
let's go to the studio and start today's
round with yasher peter and alejandra
fabulous springtime footage of the
romanian capital as we welcome you to
our coverage of the super bad chess
classic in bucharest the first stop of
the on the 2022 grand chess tour
morning i'm peter switler and with me is
the ever smiling yes here
peter as always great to be with you and
alejandro in studio hello everyone hello
everyone and welcome back for our live
coverage of the super bet chess classic
tournament the rest day was much needed
i can assure you and i'm really
expecting the players to come back with
a lot of vim vigor and energy today
peter set the stage for us what are our
current standings let's look at them
the standings are as follows wesley
continues leading the tournament he's
having an excellent tournament so far
uh three people in close pursuit uh
levon ironian maximum
and the uh local boy bogdan daniel dayak
uh levana maxim actually playing each
other today that's uh jumping slightly
ahead then two people are fifty percent
and uh four people in the miners
including two of the uh candidates uh
alireza and richard rapport not having a
particularly great tournament so far and
our format
the format for the tournament is a
template round robin with 90 minutes for
the first 40 then 30 minutes for the
rest of the game with a half a minute
increment starting from move one joe
offers are explicitly forbidden and the
normal classical scoring system is in
place after five rounds of play what's
our remaining schedule
uh now that the rest day is behind us
the schedule is extremely
straightforward we have four formal
rounds to play and we will play them one
by one finishing on saturday and there
will be playoffs if there is a tie for
first on that saturday
and aleandro is here to explain the road
ahead for our leaders alejandro as
always good to see you in studio my
friend good morning friends good to be
with you here in this morning in saint
louis of course let's take a look at the
road ahead for some of the players that
have more points in the tournament
starting with the players that are
trailing wesley by just half a point on
plus one we have mvl maxima sherlock
graph will be starting today against
lavonna ronyan a matchup that they're
very familiar with he'll be following it
up against the candidate richard rapport
and then the local hero bogdan daniel
deck who's had a very good tournament
he's currently tied in second place with
mvl and he's gonna finish in a barn
burner as this current teammates both of
them representing the french flag they
play together in the european team
championships together mvl will be
playing against ferugia to round off his
tournament meanwhile levon he as we know
will be playing mvl today but then look
at his road ahead two tough games coming
up one against favi the other one
against nepo but he will be finishing
with the white pieces against shaq who
has not had a good tournament so far of
course three rounds to go before he gets
there first the local hero bogdan daniel
dag has had a wonderful event he's had a
lot of black pieces and still managed to
hold positions without any trouble took
full advantage of richard reports
blunder and move 40 and is sitting
pretty on plus one he'll be facing a
tough group of players starting with
dominguez today wesley so tomorrow
bashir lagrav on round number eight and
will be finishing against fabiano
caruana and of course we have our leader
wesley saw he is
very familiar with the situation
comfortable lead half a point ahead of
the rest of the field he still has a
tough road ahead but he has survived
already some of the big shots he will be
playing against rapper today dak
tomorrow firuja on round eight that's
gonna be a big one and he'll be
finishing with the black pieces against
lanier dominguez but there is a matchup
that has certainly caught our attention
today it has been that one of levon and
maxime as they're going to be playing
against each other and to talk more
about the subject let's go to our
friends in bucharest anastasia and
christian
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day six of the 2022 super
bath chess classic the first stop of the
grand chess tour well yesterday we had
an amazing day filled with excitement it
was a rest day i will be your host to
bring you all the updates today grand
master christian career alongside my
brilliant co-host woman grandmaster
anastasia karlovic anastasia what did
you do yesterday during the wrestling
hello everyone yeah it was a rest day
probably for christian but not for for
me and not for the
some players because four of them
actually came back to the plane when you
and took part in a very nice event it
was a fun rising event for ukrainian
refugees which was organized by superbad
and grand chester foundations so wesley
saw
fibano caruana mvl and bogdan deck
actually didn't have literally the rest
day so they played these mini matches
and i was lucky actually to play against
maximus telegraph team and it was really
a good event and at the end they managed
to raise to raise 15 000 euros for
ukrainian refugees so
that was a really great day actually
absolutely and i actually heard one
fabiano caruana and mvl as well as
firouza and his second they actually
played tennis yesterday so they got some
sports in it was a very very fun day but
today we're back in action we're back to
chess what games do you have your eyes
set on for today yeah i have of course
my eyes on the game between
those two who are sharing the second
place at samwell and levon aronian so
both of them will fight definitely today
and after this uh great uh training
preparation which we had yesterday with
maxim uh i believe that he is in a good
mood because he won the game
unfortunately for me and he will be in a
good spirit and he'll try to fight
against levon uh both of them of course
should do something today in order to
fight for the leading for the leader uh
to be the leader of the tournament so i
think that these games should be very
interesting both of them played nearly
40 games against each other so
i believe it's going to be a good fight
christian what do you think and what is
your favorite game today well the game
that you mentioned uh definitely strikes
me as one of the more exciting ones
these guys are friends but today they're
going to be rivals one game that i'm
having my eyes on is the battle of the
former challengers for the world
championship crown that is jan
nepomnyashi who just lost a big match
against magnus carlsen in 2020 as well
as fabiano caruana and we see them right
now they're getting ready to start their
game this one is a very intriguing one
because fabiano well first of all let's
look at their head to head i see zero
wins for fabiano caruana that is just
incredible almost no other top player in
the circuit has this type of record
against one of the best chess players in
life fabiano caruana nepo never lost
against him he beat him once and eight
rods this one is going to be extremely
extremely exciting fabiano has the white
pieces nepo will have to defend the
black pieces but guys in st louis what
games do you have your eyes set on for
today well thank you anastasia thank you
christian indeed let's take a look at
all of the pairings for round six uh
peter do the honors yeah here are the
pairings for our today's entertainment
and education of course uh jacques has
not had a very uh bright tournament so
far is playing against alireza who you
could say similar things uh about he
clearly is very unused to being on -1
after the first half of the tournament
and as we have seen in the previous
round i think he is
liable to start playing risky and
riskier
openings to try to correct correct that
situation both players need a picture
for sure elinir is white against bogdan
dayak and bogdan is having a very solid
tournament we'll see what transfer what
happens next uh wesley is white against
strichard and then where by the way
creativity is not being rewarded at
least in the case of a rapport yeah
that is true and yeah he's provided us
with plenty of entertainment yeah that's
that horrible blunder in in his game
against bogdan deck is is so far being
uh yeah it's costly and is sort of the
defining defining thing to say about his
first five rounds and then the two
marquee matchups mvl versus levon who
played if you include rabbit and blitz
they probably are nearing the 100 mark
but by this point i would say i'm sure
uh and and fighting against uh jan which
i was also very surprised to learn that
uh fabio has not won a single classical
game against jan but they also haven't
played as much against each other as i
would have suspected honestly only only
10 games so far it really isn't very
much for two very very established top
top ten players there we see this a shot
of the playing hall yeah we saw a
fabulous sport of very very nicely thorn
jeans
always staying on top of the modern
fashions by modern i mean 1990s the rip
look yeah
and we're going to be having a special
guest making the ceremonial first move
uh uh yeah uh this is the romanian
soccer player florian rodriguez
uh
let's see let's see what he chooses for
e4 linear let's see if he goes with e4
yeah baby e4 there you go very very
confidently played one e4
best by test
winner of the wefa cup 1994 with ac
milan
nice
all right as we uh
yeah so far the the athletic
representation in the stern
understanding is is outstanding yeah you
have to say that fencing basketball
player soccer players this is really
great stuff and of course the players
have been dueling it out fighting very
very hard
what are they fighting for uh peter yeah
let's thanks we see yeah let's take a
brief look at the the prize fund the
price fund is as follows as you can see
there's a very very nice
sum up top there's a six figure price
for first beautiful and 65 a second 48
for third going all the way down to 10.5
for the last place and the gc gct points
on the right there they will provide an
additional purse at the end of the tour
and as you can see as you can see up top
there there is an additional one gcc
point if you win the tournament outright
compared to one tie breaks speaking of
winning the tournament outright we see
uh wesley so there against richard
reporters wesley so leading by half a
point we have one e2 e4
and you were mentioning e5 boo where's
my neighbor yeah with this fashion car
if you
you had seen uh a game that fabi lost
on the white side of the uh sveshnikov
today we're seeing a petrov yeah the
only decisive game that i remember
between fabiano caron and nepomiacci
actually happened with
fabi being white in a complex fashioning
of to be fair fabi was winning that game
but in complications just let the game
go completely and young
as usual played fast got favi into
complications and when it came down to
calculate five he lost his way exactly
was it that was that zagreb i think it
was aggressive yeah he started
incredibly well did he start with three
out of three and then the wheels somehow
conspired to fall off yeah exactly and
unsure exactly how but obviously you
know the petrov has been up uh he is his
prep for the for the match and uh
while it's still fresh in his mind it
makes perfect sense to uh to continue
employing it's a very solid opening he
doesn't
probably feel the urge to you know how
long do you feel
the expiration date of these openings
are after a match
i mean opening ideas
everything that you analyzed how long
until it kind of expires yeah sour milk
yeah expire by date i'm gonna guess two
years but certainly no longer than that
i mean
i would think they're untrustworthy but
i also but i also think it very much
depends on the opening and with the
petrov it might be longer
because the uh
the sort of the underlying correctness
of the opening has to come into into
into the equation there and
petrov is extremely solid and i i don't
think it's very easily refutable
uh i think it's more about the fact that
uh
you probably you know repeat and
fine-tune it so much for the
for the match that
you know for the for the next half a
year you you don't maybe even need to
click on anything before the game it's
also fresh in your uh in your mind which
is why he's still playing it here for
instance but
eventually you know if the point
gets reached where he actually needs to
go back to i don't know an hour and a
half of clicking through files again
because they have become hazy
this is where maybe you return to the
night or because
having fun also needs to factor into the
equation at some point
but uh for now yeah very very
understandable that he's still playing
the petrov jump in with your own uh do
by date
i don't really know it it does depend on
on a lot of factors it also depends on
the variation itself
we found
a couple of lines in the world
championship match from 2018 from 2018
that a couple months after
anymore
i don't want to go to specifics on that
one
and what that was but yeah some things
survived for a long time i know that
fabi actually used an idea it wasn't
like published or anything which idea it
was or where it came from but i know
that favi used an idea from the world
championship match more than a year
later like just nobody had gone into
that line it was something we had
long ago we just didn't expect magnus to
really go into he didn't and it just
served useful in a in a later game so
all this preparation that we're talking
about that you go into with the world
championship you just cover so many
things you cover things that you haven't
probably thought about in years going
into the world championship just making
sure that you have all of your bases
covered and that uh it just gives rise
to many ideas right
that being said petrov is what nepo used
at the world championship it's what he
prepared for it and it's serving him
well and we've seen players do this
remember how long this feshnikov served
magnus
passed the world championship match
right he would definitely definitely
maybe even more yeah yeah and his
opening was
way ahead of his competitors i remember
that
navarra lost especially cuff against
um
against magnus carlsen not that far
after the world championship match and
he went into a variation that our file
during the world championship match says
don't play this
black plays this move and suddenly white
is lost and i was like oh i have this
paragraph already ready
i wish i could have shown it to david
before the game
yeah have a look
for you you of course have experience
having helped vladimir kramnik in his
world championship match did you get a
chance to use any of the novelties ideas
months and months later or yeah i've
been sort of uh the in particular the
martial anti-martial work that we did uh
yeah and that's a whole
other topic but
really let's go
marshall marshall not so much but auntie
marshall work that we've done for for
the match served
i think
all of us who wanted to play the opening
for quite some time and uh but for me
like the the biggest takeaway there if
we if like if we if we take the hilarity
that will stay hopefully
you know subdued yeah off air for now uh
i don't know
for you alejandro after you've done
after you were done working for for the
match in 20 when was the next time you
touched the pieces seriously
in like no not in terms of playing but
in terms of in terms of actually working
on chess again properly when was the
next time you felt like doing it
it was like an energy zap yeah it had to
be like a solid month and a half of
after that because i took uh some time
off my duties as collegiate coach i
assigned var who's at the
because of the truck helping us today uh
to work uh with the team while i was
working with favi so it was a few months
before i even because for me i think
i've
legit spent like half a year just you
know playing i i could still play but i
seriously
couldn't really look at chess properly
for quite some time because i can see
that though yeah
vladimir is uh
he's very you know his work ethic and
the work ethic he expects from
his team from people helping him is uh
quite remarkable and yeah
i've had i've had my feel there yeah
hard work i'd like to turn our attention
to the actual games going on between um
fabi and eon for a moment because we
have this very topical well-known uh
system of the petrov and i have to say
that in the 80s 90s this was like c2c4
exclusive that was like the only move
rookie one still existed though
those those those strange lines after
rookie one bishop g4 c3 f5 they
they there was also the pawn sacrifice
too
yeah but
anyway c2 c4 uh near exclusively was
played
knight c3 is a kind of a little bit of a
modern twist and if you could talk
knowledgeably about knight bd2 that
seems like i have some idea about this
actually yeah because we my my sort of
most recent foray into actually working
on chess seriously was when i was
helping carol alexander for the
uh you know the 400-day candidates yes
exactly and since since everybody these
days everybody is perfectly capable of
playing the petrol against you you uh
you get to look at it quite seriously so
i've i've looked at this knight bg2 is
these days of very very serious option
one of the main options because c4
uh
it surprises me just sort of how uh rare
it has become but it does it does seem
like black is holding those positions
after night beat the night before b2
castles reasonably comfortably this it
seems to me that the state of the
opening for as of right now yeah knight
c3 and whatever you want to go here
yeah
hp6 is also probably not that bad but
bishop five being by far the main move
there
and
this is this prompted white to try all
these all these other things like
youtube being you know very very serious
among them
uh 93 has been very topical i think
about 15 years back but now is actually
a very rare guest at the top level 92
there's two options here for black
bishop five i think has already been
played by jan which is
obviously a playable move but not not
the only one you could also go on knight
takes d2
and then after let's say bishop takes d2
bishop g4 c3 you have this these types
of positions which
um
they look like nothing at all but in but
because of how exactly yasser is
immediately pointing out the one problem
black has this is a very stupid knight
it's completely restricted by the c3d2
uh pawn structure and this is why black
isn't really entirely equal immediately
right despite having a very solid
structure and not really being behind in
development either uh and this is a kind
of a weird line where that some very
very slow like creeping creeping
advances are being made right
i think it's generally equal but you do
need to be a bit precise and bishop 5 is
the other option of course
after which
you get positions which are actually
kind of similar to
uh
to what we're discussing there after
rookie one black will have a choice you
can go knight g6 so you can go knight
takes d2 as well um i'm just thinking
about the game that fabi
played with shaq
yeah but
that was with the knight on b8 yeah the
structure is exactly the same but that
was with the knight on b8 and it didn't
even go to c6 it went to a6 and c7 and
then back to a6 weirdly yeah
uh and here yeah 96 is playable but i
get the feeling that these days if you
want to play these types of as i as i
called it the previous time so the uh
chinese petrov with the
bishop 596 you don't want your knight on
c6 it's just not very particularly well
placed there uh so i'm expecting knight
takes d2
after rookie one if one does happen
uh and uh 92 queen takes g2 because
bishop 5 unfortunately doesn't quite
work tactically because you lose the g4
pawn there otherwise it would be
obviously the move to make exactly yeah
but there are no tactics here queen of
three knight g4 and you don't actually
have any
uh justification for it so you take with
with the queen on jitsu black takes on
d3 you take with the queen black castles
you play before and once again
it seems
unbelievably sterile frankly but because
of the knight on c6 and because we
currently are slightly more in
possession of the e-file than our
opponent here with white yeah we get a
little bit of a pull yeah we get a
little bit of a pull exactly uh all of
this obviously has uh you know lots of
theory connected to it there's uh the
tons of games here we do have bishop f5
on the board by the way
let's just go to i mean
you i always believe in paying respects
to our tournament leader whoever they
may be whether they're
leading by upset or what have you and
wesley so let's face it has played a
fine event he has a score of plus two
and he's playing against the ever
creative richard rapport and today it
looks like it just murano
i want to call this the karpov variation
but of course i can't do that but it was
really anatoly karpov who played queen
c2 and kind of i don't know furnished an
apartment
yeah
i'm not
i'm not as up-to-date on this as i as i
was at one point at one point i played
this with uh with the white pieces
actually i had a period where uh the
this love semislav was so popular that
uh you could actually build a repertoire
expecting quite a bit of it without
really knowing very much about 1d4
otherwise exactly and i uh but i
actually played the latvian what's it
what's what's its official name the
seven g4 is it the latvian attack or
uh because of shirov and [ __ ]
amongst others uh
and you can see it on the screen right
here
of attack actually just straight up
strobol of attack well that's great that
he got the
the
the proper do yeah i mean oftentimes the
players who do who are the inventive
aren't
aren't getting the worms the cockles of
my heart exactly and to see shabba so so
recognized and i remember the first time
i saw it you know i just kind of like
turned my eyes and said you know and
these days it's just so completely run
of the meal right right
like it's accepted i mean the bishop has
laughed at fade you're playing g4 now
come on that's soft sacrifice exactly
exactly so the whole idea here is that
if you do take it you're inviting uh
although that's not the end of the story
by any means i don't know it's just it's
just and also like dxg4 is completely
unforced there was a return of this
recently i think there was a reasonably
high level game starting from this
position very recently i mean somewhat
recently i think h6 was played yeah but
there's plenty of moves here h6 exists
the immediate detail c4 is not
unplayable bishop b4 used to be a
topical move in this position just to
secure the e4 square for the knight to
be able to meet g5 with 94. but none of
this happened because wesley really is
not
uh stylistically i mean i'm sure he's
capable while he's leading the
tournament he's not playing g4
uh with the tournament lead on the line
a7 a6 we'll keep an eye on this game
turning it over to alejandro do we
actually have a night or
sighting we do it's not a petrol every
time somebody plays e4 in romania we
have this game between lanier dominguez
and bogdan daniel derek who's given us
quite a show so far he's not afraid of
using the night of here of course
dominguez a big specialist of this the
english attack bishop e3 he famously
used it in the sink field cup last year
to destroy maxine vasherla grav in what
was the game of the tournament yes and
we're going to go down a theory pretty
heavily as we have mentioned over and
over again dominguez is a great
theoretician really believes in his
openings he's never afraid to essay them
no matter if his opponent is well aware
of what's coming his way and we're going
to go down one of the main theoretical
lines of this variation of the night or
takes takes knight bd7 queen d2 g6 is
what everybody's been playing in this
position castles and castles is a little
bit on the rare side bishop e2 is
slightly more common
but castle has been seen the problem
with castles is that in some ways it's
upon sacrifice how so because after the
move knight b6 it's not actually so easy
to defend this guy how do you put your
bishop on e2 you can just follow it up
with the move c4 and no problems you
hold on to your structure but if you
play c4 in this position you can imagine
you're going to have serious trouble
down the c file so because of the
placement of the king on c1 you cannot
comfortably defend this pawn on d5 of
course you could take on b6 by alexander
do you not just take the knight well you
don't want to take that knight this
bishop is very valuable it is a bishop
after all that solves all of black's
opening problems you don't want to take
on b6 instead king b1 was played just go
ahead take my pawn knight bd takes b
knight bd takes d5 bishop g5 bishop e7
and a3 was uh not exactly the novelty of
the game there are some correspondence
games we've talked about correspondence
case quite often in this show it's a
source of creativity for the players
staring to see what engines and centaurs
do in the game of chess and a3 has been
played in five different correspondence
games all of course and then the draws
but probably very exciting ones anyway
it's a kind of a passing move it's not
so clear immediately what the idea of
the move a3 might be
but it does challenge black to equalize
this position after some thought not
that long of a thought
bogdan daniel did play queen c7 because
it was only a six or seven minute thing
i'm wondering if he's still in
preparation because we're used to bogdan
daniel going into the tank 20 30 minutes
if he's not entirely familiar with the
situation on the board so quincy saturn
was played after not such a long thing
here i believe dominguez has not
answered yet even though every single
game that happened in the database
continuing with queen c7 where's white's
compensation where it's going to be this
light square's bishop potential if this
light square bishop somehow finds a good
diagonal and blocks black from ever
advancing d5 white could get a very nice
bind in the center it's also
worth noting that this king it's not
entirely clear where it goes if you
castle kingside there are so many
variations in which i can just sack sack
made fisher style on the king side then
you're not comfortable doing so there
the king on e8 is slightly uncomfortable
as it is as your rooks are not connected
and it's not particularly stable but
with the blue queen c7 you might be
hinting about long castling which is
something very rare in this particular
variation of the night or if it's not
something that you see very often but at
the moment it might be one of the ideas
and perhaps the reason that queen c7 is
preferred over immediately defining the
king
getting the uh keeping the option of
castling long
uh thank you alejandro i actually played
this line with white but a3 kind of
surprised me and alejandro pointing out
that this is the uh the correspondence
chess favorite is uh explaining many
things to me because it does seem like
you know it's an extremely tactical
position we have already sacrificed a
pawn there and to add to the to
alejandro's explanation there for a
second if you go back to move
12 for black after knight b6 one thing
that alejandro uh didn't mention here
queen a5 looks very natural but white is
basically one temple short because with
the king of b1 this would be a very very
strong move depending on c1 black
immediately replies with bishop h6
uh
protecting protecting the knight on b6
uh tactically and here we come back to
what alejandro said the bishop 23 is a
hugely influential piece
in these types of positions and the
bishop pair in general is something that
white kind of values very very highly
and getting those bishops off the board
is such an achievement for black in
these types of structures that i'd
prefer is just to give up the pawn on d5
rather than trade the the bishops i
believe i played g3 in this position
maybe against jose levanchuk i think i
played g3 i've looked at this position
over the years quite a bit
white is pretty much never worse unless
you commit some grievous mistakes
against against the nature of the
position but finding an advantage is is
quite difficult and interestingly
linear plays g3 after a3 quincy seven
which is now really confusing
uh because
a3 is generally a very useful move but
so is you know having a tempo
but like just generally and having the
move yeah having the move you know if g3
g3 can very easily be met by queen c7
anyway and then you can you know if you
want you can play h a3 you can if you
want you can make other useful moves
bishop d3 rook he one followed by a four
is a very typical plan
c4 c5 actually is something that white
often plays for in these types of
positions weirdly in particular if black
gossel's queen side exactly but i will
trust linear on over this much more than
i will trust my own impressions of this
position he is a much better
theoretician of the
uh of the two of us for sure
it's strange because i i am in my mind
visualizing
either king f8 king g7 or castle short
yeah it goes it goes to c8 a lot and a
lot a lot in this line the
the reason i mentioned king left or king
g7 i was thinking h4 because in case the
king does go
king's side
i should have played g4 you played g3
yeah one and another another topic that
we have to bring up here is that
white is actually uh
sort of
time and time again in this line is
saying no to winning the pawn back
immediately instead of g3 for instance
you can play c4 this is something that
needs to be mentioned we can play c4
chase the knight away probably to b6
knight four doesn't look very attractive
i mean it exists but i don't i don't see
why that would be that great and after
knight b6 we can take on f6 and on d6
right and these end games actually often
require very precise play from the black
side to equalize because if you if you
don't do it properly and the rook on d6
doesn't get kind of smoked out
immediately and stays stays there being
a source of annoyance you don't equalize
stoke yeah here i think 97 works which
is why maybe g3 is a useful move because
having access to the bishop h3 yeah yeah
that would put the kabasha
yeah yeah
also after rook takes d6 i think
the problem with knight d7 is that it's
a bit passive knight c8 also exists so
knight a forks a4 yeah knight a4 the
idea of capturing the rook on f6 by king
is seven which is quite pretty
that is a visual you
you got your hand caught in the cookie
jar there i mean oops but the reason i
bring this up is that in the opposition
after
for king of fade
once the king leaves the e8 square in
particular i think the temptation to to
actually pick that pawn up and create
pop
problems for of
for black
after all the trades happen because here
after knight a4 i can play something
like maybe rook d7 maybe c5 followed by
rook d7 you know exploiting the fact
that king knows in particular i'm very
i'm very attracted to the idea of you
know pushing the bishop on c4 and
exerting pressure against the pawns on
the king's side nice
black as i mentioned black often holds
these types of positions but not without
having to be quite precise okay
uh and we're being told that the move g3
after a frequency seven which near just
sayed is a novelty
uh
all of these things kind of flow into
each other i think g frequency seven is
one of the main lines so you can say a3
is another way uh in a reasonably well
known position but yeah
this one i'm very much i very much like
the look of this because this might be a
very interesting game to follow okay we
will and
lastly uh what is white's
um
what's the point of g3 of black
i was wondering i was wondering about
that because are you doing something
funky like bishop g2 well the king on b8
it doesn't really yeah bishop g2 f4
might be uh might be one plan
uh if uh
no but that really all of those things
only really work with the bishop on d3 i
just want to show you one tactic which
which often uh well not often but which
does sometimes sometimes work in this
position let's say we go instead of g3
we go bishop d3
okay and black castles uh coincide okay
uh here at least the possibility exists
of playing c4
uh knight b6
and c5 this works better in some
positions than worsens like in knight
takes e5
we've made a little bit too many uh
unnecessary moves here so this this will
not work as as nicely as it does in some
other positions but but this is one of
the ways of exploiting the
soft pin along the h4 d8 diagonal and
also the file that black has a lot of
heavy pieces on the c file but for this
you need to have the bishop on d3
because otherwise obviously
tempo against the green so yeah i'm very
much wondering what the intention is
after long costs by the way just like 10
or 20 moves down the road to be like yes
a3 this was the reason
this move
baffles me i i get it it's an engine
move and there must be some reasoning
behind it but
i'm trying to figure out in which
configuration this move a3
makes our position superior yeah
and again a whole tempo in the opening
being
used for making look one of the things
that you just did peter by the way and
uh thank you for doing that big shout
out to the audience because this is
really a nice
insight
as a
grand master one of the things i was
always working on in my openings was to
try to try to
understand all the tactics the patterns
the tactical patterns that i have to be
aware of as well as the end games that
i'm going to transition to so those
tactics which you just mentioned c4 c5 i
mean they really stand out in the
position something that both players
have to have an awareness of when
they're castling long um
interesting game and for me uh lanier
this is really a game he's got to win
alejandro i mean lanier is white he's
against the lower rated player but
deoc has been feasting on the fact that
people are coming after him yeah you
know we there's only there's only so
many times we can use the you know under
the
lower rated underdog when somebody is on
plus one of the five rounds exactly
having had more blacks than whites as
well
exactly
into round six yeah
the reason he is on plus one is a gift
he was given from from reporter but that
wasn't the full point gift he defended
really really well in that game and the
game would have ended in a draw if
reheart had not slightly lost his mind
on more 40. exactly i mean 50 in this
field is you know a lot of people in
this field don't have fifty percent that
is true including uh ali reza and i
thought that uh alireza was going to
actually win that game uh when he was a
piece up
against yeah he also he also
defended very tenaciously after getting
out played yesterday by the resident and
held that game as well exactly uh yeah
i'm very curious what will happen here
because it does seem like uh
linear is trying something kind of new
and unusual in that line playing
extremely slowly giving black all this
time to finish development whichever way
they they want and there is one game we
haven't shown at all so far so perhaps
time to let's have a look at list once
and that's the game between shakhliar
and alireza and this is a very heavily
theoretical nimzo
which they're called nimzo quincy ii
with c5
and then i don't know if i
am right to call this like the roman
nation variation where you kind of
fianchetto your bishop uh uh on g2
um
but okay i know that this is actually
very topical too i mean we've seen we've
been seeing some tough games yeah it's
it kind of stays topical throughout the
ages i mean the line has been in
existence for for a very very long time
and
already we're seeing i think very much
an influence i i don't want to oversell
it but it feels to me that the last two
moves that ereza played here
are
the you know he's on minus one because
this line forever and ever has been
basically you take on c3 with the knight
here
white goes bc you go [ __ ] b7 e4 d6
white goes e5 g5 knight e5
and
you make yeah you make some precise
moves you probably you know have to
defend the slightly annoying and game
you go and i just i think how does it go
it goes
uh
i think seven which probably should be
sixteen two nine this seven like that
right yeah i think this is how it goes
gabi's before bishop d6 queen e2
97 white goes like rookie one or
something and
all knight takes d7 and it's a
long-winded line but at the end of the
day
it's oftentimes an even yeah it's
supposed to be it's supposed to be a
draw but there's there's been some
attempts and people occasionally lose
this with black but generally speaking
joy is heavily heavily favored there uh
after all this happens and instead
lereza chooses to take the bishop and
goku in c7 which is
i think a lot riskier strategically
speaking but also has a much higher
chance of creating a position in which
he might down the road have some winning
chances
an indication that he's minus one yeah
and this is where the minus one comes in
because i think i think like i
i would expect him to actually know how
to equalize that other position quite
well yeah because it's a very very you
know well-known staple of uh
to uh
nimza
but he's choosing to keep it uh he's
choosing to keep it a much more fighting
game so far and
we salute him for it absolutely i don't
know how well it will you know work out
for him we'd absolutely salute the
choice
exactly uh definitely you know
a game that we're going to take a look
at keep a careful line out pardon me and
a lifetime score uh
not much in it one game one game one
game which has been actually won by
alireza i'm not entirely sure i remember
where that was but
um yeah
he is still obviously he will play
dozens of games against the top players
over the course of his career but he's
just starting out so you see those those
kind of weird looking uh graphics for
somebody who is 2800 or at least used to
be 2800 before the tournament started
um by the way shaq
for at least from that posture seems to
ali razim might be like
well i've got him to think yeah i mean
that's a that's a good uh
good sign uh for absolutely yeah just i
was just looking in the positions two
two ideas for black that pop to my mind
uh that black wants to do i yes i want
to take the pawn and maybe shut down the
bishop but another thing i could do is
with my queen on c7 is i can try to
neutralize this long diagonal by playing
b7 b6 bishop b7 when uh again
yeah
but it's yeah if i could get that in
it's like marvelous i mean i've got
everything going now i i would much
prefer that actually to winning the ball
on c4 exactly what usb6 bishop
and nothing bad happened by that point
you're better you're better with black
and quite significantly exactly so moves
forward here yeah e3 is probably not one
yeah bishop before maybe but i don't
quite know why we're provoking the 76
which seems like a move that black
doesn't really hate making either that
was the other thing that i was going to
say if you don't like b7 b6
d6 e5 and bishop e6 and that exactly
solid so i couldn't really find the
follow-up and there is no immediate if
there is no immediate follow-up you
don't play bishop before rooney one is a
move 94 relaxable
94 i was also wondering maybe
g5 is a move but knight g5 i think black
just goes like if the trade happens i'm
reasonably happy but i don't think you
trade i think you go knight c5
you just hang and and ask ask why
exactly why is this why is it on g5 and
what this is i understand that if you
don't get made on h7
it does look rather aimless um
okay 94 is perhaps the most forcing it
probably provokes d75 i would assume
but d5 looks very healthy
um
it it kind of puts puts the puts a cork
in the plans of you know occupying the
long diagonal with the bishop and using
the two weaknesses on the c file i've
got a great idea let's invite love
alejandro into the discussion here
alejandro do we have some theory of
queen c7
and knight d4 let me start there queen
c7 has been played before there are some
games in this position so it's not
unknown of course as you mentioned peter
knight takes c3 is much much more common
but we have had this position before
almost always white does choose the move
knight d4 it does as you mentioned
tickle the knight and the knight is
centralized unlike the variations with
the knight on g5 and almost always black
plays the move d5 there's really nothing
else in this position and after for
example takes on d5 takes on d5 bishop
f4 it's the engine is saying that the
move queen c5 is the most precise and
the black still holds equality in this
position
that being said i look at this and i
think white is just slightly better
compared to every other variation that
you get in this type of structures you
get the pair of bishops instead of just
one you get the dark square control it
might not be very much no but it's still
a little something i think that if you
were to give
white players a choice of starting in
this position or playing d4 and move one
this is not so bad you get some chances
it's not yeah it's playable it's a kind
of a weirdly ragosan
a regular type
position uh another game that i want to
take a look at is this one between mvl
and levon as we've already had a lot
going on on this one and i think we kind
of either glossed over didn't really
talk about it because then we all
started with d4
which he's really been switching
he doesn't do this and he has been doing
it these days levon playing a vienna
variation here with the move bishop b4
and c5 ins
in this position and we're going to go
down what is a pretty topical line but
not so much nowadays takes knight takes
d4 bishop takes c3 check pawn takes c3
queen a5 this has already been worked
out many many times bishop b5 check is
the main move in this position don't
play bishop f6 like many people have
done before it's actually a big mistake
you have to throw your bishop
there so that on bishop f6 queen c3 you
can actually take on f6 in this position
right i i think it's yeah actually uh
taking and taking hero on f6 it has been
played recently uh quesad3 i think is
still the main line but gf6 has
gain in popularity i would say it's
surging but i never thought there was
anything actually wrong with the move
queen c3 except that perhaps some of the
positions that you got were only
theoretically okay and annoying to play
with the black pieces and i've actually
analyzed this position quite a bit after
king f1 gf h4 tons of games like this
but here mvl
pulled a levon
he played the move king e2
instead of the move king f1
and i am not familiar with this move
at all and
no king of one is like
hundreds of games
yeah yeah this one is hundreds of games
i have not seen king e2 there seem to be
some relatively older games here in the
database uh
shout out to grand master libovich he
has essay this a couple of times but the
engines are not in love with it and
perhaps it's specifically with this move
queen b2 check now you could transpose
back to the other lines with king f1 gf
rook b1 uh it kind of goes into the same
variations but he played it in a
completely different style instead just
exchanging the queens here with the move
queen d2 queen takes king takes gf6 and
then rook ac1 and now we have this end
game where if you count them
black is up a pawn
he does have some problems in finishing
up his development as you see white is
much better developed than black is his
king is still in the center you have
some problems with your structure this
rook might hint that it's coming to c7
the issue is that black's position is
very very solid there's not really
anything clear that you can attack even
the move rook c7 not only does it very
often get mad with king d8 but very
often it doesn't do anything the rook
looks very pretty on c7 but if i can get
this knight out of the way then you're
simply attacking a pawn on b7 that's
very well defended to give you a sample
variation castle's rook c7 doesn't
really do very much you can even put the
rook on d8 start harassing white on the
d file and yes you have compensation but
is it enough
uh after the move rook ac1 levon is
currently thinking he spent almost no
time getting to this position it was
actually maxime that spent 20 minutes to
get here but he finds himself in an end
game down a pawn
certainly compensation but
everything i know about this variation
of the vienna before i looked at it with
the engine says black needs to be okay
in this position or the vienna would
just not exist absolutely yeah i'm very
very surprised and also uh
i saw this position on my screen and i
was about to remark on it but
on my screen i didn't see the times and
getting here with one 111 as we can see
on our screen right now means that
yeah
it's it's slightly mystifying what mvl
is doing here because
it's a position you expect them to have
135 yeah and live on 110.
because it doesn't
like as you said if this is worse for
blacks the entire opening is completely
unplayable uh which
we assume is basically isn't really the
case right and uh
yeah this this switch from one e4 to one
g4
it obviously i mean it presents problems
i've done this in my career i used to be
an exclusively a 1 e4 player and then at
some point i realized i still have no
idea what to do against the petrov and
and some other openings berlin and the
very yeah
the partial kind of here it is so i i
tried turning myself into an
ambidextrous player but yeah there's
obviously
so many issues trying to learn like the
entire body of theory
yeah and here you see we kind of made
references to it
and this is only their match-ups in
classical chess if you start to include
their rapid and blitz matchups you might
as alejandro men should be closer to 100
games against one another but near 40 on
classical chess that's a lot of games
that is a lot of a lot of games you know
definitely one of the uh you know
classicals of the current
of the current chess world uh they do
they don't know each other really really
well but yeah it seems like uh the
transition from from 184 to 1d4 is not
working smoothly every single time for
mvl here i'd also like to turn our
attention to the game of
wesley so for just a moment in his game
against richard rapport one of the
things about this
semi-slov
you know
most often i i'm used to seeing ideas of
b5 bishop b5 b4 bishop b7 and c5 and if
you don't like those apples then i'm
used to seeing queen e7 and e5 ideas and
naturally after a6 the the game takes a
completely different turn as we kind of
go into a queen's gambit accepted
isolated coupon yeah
that type of territory at least yeah
absolutely yeah and it's we're caught up
with the players now i think it's
understandable because uh when black
plays a6 there if we go back to that
moment i think a6 is a very useful move
here because
it
maintains all of our options open i
think if you don't play for black very
very happily we'll go b5 and c5 this is
what a6 is mainly about
it is trying to trying to prepare the
move b5
so that you can play c5 immediately
without the opponent b5 hanging and also
not committing to anything just yet and
having provoked a4 i think black
reasonably happily transposed into those
structures by playing 65 tempo up
provoked the weakening of the b4 square
which seems kind of irrelevant now but
might become useful later but also
whether or not the b4 square is it
certainly is useful to have a65
absolutely yeah much more useful move
and after rook d1 queen c7 i kind of
like it's not usual in isolated queen
pond sometimes your queen gets kind of
stuck on the
e2 square or maybe the c2 square maybe
the d3 square uh it's kind of feels nice
h4 is one of the one of the best squares
um
structures i think yeah and the capture
unleashing a tempo and now please take
my pawn
uh wesley is saying like with this white
will have tremendous compensation here
it probably probably is borderline
unplayable for black eyes exactly it
looks very very dangerous to take on e3
nobody yeah i i've been i've been
starved off of opportunities to use this
term so i will use it again yeah i'm
very much drawn to this marshall yes
this marshall is a very good martial
precisely this is what i wanted to ask
you about alejandro alejandra is very
upset with me probably because it's not
really such a great marshall to be
honest we're probably lacking a tempo to
here this is another martial
all we have is one hammer everything's
at nail all we have is the marshall
gambit everything turns into a marshall
looks like a marshall to me yeah but the
the
to slightly explain my silliness here
these types of compensation where black
has the pair of bishops upon down in the
center somewhere but a very open
position with files for the rooks
diagonals for the bishops honestly if if
the pawn was already on h6 here that
would make sense i would be very
comfortably saying that is completely
fine but the fact that knight g5 is
being quite seriously threatened and
you're annoying it's annoying me quite a
bit yeah i feel like maybe we're one
temple short here if i could just play
bishop d7 okay e8 here
i would i would very seriously argue
that you know there's really not very
much to worry about that there's
happiness going on or if you could just
play rookie eight in this moment
the rook
uh so having said all of this it means
you're not taking the pawn on e3 because
as you said your borderline lost that's
probably another statement
i'm i wouldn't want to defend black's
position myself i mean 95.
h7 is a strong move i was
that was not an overstatement
no what it
is yeah the bishop e3 is plus two plus
two very nice yeah
so i mean again that the first instinct
is like let's shut down white
i want to get rid of all of this yeah i
don't want to get mated but i have bad
memories of uh iqp positions of the
queen and h4 but if you did uh genuinely
fear the knight g5 and you can actually
spend a tempo on h6 here it's not going
to be horrible but i get a feeling we
don't really equalize with tempo wise
like php3 rook ac1
it's going to get annoying it's going to
get
you know white will be the the first
ones to start harassing our pieces here
a little exactly
it's much less attractive if you're also
behind on behind on development right
but i'm kind of struggling to figure out
what you're supposed to play there
because
it takes d4 and bishop g5 is coming
extremely quickly in the current
position yeah i'm dreaming of a rook a
rover 95 rook to g3 instant attack or
something like that and that's not so
instant actually uh back over to you
alejandro take a take a crack at this
will you please take a look at the
greats actually a shout out first to
russian grandmasters viaginsev he's the
one that introduced this idea into chess
and gary saw that game gary kasparov
used it with the black pieces against
luke van welley and thought black is
completely okay in this position even
though it looks a little bit scary with
the move h6 how to play this move if you
don't have your opening preparation on
board both ed bishop h6 and e4 look very
scary actually in that game between luke
manuel and gary kasparov e4 happened and
knight d7 a cool common collected move
actually moving the night away from the
king side but remember bishop h6 was a
threat because the knight was hanging on
f6 so now you just move it out of the
way and you challenge white to take on
f6 which is exactly what luke did bishop
takes h6 takes rook ac1 this must have
been some kind of home preparation by
both players queen takes f4 h6 bishop f4
is insufficient but after queen d8 queen
takes h6 queen f6 this is the only way
to defend the king side takes takes e5
this fork on the e5 square secures
material equality for white the engines
are saying that the resulting endgame is
just about equal gary ended up winning
that game in the end game in the long
term but it could be either side's game
that being said playing h6 without
knowing exactly what's going on on the
on the a with an engine is very very
scary the engines are saying the best
second best idea is to give up this pawn
in a specific martial style compensation
and that's what he's done actually
already and i'm not surprised i think
it's a little bit more of a human way of
playing if we can take a look at
that position and
i think that the follow-up is going to
be very important how is richie going to
follow up his pawn sacrifice in that
position after e5 e4 because takes takes
takes is kind of forced
yeah this will happen
you don't really have another choice but
to take on e4s black otherwise why did
you sacrifice a pawn
and then
what do you play because h6 bishops
somewhere
very very feels slow
yeah but i don't think you're gonna
allow them
i think about to find out because knight
g5 is on tap
and
yeah i'm not a big fan of queen e7
because yeah i was about to swing e7
bishop b7 bishop f4 or even bishop
bishop f4 i like and the pawn gets to go
to d6
i don't know how he does it right pawn
up not really a full pawn but one day it
becomes a full pawn you know
bishop end game and then wesley tortures
his opponent for 30 moves right and then
richard cracks have we seen this story
before
uh we may have we may have we have
indeed and again uh this unfortunately
the
the very desirable
is just very strong and he's found a
very good move this is by far the top
move by the engine it solves a lot of
the problems that you guys were
mentioning this move queen d7
prepping
both rookie eight
prepping queen f5 as a response to
knight g5 that's that's quite a visual
what do we what do we play against
before i guess we go queen g4 and then
take on e5 right do we play rookie eight
bishop f4 forces you to occupy the east
yeah well i'm i'm okay with playing 95
in this position aren't i and then queen
of five and now queen f5 was um that is
a very good solo
yeah
but let's uh go to bucharest and check
in with christian christian what do you
have for us my friend
thank you uh yeah sir well actually i
was listening to you guys and you are
talking uh greatly about all the games
and i went to the playing hall tried to
gauge uh the emotions of the players
this is what i was looking for i was
trying to understand where they stand in
that regard also it feels like right now
is kind of the first critical moment of
the round after the opening preparation
has finished and right now finally
they're starting to assess which one
came on top which player came on top
after the opening phase and i just want
to start with this game that you guys
were focusing on the one between wesley
and richie rapport and actually report i
was looking at him and after this move
bishop to d3 which was played quite
quickly instantaneously i might add by
wesley so he started thinking and he was
he seemed a little bit confused he
wasn't sure whether wesley knows exactly
what he's doing we
see that wesley had one hour in 21
minutes so he wasn't blitzing out every
single move up to this point but after
this queen to h4 take on d4 and bishop
to d3 he started playing extremely
extremely quickly so he's definitely
aware of some of the stem games in this
variation but i have to say richie
definitely played the most principled
moves if i followed by e4 and i was
wondering because i didn't have any
engine i was looking at the games from
the playing halls spectators all over
all over myself and i i could see
richard calculating e5 v4 you're going
to take the two bishops you're going to
have yourself the two bishops and where
is white's attack and this is exactly
what he's wondering but right now after
queen to d7 okay sure maybe white is no
longer going to have an attack on the
king's side but this d-pawn is extremely
extremely powerful and if i manage to
exchange the dark square bishop um for
white with bishop to f4 of course i have
to make some space for my queen right
now bishop to f4 doesn't work
immediately because of rook two e8 but
once i played d5 queen to d4 centralize
everything it seems like white has an
easier play in at this position another
game that i was um looking at was the
one between mvl and levon levon blitzed
out every single move and we know that
mvl well usually he's an e4 player not a
1d4 player so he wasn't really aware
perhaps of uh what he was doing
specifically in this opening
nevertheless i have to say right now he
is upon down and we are that is with the
white pieces but he does have a lot of
compensation with that being said i
don't think it's enough compensation
for more than equality nevertheless
after levon aronian put some pressure on
the on envious time at the beginning now
the tide has turned a little bit and we
are played a couple of fast moves and i
could see levon trying to understand
where he has to put his pieces what his
defensive mechanism in this position is
because okay he's underdeveloped for the
moment so this one is going to be very
very interesting uh to look at and
another one which seemed a little bit
imbalanced at least uh from a
psychological point of view was this
clash the big clash between fabiano and
annepo and i have to say it seems like a
lot of players are testing for whatever
reason fabiano in the petrov um we saw
in nepal right now we saw mamatijarov a
couple of days ago i'm not really sure
why they're testing because to be honest
fabiano is one of the top experts with
white and with the black pieces in the
petrov this one is going to be very
interesting to see nevertheless i do see
that nepo and by the way he seemed very
confident from what i was seeing him
walking around the playing hall um
staring a little bit that fabiano trying
to understand where he stands in terms
of his opening preparation fabiano that
is this one very interesting but i have
to say i will give the opening battle a
victory for jan in this one why do you
guys have your eyes on in this first
critical moment of round number one
well thank you christian for that
breakdown for me actually i'm i'm
looking across all the tables i'm kind
of enjoying everything that's going on
after the move a g2 g3 by lanier
uh diac
you know we were talking about well how
do you meet this you can castle long and
peter you were pointing out c4 c5 types
of possibilities and uh yeah
well i look i'm a pawn up i know you're
c4
c4 bishop takes f6 variations can win
you the pawn back yeah i'm going to
defend the pawn yeah put me what you got
protects the pawn on the d6 and uh in
terms of the potential plans for black
to kind of disentangle themselves knight
b6 followed by the 6d5 is one way of uh
starting to at least do something dream
come true yeah you you can't really in
some positions you can play knight h7
but i don't know if that's one of them
uh
if white does nothing at all like if you
don't play if you don't play h4 here you
make some kind of an additional slow
move i think i would be somewhat
attracted to the move knight h7 actually
because it allows black to at least you
know try to trade some pieces and i
think you kind of you welcome uh the the
champions kind of dream come true having
said all that i think uh bishop h6 might
be a good response
not allowing any trades
can is still keeping black's king stuck
in the center and i wanted to mention
that if i really wanted to trade the
bishop on g5 i could i could play knight
g8 but knight g8 is just such an ugly
move i'm not going to mention it
i'm not going to mention it seriously
instead of knight h7 so rook d8 uh balls
back in lanier's court and yeah
alejandro what's your take
and you can't help but notice but for
the first time
probably a half year
his chess playing career lanier's ahead
of the clock which is nobody believes
you that's a good sign you know he's a
very theoretically well prepared player
the problem is this the moment that he's
out of theory and his opponent has
played a move that doesn't really
resonate with his patterns
then he goes into the tank right this is
the situations where he spends 20 30
minutes trying to understand the
position trying to really get his chest
culture up there do i play h4 do i play
f4 what are the ramifications of
everything there's so much to look at in
this position is it's a fascinating
position especially without the use of
an engine right right you know the ideas
you know more or less where the struggle
is lying but how to exactly execute it
that's not so easy and linear loves
thinking about these positions i think
he loves thinking in general yeah
sorry i was going to say yeah currently
he is 20 minutes up but
i would not be surprised to see him have
like 22 minutes by move 20
exactly
um
i'm going to take us back to the game of
mvl and levon for a moment because we've
been talking about this pawn sacrifice i
see a great deal of activity
and we say yeah white has compensation
but does that compensation mean he has
an advantage yes or no
there's also the practical side of chess
too which is
your opponents uh on the back foot
having to defend
constantly and to neutralize these yeah
i'm not sure how much how much defending
is actually going on here okay the thing
that annoyed me the most out of this
variation when i played it with white
was creating a threat it just felt like
you were playing with five pieces your
opponent was playing with two
and you still couldn't attack anything
that's what really annoyed me about this
position like for example white already
has a nice rook on c7 you can even bring
a rook to whatever open file you feel
like bringing it to rook
rook a1 c1 and and so many off in so
many cases when this is true when you
have all of your pieces together
tactics always work out for the side
that has better development right and
the
specific position of this pieces in this
particular line of the vienna always
made it seem like black had just as many
resources even with an undeveloped
position for example rook hc1 f5 f5 it's
already difficult to meet
yeah i thought the idea was to go e5 but
that five was even stronger yeah yeah
and the idea is oops don't walk into my
knight fork
and furthermore don't walk into f4 for
check is also a huge big threat yeah and
you're threatening just to take on e4
and then go
ninety-five yeah
in this particular case i mean
knight d5 check is going to rock my
world king takes i think takes actually
lose material to f5 but you might
actually get self mated this way like
king e5 king of six hello nigel yeah
exactly walk our king into uh the lion's
mouth uh okay uh so we do have knight b6
on the board but as you were talking not
just about this position in in general
but it's sort of like as white
you want to be able to play f4 and g4
and h4 and g5 i don't know expand on the
on the king side
how should i do it peter or
am i allowed to do it
let's say i play g4 just yeah i think i
think just to put a move on the board
yeah g4 that does seem like a very
useful move specifically because it very
much softens the blow of f605 as well as
maybe e5 i mean both of those yeah
because maybe maybe you can still play
e5 by the way you can even still play f5
yeah you can even play play five but my
point is oh yeah this is the thing that
annoys me about this variation that
because like f5 is playable it should
lose of course it should of course it
should lose gf emu rook g1 and i expect
that a couple of moves for now my
opponent will resign because i'm hating
him right but you really aren't and you
really aren't you not only really aren't
but what do you play
again f5 f4 check is a threat capturing
the pawn is
uh taboo
knight d5 simply wins this is a
difficult decision to take over the
board though for black i want to point
out that
bishop d7 simply is also a much more
sort of restraint here because
yeah i mean i do win my pawn back but no
i don't actually there's a check on e5
uh check on c4 yeah
it gets very awkward very quickly with
the king on e3 and the royal pg2 next
move like you you take black here
without that you know
too much shadow of a doubt yeah and uh
yeah that was also what i wanted to say
uh uh
after after the the christian segment
uh when we spoke to us to friends in
bucharest that
i just don't disagree with this this
entire narrative about levon looking for
ways to defend against the
the sacrifice i think lujan is slightly
confused why this is
happening but he also has by this point
counted the pawns
and is playing an endgame with an extra
pawn very carefully counter
where he thinks okay maybe i will not be
able to convert it into a full point but
i don't think you know defending and
securing a draw here is very high on his
agenda i think he is just kind of happy
surprised but happy
about how the opening came out is there
anything to be said for
shooting
kind of like a cue ball shot five four
f5
yeah and the moment you give up the
control of d7 yeah work d7 also run the
7xz7 location i
it's still playable for y but mainly i
think it doesn't defend against the 504
which is a very
uh underrated threat i when i saw 9b6 i
assumed the idea was to play 5b6 right
and to decent this disincentivize knight
to 5 by having the 95 check after the
trade exactly but yeah 5 is just a much
much stronger idea in general
um even though e5 b6 in some positions
will be quite sensible actually but
five is just
a threat whereas e5 is an idea
so this is this is
awkward this is what's awkward to me
about this position how come we're
talking about blacks threats black
threads blacks threats when we're white
and we're upon down we're wide we're
pawn down we're better developed
it's just such a bizarre end game this
this thing has always been bizarre to me
since i started studying it many years
ago when i became a grandmaster because
everybody's played this at some point in
their lives i think it is this structure
where you're down a pawn and you're
playing against this king awkwardly
between g8 and e7
and it just seemed that it was dangerous
for black it was certainly more
dangerous with the queen son that you
felt that if black got the queen's off
that your advantage or possibilities of
an advantage certainly slipped but then
you should have compensation
somewhere it's not so clear and this is
one of those end games where
i the logic of the position says this
looks like a groom field where you gave
up a pawn and you got your pieces active
and suddenly you have a great deal of
play maybe even playing for an advantage
not so not the case it feels that black
is the one that has all of the resources
in this position
and i'm very curious on what maxim is
going to bring to the table
thank you alejandro and as we prepare
ourselves for a great peter uh which is
yeah we have a very exciting and
legitimately a very very exciting item
to show for you today in our q boutique
segment
that's good i i've seen a shot of it
earlier and yeah there there we go is it
isn't that something probably yeah this
is the uh unique concave board crafted
from walnut maple that feature chessmen
with weighted rounded bottoms that
wobble freely
pieces feature chrome accents and
the king is five inches high but mainly
just look at this picture
aren't they aren't they cute party set
for some reason they stopped wobbling
though this is very disturbing they
should wobble constantly exactly forever
thank you
thank you there we go we've got to give
it a good wobble good shake and as we
prepare for break we asked our players
what's it like for them uh playing in
romania
these are their answers and we'll see on
the other side of our break
[Music]
we are back in bucharest romania with
the first leg of the granchester the
super bad chess classic what are your
thoughts on this event and how does it
feel to be playing here in bucharest
yeah it's going to be exciting i mean
i'm very glad to be here back here in
romania
i am very grateful to the sponsors for
having this uh
and it's a new start it's a new season
it's a very strong tournament with all
the top players we'll see how it goes
so yeah this is for me a new experience
i i like visiting new places actually
it's
you know i always feel like uh going
from tournament to tournament pretty
much playing the same players and
everything it kind of gets boring you
fall into the same pattern same routine
so i like at least that there's for me
at least a new environment and
even though the players are pretty much
the same right this can
this can make it interesting and
yeah i'm looking forward to it of course
it's very nice we're good to back
again i i played here in bucharest only
one time and i played very good
tournament
it's not easy tournament is every chess
player come win this tournament and for
this reason
to play good
it will be not easy but we all will try
yeah i was always watching it
from
live from home on
previous years i think it's a very well
organized tournament
and it's a very top tournament and also
very tough
so i think it's great to be here in
romania i heard a lot of good things
about this country and i was always i've
always wanted to visit here
so
i look forward to the tournament and i
try and do my best
i feel good
i must say that last time i was pretty
sick for the duration of the event so
that was not a great experience only
because of that because otherwise things
are i've been organized
at very high standards so i was
definitely looking forward to
to be back here and my shape
at least i'm not feeling sick at all so
it should be very good i've been coming
to bucharest since early 90s great city
and a city that
i love being in yeah and now i have many
friends here so i really
enjoy the old town and
generally the whole city and
it's love towards chess
well first time here in romania and
obviously i'm very happy to be you know
back on track and play first classical
event since
whatever november and december
yeah it's my first time visiting romania
it's always nice
to visit new places as a chess player
that's one of the pluses
the best players in the world come back
in romania it's
very good for romanian cheese in romania
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round six of
the super bad chess classic the first uh
the first tournament of the gcc to 2022
and here are your standings before the
run started with wesley in clear first
and chocolatier and player last and the
field's still very very tightly punched
together with uh well
plenty to play for in last four rounds
yeah with four of the four of the
candidates players there as you see
being in the bottom half of the
tournament
only ian and uh
bobby
yeah who are playing each other today
and uh
uh plenty plenty of very very
interesting positions on the boards uh
so let's maybe start with that game that
we just brought up the game between uh
jan and uh
and fabi because five just made a very
curious choice there i've been trying to
uh to calculate some things there we
left it after knight b3
jan made the most obvious perhaps moving
the position castles knight c5 queen c8
you may perhaps ask yourself why not
knight takes b7 in this position after
queen c8 but i think there's a couple of
reasons the simplest being that
obviously not quite sb7 queen takes a 5
but knight before is very strong there i
it took me a while to realize the move
even existed but knight before actually
uh kicks the queen away from attacking
the
knight on the f5 and then we can uh
pick up the knight on b7 at our
uh leisure uh so that doesn't quite work
qmp3 probably doesn't lose the game but
we are not fighting for currently
exactly it's so fab we played bishop
four and bishop four looks like a very
very logical move but it's actually
somewhat remarkable because you do have
knight of five takes d4 here exactly i
was thinking that well the only thing
protecting the knight on c5 is the pawn
on d4 and if i kick
that pawn out from underneath
and also uh
phobia is down to 38 minutes in a petrov
by mu 14 with white which is quite quite
a night of default already played by jan
by the way i'm pretty sure he wants 94
knight of five he clearly hasn't
blundered that takes d4 it's the only
tactic in the position
uh i'm pretty sure he wants neither five
here it is upon sacrifice yeah but it is
before again
that is that is a curiosity knight h6
check though but
i don't trust this i feel like it
shouldn't work are you playing for a win
after gh maybe i am but the gh is not
for us i think we can go king h8 here gh
queen g3 check
uh
king h8 bishop thank you
we have queen c3 check when we need it
yeah but bishop h6 check is also a
legitimately scary move because rouge 88
queen e5 is
made i was thinking bishop takes h6 we
do have bishop t yeah but then i want to
take on the fate and play c3 and claim
that i'm maybe winning yeah probably
probably winning yeah but do you think
h6 is completely unforced you can play
uh you can play a king h8 first wait for
you to put the choose a square for the
queen and then proceed accordingly
and queen g8 check is illegal right um
yeah and jack would be quite strong here
but uh
i don't know what i'm chasing yeah but
the thing is i'm not sure what your
threat is exactly right right a 7b6 here
for example followed by f6 and then like
put my knight on h6 for a pawn yeah i've
done it for a purpose but just a second
hold on so we
this is our current game position
with fabi to play
b3 you do have knight b3 but it's just
such a sad move to make even if it does
win all that yeah it takes takes quincy
three i just want to make sure that well
even here i'm not
yeah first of all you know you haven't
actually won the phone back yeah i
missed queen bishop v6 i was going to
say bishop b6 i'm nowhere near like i'm
never worse there with it i agree with
that maybe but maybe we have better
words maybe maybe we're better yeah
so it's very confusing so knight f5
looks like the right move you went night
before we went knight h6 quickly to
three maybe yeah quickly i mean h3 yeah
i keep on missing things i mean well no
i'm still
i for me the jury's out only that you
don't have g6 because i do have that
shack and queen cedar we can start with
f6 maybe yeah and then try to try the
most comfortable now i'm beginning to uh
believe in the pawn sacrifices h6 or
rookie one rookie one let's say go lego
rook f7 if i get rook of seven bishop
fade there will never be anything
significant happening on the king's side
yeah rookie six does exist yeah that's
very it's still a bishop
yeah i think we're past the point where
we were before before rookie one yeah
can i try f6 something like c3 or a3 i'm
not sure which one but let's try c3
so queen h3 f6 yes uh alejandro yeah c3
i just want to kick out your yeah knight
six yeah
before yeah that makes it honest where
does the bishop go because
d6 knight d7 i want to play but 97 you
have my h6 check but i'm not that
unhappy about it
i think knight e7
feels like you do have to play knight h6
check because everything else makes no
sense i will take you play queen g3
check i go i don't know
king of seven rook g8 or something yeah
i like i like being f7
it's a strange position very disbalanced
weird position right for um but before
we get too concerned
i want to say that night before is by no
means forest it's basically i like clean
ignored the fact that financially
existed i legitimately thought we were
kind of winning the piece there
i want to point yeah first of all this i
wanted to point out that my original
idea was just to play queen d7 and kind
of uh ask what is all the the fuss about
it but bishop h6 might be quite
interesting
even though the game still very much
continues i have knight e5 g6 as a reply
for instance and who knows what's going
on 95 queen g3 good knight g6 i force
you to take with the knight and then
maybe i can use it somehow but maybe not
yeah because it comes out to h5 that's a
good pond yeah yeah yeah it comes out to
h5 the position i mean the game
continues i can play a five knight h5
rook f7 and claim that
not that much has been lost but
obviously black should should be aiming
for more than this i would say i think
this is quite happy for white
uh by the way the the time you we we
were talking about fabi spending a lot
of clock
on the sacrifice that's quite remarkable
actually yeah 34 versus an hour and 22
minutes basically we've that's a big
decision
nepa of playing quickly but this is
really it's really something remarkable
sorry i'm taking advantage of the fact
that this is a critical choice for fabi
right knight b3 it feels like a bailout
but i can't believe white's too much
worse
i'm taking black after bishop b6 i agree
i take black that's the thing knight v3
mission b6 you don't feel like you've
equalized with the white pieces like
queen g4 here is quite annoying for
instance but maybe you equalize with
queen like you have to beg a little bit
queen g5 maybe
but it is it is five against five
extremely symmetrical hard to imagine
we're doing that poorly or six versus
six it's just where you wanna think
about livelihoods yeah i don't wanna
yeah yeah we might be threes just
a move
no no no no no they like like you say
you're you're playing for
equality you sacrificed upon and you
just have to play the position like
you've sacrificed the pawn for the
initiative yeah let's see it again
knight f5 so
by the way i thought you'll move night
before was very
it's very concrete yeah it's very
concrete but
that's a nice word but i don't maybe not
that great though i don't know if it's
required yeah after alejandro's maybe
actually rook d8
to prepare to play bishop fades straight
away
because i really like the idea of
getting the bishop to fa2 to
make sure my king's side is under yeah
during the world championship match uh
of dubai it was really impressive how
the world champion magnus just put his
bishop on f8 told
nepo you can't kill me and nepo did not
kill him in fact so i like this concept
very much
i think returning to the current
position phibi would hate hate hate to
play knight b3 yes but if you can't make
knight of five work at all i think you
you you know the deep feelings of shame
and understanding
you do play knight b3 and you do you
like
i'm sorry you apologize to your fans
yeah you go to the confession and said i
i was scared
um jump right in alejandra does the
engine say knight f5 and wins
the engine has no shame and it says it's
time
it's time to go knight b3
and after bishop b6 whoops i don't know
where the bishop went there bishop b6
queen takes a d5
both h6 and queen g4 do give black an
advantage that i think is much more
sizable than i would have thought so
thinking that after queen g5 takes takes
a5
black's actually significantly better
with a clear advantage in this position
a4 is kind of an issue you would think
that a4 is not such a big deal but the
engines keep the pressure i think rook
feat rookie two coming still retains
some initiative for black perhaps still
within the drawing range but not a fun
position the problem with the move
uh
knight f5 that we've seen is precisely
this move rook d8 that you've guys
finally figured out rookie 8 is not
playable because d5 is hanging the move
queen d7 has the the problem with bishop
h6 as we mentioned uh knight e5
is playable but it doesn't force queen
g3 actually move queen h3 slightly more
unpleasant
in this position i'm not really sure how
the tactics work out here but they do
and
rookie one yeah guest rookie one yeah
rookie one yeah and the idea is rook d8
in this position for black it's just
really strong you don't have a good
follow-up the move queen h3 does nothing
you can pretty much do anything 94
already trades uh pieces and how do you
really
coordinate your people okay you won yes
the the logical follow-up but the
problem is that what was more useful
right rook theater rook a1 and so many
of these variations for example queen d7
my queen's already defended bishop f8 i
already defended my king side so let's
put the move bishop f8 immediately and
again this was a nice move what what's
your next one because i'm starting to
get out of my my shell right queen d7 is
going to come at some point 97 or
something to trade off the pieces g6
maybe if it works in some day so i have
a clear plan as black i'm going to
develop all my pieces i'm going to be up
a pawn
where is this
white compensation here i get it you
have some active pieces you have some
threatening looking ideas but concretely
where what is your next move and it's
already not so easy for white to even
make a move like the engine wants to
play c3 right like what is what is this
movie stop knight before or something
but you don't play it upon sacrifice to
go into this no so because of this the
engines are saying it's all your pride
it's time to go knight b3 and play down
an end game
wow
let's jump to bucharest and anastasia
anastasia
hello everyone once again here we are in
romanian bucharest and i just came back
from the plane venue um i mean it seems
that actually yanni pomeshi spends more
time walking around and sitting on the
board because
he actually spent only kind of ten
minutes of his um
his time and um fabiano has only half an
hour left on his clock so actually the
position doesn't look so great uh at the
moment so i think ian actually got the
initiative in this game nevertheless he
plays with black pieces right now um i
also noticed uh that
pieces are leaving the board
in the game between uh wesley saw and
richard robert and we don't have queens
anymore and we know that it's not the
best uh situation for richard ferreira
likes to complicate the position no
matter what so two bishops are on the
board for black and uh it seems to me
that uh despite the fact white has extra
pawn um i mean the game probably goes
towards uh drawing the direction um so
so far so good uh
it's quite kind of quiet still at the
plane venue but the tension will grow
closer to the time travel i guess and um
so all the way all our eyes are on the
games what do you think about those
games guys
yeah yeah we feel uh the same way as you
that the tension uh keeps mounting as
this round six uh continues i
i'm
i'm just a little bit stunned that
you're an hour down on the clock yeah
that's quite the market worse with white
slightly worse and another thing i
wanted to bring up is that uh
wesley is about to play his third third
opposite color bishop ending with an
extra pawn
like
how does he do it i mean rick richard
actually hasn't taken on d3 yet because
his pieces are so active that you can
definitely let's say make an argument
for even maybe going bish buffet and
continuing but this is i think a very
comfortable draw of the bishop d3 bishop
d6b4
a comfortable as long as you don't allow
the pawn to reach d6 which i think with
the move [ __ ] before you achieve very
kind of very easily d5 for kga just
loses the pawn on the spot so i block a
i put a blockading piece on d5
the ideal scenario for me here would be
to actually play bishop c6 and get the
rook to d5 but this g7 is a clever move
that yasser made there stops that plan
right but i was trying to get out of the
way of d4 d5 yeah
as well as maybe but yeah but we go we
go bishop d5 roxy one we go i don't know
rookie seven rook c5 rook d7
and that's a blockade but the crazy part
really unbreakable i would say
yeah
nearly i like that you know like like
hedging because it is absolutely crazy
that uh
somehow in these variations these games
where wesley has the opposite color
bishop and it looks like things are more
or less cruising to it towards a draw
let's say and he's converted them uh
here is the
the defense looks
wonderful i i don't dispute at all
that uh black should hold black has
pretty much an ideal scenario where the
bishop the light square bishop and
richie and he's included bishop c2 which
is i think is a clever clever idea
inclusion as well you have it on the
move you play bishop c2 because you
cannot really play rook d2 because
bishop takes a4 equalizes the material
balance on the spot using the background
cases
i get my pawn in that case to d6 yeah
but we don't equip located on d7 i've
had like greenfield players just kind of
smirk
well girl groom foul players are a
strange breed of people yeah i mean
they're willing to pay a pawn down
is down they'd like their activities and
you're saying i am very much in the
smirking
state the the the the past deepon is not
yeah it's troubling
to you at all even even with the upon uh
let's say for surviving i wouldn't be uh
absolutely certain this is enough but
with the poland
for being one we're not we're not in
trouble rugby one played and before is
okay but i can also go to kc8 here i
think and just continue rook ac continue
doing this for a little bit be careful
are you going to be able to get your
bishop back to d5 uh
i mean you want it it should be three
exists this is why i have the other
squares i have the other square they
should be three and what i wanted to say
is that this is an absolutely ideal
scenario with the pawn specifically on
b7 then a6 and the white pawn already on
a4 and it will continue sort of
semi-hanging which probably prompts
eventually prompts wesley to put it on
a5 and after that the bishop on c6
really is completely untouchable because
there are no pawn breaks on the queen
side no before b5 to follow up now i'm
not disputing anything you're saying
peter i really
do believe that uh the the draw is maybe
a 90 percenter but from wesley's point
of view oh he's enjoying this is
fantastic i mean it's a i mean he's plus
two i mean wesley on a 10 percent
winning chance position seems to score
30 or 40.
i don't get it i don't know how he does
it but power to him but in any case a an
outcome of the opening early middle game
that wesley is going to embrace if only
because he loves to be in the lead a
play that uh
i don't lose with white very very
dangerous front runner if you give him
if you give him early points in the
tournament he he will he will
yeah
and also of course our uh reminder about
our next stop of the grand chess tour
peter yeah
soon after the the bucharest leg
finishes we we all uh proceed well we we
stay here we get on the train we move to
uh virtually virtually proceed to
right
to line up there yeah and this is this
is the lineup for the rapid blitz with
plenty of the same players playing but
there's also some additions
and some
yeah
to two uh two very strong ukrainian
players kiril shachenko who is a very
very promising very bright young talent
and anton korobov who is a brand name or
you know one of the more exciting
players around two locals from poland in
buda and madison yeah radhik
radhika i've known for ages and ages and
he's a very nice guy very very strong
theoretician and of course
uh young shirt who is
one of the candidates and the winner of
the world cup 2021
and by the way for anybody who would
like to join our conversation ask
anything you like of peter alejandro
myself yeah use the hashtag grunchestore
or tag the grunchestore official twitter
account and we will be
applying to them as they come
another one of the uh great matchups
that we spoke about coming into today's
round is between uh mvl and lavonne when
we left it
uh
this pawn sacrifice was not getting any
fans uh i like white's activity and
after the move knight b6
knight b3 how much how much of an
activity are you having yeah yeah
exactly well i mean in the face of these
ideas of f5 and e5 uh i guess mvl felt
it was necessary to
re-maneuver redeploy the knight i think
he's also sidestepping a five of four
check id specifically yeah i'm a bit
surprised by bishop d3 though because i
thought
not not for
king 2 is not that bad i'm wondering why
we're not playing f3 though
i beg your pardon instead of bishop d3 i
thought you know the more logical way of
preserving and sort of protecting
against the knight appearing on d5 would
be to
uh continue putting you know
put you know a potential pawn on e4 by
by doing this but i'm guessing some kind
of bishop d7 tactics don't quite work
out for us i suspect the same thing that
he was worried that his bishop would
probably fe4 before bishop g7 and we
have to have to spend a tempo retreating
the bishop so he went bishop d3 and
levon went with a very very slow move
there i was kind of expecting him to go
for something forceful here e65 remains
playable f takes e4 with 95 check to
follow is always playable uh but he
chose to go rk8 b8
a useful move but
not the most forceful move in the
position clearly preparing for bishop g7
protecting the pawn on b7 for the time
being
uh but mainly i think just kind of
passing the move to white and and asking
why okay so which which pieces would you
like to misplace
further i don't i don't know about the
misplacement so much as i thought that
the move knight b3 was it was designed
to be playing for knight a fighter
specifically specifically it's a trap
against knight c5 right because knight
c5 loses to a very cute move here just
straight up loses
check
knight a8
and
the rook is
entombed so apart from protecting b7 we
have also given us apparently
you could go fe4 now you can certainly
drive my rook away yeah i don't like why
i ate this much yeah yeah it doesn't win
the game on the spot i probably love
playing it
g4 which before and just give a check on
d5 take with the rogue exactly win a
tempo with your knight on a5 play bishop
d7 next yeah i'm a healthy pawn up here
yeah
so
in that case is it time at long last to
just bring our uh rook into the game
probably yeah but i'm guessing we go
bishop this um 7 95 though bishop d7
knight a5 makes a lot more sense in this
iteration because it is a tempo yeah
yeah i still feel like white is fighting
for equality here even in that final
position i can go rugby rugby gc8 which
final position after because after this
g7 knight a5 i can go rook gc8 and then
b7 pawn isn't actually lost but i'm
worried that eventually with the rook on
c7 getting traded i will have to reply
to ef with the ef and i'm not exactly a
huge fan of that there will be no knight
d5 check anymore very close to a draw i
mean i take with the rogue then i take
with the bishop
i'm still probably picking black there
because currently the f5 pawn hasn't
fallen yet and you still have to expend
uh effort everything yeah but yeah it's
very close to a draw yeah it just feels
like the the pacific uh yeah the 95
check 9 before here i thought you still
have to work for it a little bit
actually it's right it's not an
immediate draw no no because a2 is
hanging and i want to play b6 next move
and like this c4 b6 is actually kind of
awkward
good point good point so
yeah i mean mvl and bl has his or he has
his work cut out for him here and you
really have to one wonder yeah queen
king d4 is a very good move though yeah
i like kingdom
but okay uh those two games uh strangely
enough uh
as we were coming into round six i did
not expect our tournament uh
pre-tournament rating favorite ali riza
faruja to be uh struggling in last place
against the
defending champion
uh
shaq uh and let's just
yeah c4 is an interesting move here
because like
at
a
surface glance it looks like a pawn
sacrifice question mark question mark
what's the reply through crazy8
rook apparently we're still following
some games even in reasonably high
profile games as well this mission has
been reached by
uh moldavian grandmaster svetoshkin who
i think sadly passed away last year
i'm
um
hoping it's not the word there but i'm
pretty sure i'm not wrong
the clock times i'm just trying to
decipher who is out prepared who as we
get uh out of the opening into the early
middle game what are the clock times uh
peter between the two uh white is down
to 50 well 43 minutes now
alireza is 55 and counting um
so okay
so
first
hand i would say that uh somewhere
i don't know which one but a little bit
better prepared and we do have this move
c4 on the board and it's caused you to
question
why not
why don't that look ca yeah attack and
win it uh
probably like i think it is possible
winning it it might be slightly more
more difficult and maybe knight d2 is a
reply i'm not quite sure
maybe this is why we choose the other
rook
knight d it's it's an awkward move to
make but i'm really struggling to
preserve the pawn otherwise i was
thinking queen d3 but uh
though yes okay that was i i apologize
and i take everything but no no no no i
mean it it it was a uh
as you say i'm struggling to i also
maintain my my my pawn i'm not saying
that this is necessarily playing for a
win either it doesn't look uh but the
trick was as you as you so quickly
pointed out there is rook takes e4
against bishop e5 yeah this is what i
missed originally so
trading c345 in general improves by its
position
yeah i think the balance c3 is much more
of a weakness than the pawn on g5 yet
the pawn on d5 uh isolated or otherwise
it does actually defend a very good
knight the pawn on c3 does look like a
sore thumb on the open file
and that trade you know i don't like it
if queen d3 exists
you like this better yes
yeah but your point is also well taken
something like taken c4 rook c4 and
either immediately or perhaps after a
trade of rooks we can go bishop c6 and
right
in general i'm very much in favor of
having the pair of bishops here but the
bishop on g2 continues being
somewhat restricted on the other hand if
white somehow manages to play f3 and d4
here
i can easily
stop being joyfully take
away the white pieces it will stop being
fun we'll keep an eye on that one and
i'll turn it over to alejandro and ask
him alejandro i actually like today's
round five very different looking games
to my eyes maybe not everybody's taste
but it's it's it's an intriguing round
uh well rook aca could be play actually
was played in the game between ali reza
and shaq the engines are saying well you
could suck a pawn just go queen d3 it
works out tactically you defend the pawn
so it's not really a huge issue they
think queen d3 is the move you could
take on c4 take on c4 it doesn't really
matter what you take with there's no
bishop d5 ever because you know rook
takes e4 will always be working you
could take take rook c8 but the
interesting this is just about equal uh
yeah you have the pair of bishops and
perhaps this structure on the queen side
you could try to attack but you can see
how active black is the knight's coming
to c3 as well hitting a lot of things so
black is doing okay in this position not
more than that
in the game between mvl and levon we
have a pretty crucial moment in my
opinion for the game here mvl has played
the move f4 and if levon finds the move
e5 here he's much better if he doesn't i
don't find a great move for him for
example you are preparing to move bishop
d7 in previous iterations but at this
point the move knight a5 without the
move knight d5 check later it's kind of
annoying you don't have a good way of
defending the b7 pawn particularly in
this position so f4 is also kind of a
waiting move waiting for you to put your
bishop on d7 so that i can go knight a5
move like rook d7 rook hc1 doesn't
really help me all that much uh trading
this rooks will only favor white so not
a great move the move the engines want
to play e5 it does not win tactically
but it does pose a lot of problems for
the white side now you cannot take on d5
because knight d5 is still hanging that
has not changed if i play any one of the
rooks to c1 or something like that ef4
is a very serious problem because
remember that the king is tethered to
the bishop on d3 this rook is attacking
it so the only real move in this
position is f takes e3 e5 you could play
bishop c4 but it's such an ugly move to
make you're not really considering it
fe-5 must be the move that you want to
play now the point tactically is of
course chuck this king is under attack
cannot take the pawn again because of
the bishop can't really go to e2 because
you give me a free tempo with bishop g4
check you might as well go to d2
immediately and here the move bishop e6
97 is also strong with bishop e6 first
the idea tactically knight c4 takes on
e5 will pick up a very good pawn and of
course coordinate black's pieces most
importantly and what do you do against
it if you go rook hc1 well rook hc want
to take control over the c4 square and
develop your rook the knight reroutes
and this might be the difficult move to
find
from the situation that we have
currently on the board but if levon
finds and spots it you definitely go
down the line because 97 is very strong
in this position you don't have a good
way to defend the pawn the rook
cannot go to c5 because the knight is
currently controlling that square and
with 95 coming on the board that means
that you're gonna get your pawn that you
sacrificed for a second so you're going
to regain that extra advantage of the
pawn and your knight's going to be on e5
where it's like just so much better than
on b6 this bishop got out of the last
rank and it feels that black got
everything that he wanted he's going to
have the pawn he's going to have a
little bit of a weakness on f4 but who
cares i got my compensation uh gotten
rid of white has no more activity than
black really does this rook on c7 is
just about the only thing keeping white
alive because otherwise black's pieces
are all coming into the board with tempo
with vigor with strength and white still
unable to create threats e5 a huge move
in this position he plays that i think
that is going to be very difficult for
mvl to hold this position with the white
pieces if he doesn't find it because
perhaps he doesn't find him in knight d7
i don't see a great way for him to
coordinate his pieces so a make it or
break a type of decision here for levon
but the e5 is visually such a beautiful
move i i think levon finds it i think he
does find the knight d7 because the move
f5 is already an indication he sees
those tricks that were available with f5
f4 and e6 e5 is a beautiful continuation
of his previous play i'm impressed by
eon's position against fabi fabi again
you know is just such a great player
what can i say to be worse with white
yeah he probably holds on and i think
the fact that alejandro was indicating
that you need to start with a5 it might
sort of come in handy later exactly
the inclusion of a5 and a4 is probably
favors black in all of these types of
positions
but as we see in the game the knight did
come to b4 with a5 a4 included that
knight's not getting chased away by c3
either yeah but rookie eight that's
moved yeah rook of e1 needs to be played
and of course you don't blunt the knight
before here it's the most natural idea
and uh did find it's not very difficult
but he did find i think the the the best
way to proceed which is take stakes and
bishop g2 very precisely yeah you need
to attack the knight on before sort of
force it to take on c2 and then you go
roxy one exactly and having taken the b4
square away from it you force it to
return to d4 not b4 which allows you to
win the pawn back on c7
exactly extremely likely that everything
just gets exchanged off here it's uh it
becomes very very sterile obviously if
you don't take on c2 the position is
also completely equal so there is a
number of comfortable choices
remark it's remarkable how important the
inclusion of the move a5
and a4 was for black right here i'm not
sure exactly what the what the
difference is if we get the same
position with the inclusion let's say 5
a 4 key or key one knight before
well then we've got that whole variation
that you just showed where you just go
it goes it goes back to before in the
end exactly it goes back to before we
also just have rookie too in this
current oh yeah yeah yeah
it's not a tempo that is a huge big
difference of course rookie tool uh
attacking the entirety of white's
structure on on the second rank this
feels like it's wobbly and gone yeah
very very quickly
um
i i think the wobbly chess set is is
still uh
on our minds yeah exactly but yeah but
the way the way young played it and uh
jana is playing extremely fast uh today
and i mean he he should make a draw with
no issues whatsoever but perhaps
you know some eevee has been left on the
table there with the speed of play
because yeah the inclusion of a5 a4
would have been a much
bigger bigger issue much bigger issue
for five talking about challenging i
wanted to go to our neidorf game because
it seems to me that uh
well both players have been pursuing
their respective plans after the move g3
daniel just said okay look my knight on
d5 is a kind of issue i would probably
much rather have it on d7 maybe even on
e6 so let me just redeploy my night
nighty and uh lanier said okay i'm
bringing all my pieces to the center
your turn and you spoke about this
earlier peter you said like okay you
play a move like d5 you've got the
beautiful central pandu and you end up
regretting the fact that potentially get
a little weaker potential
is already like white is starting to
you know
tickle uh tickle in the senate i think
knight bg7 is borderline first they only
move here
and you can already start looking
at some force continuations here but i
very much like in all of these types of
structures
i like the idea of starting with h2h4
i don't know if it's the best move here
but i think it's just a very useful move
in every single position just to make
sure it's secure on g5 that you don't
blunder
any kind of tactics later in the game
and the way to try and undermine the
white center would be at least one way
is to place your 2c4 here
and then if the pawn goes forward to g4
f4 will be a very strong continuation
but also currently i think knight takes
d4 simply wins it so you don't even need
to spend the tempo before we're breaking
up the team but knight takes d4 actually
is stronger simply because this just
wins upon a format to win the game right
yeah it's uh yeah exactly f4 might uh
bring you
more just break everything completely
yeah completely apart
you're breaking up the team
i have the impression that uh while d5
may be a desirable move
uh
maybe it's more loosening than it is and
i think it's mainly the product of
yes i have an extra point but i'm not
quite sure what my plans are so at least
you know i'm expanding in the center i'm
doing like
it it's it's born out of desire to do
something i'm not sure he is so much in
love with uh weakening the e5
pawn himself bognan but what else do you
play well a move that i'm really drawn
to i don't know why is i really think
that if i put my king on g7 if i could
put my king on g7 and have my rook
defending on the h file i'll be right
still goes let's say queen two and left
four
and then f4 typical typical plan that
happens in many of these positions and
then perhaps a five if you go on mbd7
but also i can keep the pressure for a
while without committing to either five
or few five
these are strange positions because yeah
visually
i mean there's clearly some play for the
pawn but you don't you you're absolutely
unsure if white is you know fighting for
a quality or advantage but
um
they're difficult to play and i think
they're almost always at least fine for
white and perhaps even more
and i just want to say about this game
uh both players have been getting into
time trouble and we've certainly seen oh
they're rushing as quickly as they
humanly
so that they can play on their
increments and feel comfortable at last
and who's getting their fastest with the
most dislikes they're they're trying you
know one one side spends 20 the other
one says no no no i'm going to spend 30.
get there before you 21 moves to go for
i won't say actually they both play much
faster than usual they were until the
opening and then the opening stopped
right and we got their usual thought
process and this is a fascinating
position also a very difficult one to
explain right there's a lot of dynamics
in the position white has some obvious
trumps but black does have the center it
always feels visually the black has a
lot and the more you analyze the
position the more you realize wait it's
difficult to make moves with the black
side in this position actually i was
looking at it with the engine and i also
thought knight bd7 was absolutely forced
the engine says look c4 is a real idea
move the other knight
yeah you can actually and often
you actually kind of happily uh
uh
forego the right to castle just to trade
these bishops off yes because your your
king of fake seven plan
will still be in place yeah just trying
to escape uh exit uh stage
right here uh the bishop seven king e7
wow honestly i'm not sure i'm even
taking on this seven i know it feels
like you'd like to they often actually
play h4 in these types of missions or
even bishop c1 yeah h4 looks reasonable
you'd have to say you played bishop c1
black's got
the better version absolutely absolutely
i agree agreed uh i mean white was
certainly playing for these c4 f4 g4
even types of brakes i liked your
concept of f4 f5 very much
uh earlier too peter uh some pressure
for lanier but as we know
we'll wait for these players to get into
time trouble and we'll
we'll join them it'll pick up for sure
wesley so by the way again he's in one
of those bishops of opposite color and
games that has brought him
uh great tournament success this thus
far as he stands in clear first place
with a plus two result and again he's
nursing
this
half a pond this one this one is
actually
a lot drier than a lot dryer
and you if you compare it yeah you've
been kind of pounding the table a bit to
redeploy the bishop put it on c6 in
particular because wesley is now
prepared to play rook a3 and actually
deny an easy way for the bishop on situ
to get to g5 i think now is the time to
actually play bishop's bishop b3 well
the one great concern that you
absolutely absolutely have is not to
allow the pawn yeah if he pushes d6 if
it reaches d6 it's not indefensible but
you obviously feel a lot worse about
your position so stopping it stopping it
on d5 i think is a reasonably high
priority i guess bishop rook c3 is
slightly concerning
but only only slightly i'm always
thinking of the well it's the karpov
unsecured game but not here right here
because if you go the idea was to double
the rooks behind yeah but the bishop but
the in the carbon function game once the
bishop leaves you achieve something
whereas here okay i go i don't know i
mean d5 first
okay i go rook g7 king f7
and eventually eventually you play
bishop before and i will take on c ah
you will take the pawn that was the
concept okay so
eventually you will play bishop
somewhere and i will play rook c6
or bishop c6 even okay and then rook g5
and yeah how do you how do you shake
that that set up off as well i have no
idea in particular the setups with the
bishop on c6 uh now that a5 has been
played they're just so rock solid so i
mean i can yeah i king of seven i'm
gonna exactly exactly
no actually once you play rc5 i'm taking
on c5 because yeah yeah dc5 is not
worrying me in the slightest bit xc3
though is slightly worrying uh
intriguing so you you don't
want this this even this is not that bad
but yeah but why allow it yeah but you
do want
this uh yeah let's say
i i snap on c5 here very happily and
even though dc5 bishop v6 black is just
not wars here i mean
slightly but rook g8 rookie 8 and it
comes out
can't argue i mean it's beautiful
it's a dream fortress ambition bishop v3
played by uh by reheart and wesley just
snapped takes on c8 which i think was
i was kind of semi expecting this
because i think wesley knows this is
very difficult slash impossible to win
so
he will not
try too hard
i mean he will he will still try and
rook c8 i think he wants to occupy the e
file
yeah the problem with occupying the
e-file is that there's basically nothing
there you're not really creating any
threats and bishop d5 bishop c6 through
k8 is a way to deal with it
but i mean it's still a free pawn it's
still like he will he will push but i i
don't think he has a very high
expectation of of winning we were saying
the same things in the previous year
i i feel like deja vu here i i've seen
this movie uh played twice
not betting against but
i've done that before
burn once never again twice let's go for
thrice okay uh alejandro back over to
you please what uh what do you reckon uh
is it still ten percent or is it fifteen
percent now for for wesley yeah ten
percent man if this was not wesley so
somebody else i'd say five right but
it's wesley he managed to win these
games
i don't even know how it's like he
hypnotizes his opponent sometimes
it's pretty
from the opposite color bishops that
he's got it this one is the most
comfortable draw right definitely in a
different league of comfort compared to
his shock game
definitely more comfortable than the one
that napo got i think i have a very
clever solution to our problems here
somewhat tactically you have to bishop a
i really like this pay for here
and this is for for a change i haven't
actually read your screen normally i
just read your screen but
there's a payphone bishop a4 and and my
point is i want to play rookie a but i
also want to preserve the idea of rook
one check roxy to check and rook takes
b2 so i guess rookie sound for example i
guess rookie seven i actually go in and
take on bit zoom yeah i don't think the
g pawn reaches d6
so i can actually do this yeah check
check take note i have also protected b7
by removing my bishop from the b file i
want to play bishop g6 next move
and d5 rogue d2 you just lose that pawn
actually as far as i can tell
yeah the trade will just
precipitate very very quickly
i just i very much like the idea of not
allowing rookie seven i don't think
we'll lose if we play bishop v6 rookie
seven in the current like if we play
bishop d5
in the current position like something
like bishop d5 bishop c5
bishop c6 rookie seven i don't think
this position is necessarily lost i can
go rook d8 or g7 it's also kind of fine
but if i can even stop rookie seven from
happening i i think i'm i'm yeah the one
the one thing i do say is
[Music]
i've activated my rook
you know like on a good day something
crazy might happen exactly i could even
start thinking i don't know about crazy
exchange sacrifices but
uh what you just said was the bishop a
phi bishop a4 variation
before and if you play bishop c5 really
good if you play bishop c5 if i go
rookie 8 immediately now you're now
you're cooking with gas that i just
don't want to allow the rook into into
my position at all exactly so yeah this
feels like it probably holds maybe the
best uh
quite comfortably yeah and alejandro
what about the levon mvl uh game
var must be very happy in the truck his
prediction to win the tournament was
levon adonyan and he's playing a great
game today he has found all of these
moves we were harping about the move e5
takes f4 straight down the line now mvl
didn't play the move rook h1 to c1 which
is what we were expecting taking control
over the file especially of the c4
square but we still didn't like his
position after knight d7 instead mvl has
played the move king c3
perhaps holding on to ideas of the king
being active something like that but
very logical move here rook bc8 trade
off that active route that active rook
has been in the bane of your existence
for the last 10 moves no choice we can't
defend the rook really right you have to
play takes on ca takes on cn and sadly
you have to go back to the second rank i
was thinking maybe he wants to go
forward to defend the pawn so the 97
doesn't take uh the pawn the problem is
that if you play king d4 and you see the
move knight a4
he really is a mate it's kind of a sad
thing but you can't avoid rook d8 mate
who put a pawn on f4 he's got a kind of
a funny position right which means that
after king c3 rook bc8 takes takes you
have to go back you have to go king d2
but this is just a worse version than
what we just saw because you can still
go knight d7 you can still take that
pawn you still can't reach it as the
white pieces but now black doesn't only
have the extra pawn he has the better
pieces and this looks like a crushing
position in my view for black totally
and if you put that knight to c4 check
yeah and you're forced to take it and i
take with the rook it's the rook and
bishop versus rook and knight
combination uh play on one goal as far
as i'm concerned levone with the black
pieces and don't forget he won
uh with the black pieces also earlier in
the tournament uh he's dangerous maybe
one more along with richard i would
i would put lavon as being the most
dangerous player with the black pieces
i think i think i'd go with that
i wouldn't argue but i think
specifically today this is all
largely self-inflicted or without
question yeah because i think you play
the vienna to make a comfortable draw in
some kind of a long forcing line and you
don't really it's it's it's not a weapon
people very often use
uh and it all came from level three
from this very uh
well-known
and uh
yeah king of one of one player hundreds
and hundreds gf and then either
immediate h4 or rook c1 queen before h4
i remember the game starts here yeah
this against
bogdan
against mache i think everybody has
yeah i played h4 but you were mentioning
that lubermair leboyevich had actually
championed the move kingy too
and gone into this end game voluntarily
and we were
really questioning the way that luba
played that was king to queen b to king
f1
i beg your pardon king e2 queen b2 king
f1 so yeah
that the queen was worse on b2 but this
was before engines and now we know the
queen is
actually okay
yeah some very serious players like in
the in the early to mid 90s tried this i
i see on my screen that uh vladimir
tukmakov also played this a very
you know strong ukrainian theoretician
and a later coach of
romanian national team including anish
geary by the way which i thought was
very funny because he he published a
book
tukmokoff about his work with anish and
he basically said that you know the
preparation was excellent and whenever
anish got out of his preparation that
was when his games went south
he was like what
he was a very
trainer's like this really really you're
tough sorry
he's a very forthright character yes
but the problem was that essentially the
initiative the early initiative that
white had just kind of went nowhere and
the moment lavonne got in this great
shot e5
it became
uh
yeah this is a nightmare for for white
and like yeah if this is your position
by move 23 in the vienna when like first
15 to 20 are normally theory and yeah
you're you're straight things have gone
things have gone badly badly wrong for
exactly he you know
you occasionally save these types of
positions but very very occasionally
like 97 95 97 95 winning the pawn is
brilliant
but imagining that you had uh this
position and you're you're very grateful
by the way to have this position as
black would you would you choose knight
d7 or knight c4 just just inviting this
uh to be honest like structurally uh
okay yeah structurally i would prefer an
id7 because i like i generally don't
particularly like the idea of trading
the knight for this bishop on d3 the
bishop one d3 is not a very good piece
okay but knight c4 checked bishop c4
rook c4 yes looks so crushing doesn't it
that maybe it's just an improved version
of knight d7 because we also like win a
tempo by forcing something like king e2
yeah because this looks horrible yeah
and rook a4 is just such a big threat
exactly and if you have to go king e2
well then you get it's just a much
better version of the sound yeah but
also king c3 king d2 right
i mean you only play king c3 king d2 if
you missed something yeah yeah you've
missed something right he he must have
missed yeah
i think he missed knight a4 if you go
back to this position yeah
you don't play king c3 to immediately
play king d2 in the next turn
so something i mean location 197 is not
very attractive either like if we're
just ourselves it's right none of this
is a dream
no we
we're we're we're past that point but
that is for darn sure but this does
uh look very very attractive indeed for
lavon we'll let uh lavon uh uh enjoy his
position and we'll come back
to
our soon-to-be
time trouble game well lanier played in
a minute
yeah he might but i mean how dare he
play
really shocking the commentary team here
uh he is uh
you know very diligent worker at the
board on his opponent's time so he
clearly 97 was one of the you know two
perhaps straight up two possible moves
the opponent can make in this position
so you analyze it
uh while your opponent is thinking and
you come to conclusions and yeah i mean
he will still be in horrible time
trouble in this game i'm pretty sure but
he knows this is a problem so you know
he is not really you know against the
concept of maybe saving sometime
somewhere yeah
c4 though is just like a dream from
white's perspective because giving
squares to those bishops i mean
yeah at the moment
for d4 i really hate
either of these two moves as uh d4
question mark f4 or knight takes d4 but
white's for choice i mean he's fully
mobilized yeah i think we're taking on
c4
bishop takes and now the question is
do i need to spend the tempo on b7 b5
just to drive it away from the c4 square
alternatively i am kind of attracted to
you know returning to your idea of king
of faith king g7 i'm pretty much never
cussing in this position i think the
rook on h8 is a very very important
defensive reason exactly
yeah and uh we see we see the clock
we see the clocks here and for who can
burn their time fastest yeah this is
move 20 and uh dayak is now down to
below it's not just that it's moved 20.
they blitzed out the first 16 right
right
exactly actually
actually only the first four
what
what and he resigns he forgot about that
a4 completely and immediately resigned
well and he's there shaking his head
yeah like this has been uh what oh yeah
not not beckham's day clearly oh my word
we we love that checkmating pattern that
you you showed us
king d4 knight a4 and we'll have more
explosions because uh you're with me
yeah um
jan sacrificed the beast it's a
temporary sacrifice it will be a draw
but jan currently is of peace down in
his game but yeah let's finish with this
yeah king before 94 resigns is uh kind
of abrupt
okay i mean yeah exactly exactly uh
oh okay uh
wow you don't see uh grandmasters of
this class losing with the white pieces
in a mere
25 moves yeah that is
quite something i mean
stunner
wow and let's check in with anastasia in
bucharest
yeah it seems that actually now that you
were mentioning the game between maxine
and daryn and what a result and it seems
like i
i was kind of rooting for maxine
thinking that i have prepared him
yesterday but it went the other way
around maybe he was tired after
yesterday's race day um yeah so lebron
is winning this game and still we have a
decisive result so um i wanted just to
draw your attention now to the game
before we have the interview and
christian let's bring it now to levon
here to the studio um there was a there
is a game between chakrillar and talia
reza ferruccia and i think it's getting
exciting
actually with the last move bishop f3 it
seemed like shakuriya invited alireza to
take on a2 but of course normally you
don't take such pawns but still i mean
many many different complicated
variations would have come but at the
end
um alireza decided to play bishop h3 and
for example if you make move rook c1 you
should literally count some moves like
knight to take c2 for example and uh if
knight takes i mean rook c1 i mean then
you can see this kind of variations can
follow with queen one and checkmate so
you should be careful not to play the
move rook c1 now um what is alternative
maybe after knight to two you can
take with the bishop yes for example
but still the same scenario so i think
this game is getting a little bit
interesting at the moment but of course
i think it's time to come back
uh to you first of all and then we'll
see the interview with leon the news
thank you anastasia will definitely be
keeping an eye on this very important
game as our defending champion is just
having a horrible time
as is uh ali raza but i'm still kind of
like
tasered by what we've seen in the game
between mvl and levon
as we saw at the opening of the show
this match up these two players i mean
are so close uh with one another five to
four not anywhere it's five to five 29
draws in between it well there's nothing
between them anymore nothing yeah but uh
wow uh this this
catapults
uh
uh lavon into clear first at this moment
i mean of course we understand that
wesley can catch him or pass him two and
a half rounds ago wow two and a half
rounds ago you would tell me that levon
is leading the tournament no no no
no no no no that would have been tough
to swallow exactly
considering that he uh saved a
completely lost position but power to
him yeah as he seized his opportunity
wesley so by the way
uh bishop i was kind of wondering if you
will do this honestly bishop a for the
move that you mentioned uh richie uh
well
i mean as a grunfeld player you're used
to having a pawn hunting six
yeah it will be on d6 but all the rooks
are gone and i think richie is doing
absolutely the right thing by forcing it
to d6 actually not allowing uh the king
to come to g4 so he's gone bishop f76 b8
and uh
by the way
it's going to be it's going to be a very
very easy draw for uh for richie here
there's just
a professional repetition and that'll be
it
and let's just
with this amazing victory early victory
uh stunning victory by lavana romeo and
he catapults to first clear first and
expecting to be joined by wesley yeah he
will be he will be joined by by wesley
and uh if bogdan wins also potentially
by bogdan but
that's uh sometime in the future but
yeah the the wesley game is probably
about to about to wrap up okay
reasonably quickly as well
and let's go back to bucharest and
christian with lavon
thank you uh yes sir yes we are indeed
here with levon aronian uh lavon first
of all congratulations you're on a roll
uh how did you spend your rest day that
you came back with the black pieces and
what's uh one such a handy game
uh i had the pleasure of visiting the
opera
by the invitation that
you have provided for me their christian
and uh
i was sitting at the artist lodge and
all the musicians who were looking at me
saying who's this
artist we don't know
but uh it was wonderful we'll listened
to excerpts from
mainly except from two operas
one was uh cavalier rusticana
very nice beautiful with choir and
everything
and the second one was
where this
macbeth
well i think you uh might have found
another tool to increase your
performance uh during events so keep it
up for sure now let's get into the game
you're playing one of your good friends
uh mvl and you guys know each other so
well we were looking through your
crashes you met close to 40 times
uh and the score was quite close but he
surprised you with this move early move
d4
did you expect this at all what was your
strategy after you saw this move played
on here
i
expected maxim to play for so i didn't
expect before and then i thought to play
something that
i play sometimes but not all the time so
when he played the bishop g5
dc4 so here
okay i play b5 i play h6 i play c5 but i
thought to go for this
line that i checked recently and it
holds
take us through uh where you felt like
he went wrong
okay king gets too quick too it's mostly
white do it
if white wants to draw he will play king
three king e3 and nashua is going to be
a perpetual yeah yeah
and uh king f1 is the topical line takes
h4 and then it's uh
there's just the theory starts on mod
number 20
right right mostly but he played this
move queen to d2 uh it's a possible line
yeah did he think for very long here
yeah no
he thought all the way up to here but
now he well
i think that probably uh maxine was not
expecting me to take on c3 correct yeah
he thought that i will play queen a5 a
move that i employed quite a lot
but i thought you know to mix it up
since
i played i played this opening since i
think i am 18 so
and he's a fresh d4 player so yes you
might as well try to take advantage of
that and you guys went into this end
game
it did feel like he has some
compensation yes but the rook c7 is a
risky move risky move yeah he has to
play rook d1 you know just to be careful
because i thought rook c7
is already asking for it
it does feel like a natural move why is
it bad in your opinion this mover to see
so well they're because of the tactical
reasons i have this knight b6 which is
extremely annoying i have the cf-5 and
the rook on seven is getting under
a hit size of 95 96 95. i think he
hurried here at the very important
moment and after that
it was difficult for him to recover from
it okay and uh where did you feel like
he made the final
uh well i wasn't sure i wasn't sure
about bishop d3 i thought he anyway will
need to play f3 i thought
f3 takes takes which of the seven takes
i thought
okay this is slightly better for black
but uh it's not the end of the world
he will probably hold this so i thought
this is what's going to happen and then
uh after f45 i thought okay this is
already uh
disaster yes
thanks sir
and then
this was
it seemed like at this point the game
was close to over king to d2 still
offers him some fighting challenges even
knight c4 i thought is completely
winning takes stakes and rook
he cannot hold the spawn you know
versus rook and knight and he'll
probably have to go to the rook end game
which i thought i know i even have a
chat no take three yeah fake takes
uh rook c1
is this enough content play i don't
think so probably not yeah it shouldn't
really work levon two victories with the
black pieces in at this event what did
you uh do differently if anything at all
did you try to take more risks as black
do you see black nowadays as a weapon to
surprise you black is the new white
black is only white i like that
yes there was a book uh
black is okay yes did you read that book
no no okay
perfect now you're also tied with wesley
most likely if wesley draws his uh game
how are you going to approach the last
three games
just regularly i don't think i'm doing
anything particularly special
i'm just uh enjoying myself
the opportunity to play in bucharest
it's always very nice so yeah i will
look forward to be playing and trying to
play my best awesome congratulations uh
levon and looking forward to seeing the
next few games thank you very much guys
back to you thank you christian it's not
the shoes it's the shirt it's the shark
sure well but today today he hasn't worn
it and it's still you know landed him a
victory in 25 moves so perhaps it's not
really the shark maybe it's the
the man occupying the shirt
that's that could be it and by the way
uh between the two
again uh two two top players the
challengers if you will fabi and nepo
it's three versus three rook ending
and uh they have found a professional
repetition i wanted to say there was a
peace sacrifice in this it was very
temporary yeah that happened earlier we
had left it after the move bishop d2
that and the players
have made a draw a three-move repetitive
repetition
handshake
and it was right here we left it after
the move bishop d2
and uh
well yan
yan saw nice
first blush
it's a very attractive looking move
rookie too and then after you get here
you think to yourself okay well uh
discover check
uh threatening uh
aren't i doing great until this move
lands on the board
you're you're missing uh the the luft
yes with the polynesians would have been
completely winning for black people
exactly as we're about to see the bishop
had to take that take on c5 we take on
d2 by takes on c7 and unfortunately you
have to spend the tempo on creating the
luft otherwise rook takes me to just end
the game here exactly and uh
as it happens this is just a very very
easy draw for whoever you i mean for
both
it's just a very easy draw and the
players did make a professional
repetition and uh those both players are
standing on 50 after six rounds
and it's not where you want to be as a
candidate coming
not particularly now
but uh
it is what it is it is what it is and
also
like there's only so much we can read
into what the tournament results of
candidates are prior to the kind of this
tournament it's
it's you know
obviously it you know quote-unquote
fills column inches and of course we
will be discussing it but at the end of
the day what counts for the candidates
is the candidates exactly it's all about
becoming
there are no additional points you know
being carried over from here to madrid
and again these are the four players
that are heading
to the candidates next month bobby
ian richard and ali rija ali riza uh
turning to the game of shaq and alireza
because it was what anastasia brought to
our attention this move bishop h3
and you know you you start to look the
squares of the rook well you know
all the way all the way all the way over
to a1 and that
what was your knee-jerk
impression has uh has black seized the
initiative
uh a little bit yes but also
this type of initiative where
structurally there's absolutely nothing
wrong with the white position
it is kind of a tactical tactical
situation where you know
generalities such as you know white is
currently slightly on the back foot the
rook has to go to an awkward square all
of this really counts for anything at
all if you have a way to capitalize on
it right uh and i don't know like the
only
proper active move that comes to mind
here is queen bitsu okay but that
actually invalidates some of the tactics
that uh anastasia was showing us let's
say when the rook goes yeah i can go to
e1 we can also just go to see one i
think actually with the queen on b2
weirdly i think the rook is safer on c1
because there is no queen e1 uh mating
ideas such were such as were available
here yeah this is where the tactics so
we lure the we lure the queen to b2 and
then we go rook c1
and 92 tactics no longer work at all and
i want to play i don't know queen d2
bishop d2 something maybe even
something more adventurous
queens no queen c2 might not be playable
but
but we have an interview so let's go
back to bucharest
with fabi
thank you guys yes we are here with
fabiano carolina fabiano first of all
welcome back after the wrestling into
the studio how did you spend your
wrestling
well i played tennis with some of the
other players from the tournament
uh that was the main thing
uh oh well also in the start of the day
we had the fundraiser which was a tandem
you know casual game pro program event
uh for ukraine
and that was pretty much my whole day
then then after that it was already
evening and we started to consider uh
the game today
and uh what to what to play
but anyway he kind of surprised me a bit
so it was uh maybe not the best
preparation a bit of an insight from
you if you don't mind who is the best
tennis player
in this group i think you played with
ferugia mvl and wells
yeah so we played with alireza maxime
and iwan chaparino
and uh and also lebanon was there but he
didn't stay the entire time
uh
i i mean i think uh yvonne is good
he has good technique he said that he
had played
pretty much every day at some point
years ago so he still kept his good
technique
um and ali reza is just starting out so
he was just learning the ropes
and the rest of us are
bad players but uh we try
excellent let's get into the game you
are playing napo in this one and you say
that he surprised you early on with the
petrol is that it no no no i mean uh
well he played the petrol in the match
which is that um in the match he played
this land which is the most popular
these days
and um
chakra are against me played bishop with
five b7
and this line is
well it's uh it's a fine line but it's a
little bit under the radar these days
compared to the other two
um
yeah i i don't think i got very much i
was freestyling a little bit
and uh and turned into nothing and you
were also spending a lot of time uh i
was trying to find some way to play
like for
an advantage but like a fish of f4
i i think a good move is b6 and the
point is this would normally win a pawn
but he had knight b4
and at 95 he moves his queen somewhere i
was thinking queen e6 but queen c8 as
well and then um
the bishop actually gets trapped um oh
and what is i if you go queen to h3 for
example instead of queen b5 uh again i
think knight a6 yeah just like that
bishop is just trapped
so uh so okay i would have to make a
move like c3 here but then he
he had bishop d6 and i was considering
this a little bit
but yeah like this position didn't
appeal to me very much i thought
it's playable but it's definitely not an
advantage
so i thought okay knight c5 is a bit
more ambitious
um because at least this position is
quite imbalanced and
um
you know the bishop could be stronger
than the the knights in this position
and i think a big moment came uh
at this point at least from
my perspective at this point you stopped
and you thought for a while and you
decided to go with this knight to b3 try
to equalize the position you also had
the option of playing knight to uh f5
yeah which one didn't like this position
yeah why would not the card maybe get c7
but my pieces are going to become
extremely contorted anyhow root d8 and
the bishop drops back to f8 uh in some
cases seemed like a good idea
um
so by the way i do think that wesley's
so uh and richard report are about to
repeat so we're going to jump to that
one once they start repeating um
continue yeah i just like i basically
calculated this line to the end with my
b3 and there it is right now the players
have agreed to a draw
let's get back into it um i mean yeah
it's just here of course i shouldn't
play bishop before i should play
well i was considering that b7 quite a
lot
uh
and i think it's quite important for him
that after a3
i was thinking i would have a slight
advantage here but queen a6
otherwise i'd take on before i have a
slight structural advantage but here i'm
i'm pinned so i can't they're actually
going to be a piece down it seems like
yeah i can take d5 or something actually
but it's pretty bad and yeah i was
considering just this position after c3
i was thinking maybe a5 cb4a b4 and of
course i should have gone for this type
of position but i wasn't sure about it
and then i just decided okay bishop f4
is probably
kind of simplifying the position a bit
but
it's clear that black is slightly better
here
um
but i calculated i mean when i played
knight b3 i calculated this stuff more
or less till the end of the game i mean
in the until the rook end game
were you at all concerned at this point
after r38 that he has this knight before
ideas and no no no i mean i had already
seen the blind i was going to play i was
only thinking his only chance is a5
but i was thinking that i could play a4
knight b4
and uh the same lot line oh no so sorry
bishop
i think there's bishop d2 first here
yeah officially two first
um so i don't allow rookie two and at
knights e2 i can take
take and i have now it's a slightly
different
uh type of uh line but i have this a5
and uh i thought i was equalizing like
this
um and if he takes here first i thought
that this was equal but i don't remember
the line i think it was with before that
i was counting on
but yeah it seemed like i was holding
the draw here and
when he played knight before i was quite
relieved because this i thought was just
dead equal like the only way to play on
is something like a5 but
here white doesn't risk very much
because the knight is very stable it can
go to d3 eventually or white can just
play like a3 and or a4 and simplify the
queensland
and yeah what we saw in the game was
just a
straightforward force line which leads
to a drawing rook engine fabiano uh tens
game but we'll let you go now take some
rest and good luck in the rest of your
games thank you guys back to you
christian a little bit of a
disappointment there for fabby as he
gets absolutely
nothing even worse than nothing
he has to defend well you had to
figure out some things to to make sure
he doesn't lose and with three results
two games uh still in progress these are
our current standings lavon and wesley
sharing
first peter yeah absolutely and there
are plenty plenty of games still in play
but
the big one is uh the local hero bogdan
daniel
with a victory very unlikely well who
knows uh he could actually uh catapult
himself uh into a sheriff first and
bogdan has by by the way played a move
that we somehow resisted uh playing
ourselves uh peter he did just grab the
bull by the horns that says why don't i
castle yeah with the rook already uh on
e1 and not h1 even though i don't know
why it's a
there really isn't that much difference
but somehow it feels safer to castle
when the rook is in the center and not
on the h-file because you with the pawn
on h5 you're very worried about some
kind of g4 h4 indeed and things opening
up on the king's side exactly it looks
risky but it's also logical just
evacuating the king away from the center
connecting rooks
and uh yeah hoping to uh then start
alleviating the pressure somehow can i
be the first therefore to ask a question
what happens if i go right i think would
take right and then i was going to
tickle your rook and if the rook was
yes
winning a pawn or winning a pawn back
winning a bomb you do have i do have 93
checks but i'm used to i'm not that
happy with the entire thing to be right
and this is something that you do want
to avoid oh yeah this is this is very
annoying now your king is simply yeah at
least with 93 check we also spoil the
white structure right exactly
tick for tat
you you you mess up white
and maybe this is not
unhappy maybe this is not that bad i can
protect the the g6 pawn with king f7 and
king h7 and
both c3 and a3 are currently hanging
knight b6 c4 is a very good source of
counter play for the future on ib6a4 as
well
maybe this is playable um is there
anything smarter instead of rook e8
i don't see it at first blush but
yeah i don't i don't see it i don't
think good day you could play queen b6
queen takes b3 but bishop c4 is just
such a crushing response ouch just takes
away all of our con to play and then we
pick up on the fate and we are very
happy right yes well uh if the knight i
would no i was thinking i was going to
have to play king h king a2 or something
and maybe allow
some trickies but i i guess not a bishop
[Music]
ridiculous
probably
i mean i want to hang on a second why
are we this actually may be a
semi-playable but after bishop three can
i throw in something like bishop c4
bishop e4 somewhere i don't know i want
to choose a square i don't know which
one is strong
um
this i mean if 96 i take on d5 take on
f8 i want to take on a5 but that loses
material yeah
sorry
queen takes e5 was my plan but that
actually loses loser's material tonight
i i do don't like you three checks
exactly i've got a tricky uh
oh those tricky nights discover check
yeah
even though i i do feel like we probably
have traded enough pieces here to be
quite happy with our extra exchange
and of course c4 takes d5 is one of
those uh decisions that
in case you ever regret them you get to
play this h4 move that you're kind of
thumping the table for as well ideas of
g4 and the players
clock times dare i ask yeah let's take a
look let's take a look at what's
happening on the bird's eye view yeah
actually very very kind of
by there by their standards very well
you know relaxed 25 26 minutes each for
the rest of the 20 for the 20 minutes
wow i'm just going to even get a left
i'm going to even call that a comfy
time but we're going to jump to
bucharest as wesley so is with christian
thank you yasser yes we are with one of
the co-leaders of the event wesley so
wesley first of all welcome back uh to
the studio tell us a bit about your
resume what did you do during the
wrestling
oh yeah well we had the
christians go back first of all then to
back to play again but we had the
ukrainian fundraiser
uh which invited business people to come
play with some of the players
and uh
it worked like before in the base
section where
i play one move and then my partner
plays a move
we played two games actually against
natalia scova and her partner and we
lost both games
but it was fun and uh
then later i was just relaxing the room
and looked at the games and players and
looked at my next four opponents did
that kept your competitive juicy going
uh those hand and brain situations that
you had
yeah definitely it was a lot of fun uh
fabiano was there team
but sherlock was there i think everyone
was just
very relaxed and having a good time and
i think uh
my partner like i've never seen it
before but
we we seem to be a good match definitely
it felt like you came to the game quite
a relaxed confident in your play take us
through the critical moments of uh this
game yeah first of all i might say i
think
richard
opening real well i think he preferred
really well
and
i mean this tournament he has on minus
one so it's very unfortunate but he made
a very big blunder against uh dick
bogdan uh richard is also very uh
unpredictable player so he can play
extremely well like he did in serbia or
or sometimes he can have really weird
tournaments but
i think i only played a few games in in
my career and in classical chess so i
don't he's just
recently reached the very top level of
chess i didn't really know what to
expect and i don't really know him that
much so today he played
did you expect him to play something so
topical rather than something a bit more
creative artistic if you might yeah
that's true like that's one of the
reasons which i
don't really know what he's going to go
for i mean
in blitz and rapid i guess he plays the
dutch and the king's indian but i guess
for classical chess he's trying to play
real assault openings although as we can
see the other day 92 yeah
which is not very good well but it's
very
creative and very imaginative and it's
very nice to see a top player playing
moves like that from time to time
absolutely so
it felt like
yeah i thought i thought
i think he i think in the database he
only played the semi-slub once recently
so i didn't really know
but i think like okay after bishop c
four i mean like as many lines here
obviously like e5 is very solid
b5 is what i expected mainline but a6 is
very good but i think a4 is just not
ambitious enough
i preferred this maybe six months ago so
i wanted to try it but obviously i
should
play rook d1 uh i mean the same swap is
a very solid opening but roughly one is
the critical move here so that's clearly
what i should have gone for
because uh here unfortunately richard is
also very well prepared and this line is
probably just not
not dynamic enough to play for
a win so you play this move bishop to d3
quite quickly and confidently and now we
see that h6 might be the main line but
now he thought for a little bit and then
he decided to go for this uh e5 line
taking yeah giving you the uh pawn but
taking the bishop there did you feel
like he has enough compensation yeah
definitely
yeah definitely i mean h6 is the main
line here but it's also very complex
with the p stack on h6 but i mean black
is totally fine
i don't thought gary played this line 23
years ago he did you know yeah that's
incredible he's so far ahead of his time
but i think richard
obviously prepared this question you
still think he was within his
preparation even though he was spending
some time yeah i'm 95 percent sure this
was in its database queen d7 is a very
important move because i'm dirtying
knight g5 very good move indeed yeah i
mean otherwise knight g5 is coming and
black doesn't really want to win
september playing h6
so after the very quick accurate 1.7 i
think well black has good
compensation for one obviously
27 is
uh important but also a slightly
computer mode so
95 percent sure it's still in its
preparation
yeah and
i mean here
i think
i think i prepared something like this
but
my database also but obviously it's just
uh equal
i i think if i want to push for anything
ending
should go d5 rp8 queen b4 so i was
thinking for a long time going for this
um
i'm not sure if black should play queen
g4 queen f5
but let's say queen is
five if i could activate my dark square
bishop i'd just be much better you
should be to bishop c3 and but you
don't have time because of uh yeah rupee
for
yeah it's calculating something like
this like i'm turning queen d8 check
going to f6 probably yeah queen f6 and
it's just
like
uh no problems because you don't have
time to attack the queen
would win the game yes i'm pretty sure
uh
yeah i mean i would have gone for this
but i wasn't sure how prepared richard
was and
yeah in any case uh
i'm pastoring us on my f1 so i didn't
want to risk that much
but uh
yeah at the end of the day a4 and move
then it's just too quiet to post any
real
problems against our prepared opponent
wesley you came in to this round as the
leader of the event uh now
managed to catch you what are you going
to do in the last three games to
separate yourself from attack yeah i
mean lev won two games with the black
pieces which i think it's almost
impossible to win with black in this
so i mean if he wins win still against
the black pieces obviously it's going to
be
a tough sight
but at the same time i cannot control
how my
other opponents do in their game so i
can only really focus on my game
so uh i mean i
i have to
try to push in some in my next few games
i hope hopefully we'll see what happens
thank you very much uh wesley for
joining us in the studio keep the energy
up for the last three rounds and we'll
see you tomorrow yeah thank you kristen
thank you so much and we're actually
going to go on a break right now stay
with us we're going to come back shortly
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
that's our show
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the us and world chess halls
of faith
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round six of the uh
bucharest superbad chess classic and
these are the standings with three of
the days games finished and two still in
progress levoir onion with a very swift
victory over uh maxime marshall graph
quite a striking game frankly yes it was
and wesley already drew against rickard
rapport so we have two leaders on four
points and potentially bogdan they are
joining them on four points he has
currently
a reasonably promising position a very
sharp position but there is really
promising position against linear
dominguez where he has an extra pawn and
he seems to have resolved
many of his problems like he finished
development the king is now reasonably
safe on g8 and the extra point e5
remains
but uh we do want to bring you news of a
move which uh we had a conversation in
uh in the the
during the break
our group of commentators
and uh i very very confidently after
bishop h6 rook fa-8 gave yasser ten
guesses because alejandro informed me
what the computer liked there for white
and i thought i was absolutely safe
giving yester not five but ten guesses
as what the best move here is
and all whenever you you uh set a
challenge exactly like this this gives a
little bit of a hint right because that
implies that
non-standard tricky move is the best but
i still felt completely safe i i thought
you know in my experience there is
plenty here to exhaust before you come
to the conclusion that you need to come
to and he also said we wanted to play
bishop to g6 we even said it on there
but it probably doesn't work
how about
how about trading queens what do you
think about quincy too and at this point
this is the we are not worthy
type situation
because
honestly guess one
i am i am still in in shock well i like
bishop g6 i have to be fair i mean
because it was knight c3 was the
off-putter yeah but the idea behind
queen c2 was pretty straightforward that
queen takes c2 bishop takes c2 this
knight is hanging if it's supported
yeah yeah exactly this type of thing and
i think peter the the the 95 here also
might be even stronger than rook takes
e5
knight a5 yeah knight a5 is an
incredibly annoying move to face here b7
is hanging before might be the following
because we were doing a blindfold that
basically went rookie five bishop a3
you were thinking well i can even take
on a3 i have bishop e4 as well
and maybe just this position the only
question is this is probably fine for
black actually because of how active the
pieces are you take on d1 you go knight
c4 next move i think you hold yeah yeah
i think you hold it but it's just
it's not ideal but i think you make a
draw here okay because eventually i
think it ends up being three against
three and three against three with two
pieces against stroke has been known to
be holdable you know it's interesting
you should say that because there was
actually i believe a couple of practical
games where the rook
lost against the two bishops on the
three versus three worlds i mean it's
different right specifically against the
bishops it's much harder even though
famously held it against magnus in uh in
new york and in one of the uh tie break
games uh he was losing at a very
specific moment for like one ply
he he held hail held and then blundered
something and was losing for i think
strictly one ply and then it was back to
being a draw cool but what we what we
did get instead of a move queen c2 which
was actually a decent alternative if i
can use that word uh rook c1
yeah tickling the queen that's what i
expected you to start
start guessing
and then you're saying this is going the
wrong direction though but it's it's
removing the rook from a very very
useful uh open file i think it's very
well placed on g1 d1 and i1 are
obviously the ideal to squares for our
rooks here yes it gains a tempo by
hitting the queen but
it's
somewhat misplaced in the rook and you
can play something like 26 here i wonder
what the response to let's say rook e1
d1 is but white isn't really creating
that much of a threat perhaps we can
even dare to play queen e6
because because bishop c4 knight seven
b6 seems to uh solve the uh the pin
nicely uh quite nicely
and i only interrupt when there's like
huge
g5 is just g5 just wins the bishop oh
yeah you would think that there's some
kind of counter in this position but
i
apparently there isn't maybe because
there's queen g6 and knight f6 if i need
to against bishop c4 but this apparently
the edges think just wins a piece
dope chicken knight seven b6s yeah
painful
dough very very painful yeah and if
queen e4 uh instead of bishop c4 i'm
guessing if all else fails we can take
on h6 queen takes d5 knight c5 and we
are massively massively better with
black because we get to trade the bishop
on d3 which is the underpinning
all of our hopes for compensation with
white here no question about it no nice
nice no g7 so 26 actually generates a
threat of justice a very serious threat
in fact meaning that white perhaps has
to spend the temple without evacuating
the bishop from h6 or playing h4 or
something giving black a very important
uh additional tempo to do something um
i'm really uh souring fast on the move
rook on a1 to c1 uh rook on d1 to c1 uh
alejandro was
lanier
made
a big step in the wrong direction
will be signing up for the yasser sarah
won school of chess after this game
because you're absolutely correct queen
c2 was the good move rook d1 to c1
has led black
i wouldn't say out of all his
difficulties because remember he is up a
pawn so he is suffering for it he has
certain positional things he's suffering
from the pair of bishops some discomfort
in the center the part on e5 being
slightly weak some tactics on g6 black
is the one that still has a lot of
threats to um to perry but after the
move of rook c1 queen d6 it's kind of a
breather for black because you finally
get a threat of yourself right g5
trapping the bishop is a serious threat
despite the fact that it looks very
weakening and that they you have to
calculate very many tactics precisely
make sure that rook d1 bishop c4 doesn't
work queen e4 queen h7 doesn't work but
once you get it down you'll realize g5
is a threat in this position and that's
a breather it's a breather that black
can use to keep increasing his position
for example the move h4
you guys have mentioned this before move
the queen out of the way
and get uh some pressure on this knight
on b3 immediately you never know when
there's a tactic with the knight hanging
the queen is beautiful beautifully
placed on e6 not on the way of a lot of
pieces for example a light square bishop
already disappeared have the queen cover
some of the light squares and queen on
e6 is beautiful you can also even
consider a move like b5 perhaps not as
aggressive to play before but just to
take away the c4 square from the bishop
because we've seen so many options in
which this bishop is powerfully placed
down this diagonal so there's a couple
of tempe that black can use to safeguard
his position keep that extra pawn
consolidated now white will forever have
compensation pair of bishops
possibilities in the king side but
they are diminishing and the more moves
bogdan is able to make the more he
consolidates his position and kicks out
white pieces the more the central pawn
will be felt remember it's not just any
pawn it's a pawn on e5 which controls a
lot of squares yeah i just
thank you for that alejandro that's a
and a quick look at boxton daniel deck
he had a lot of experience last year he
certainly benefited from playing this
giant and he had a pretty decent
tournament a very good start certainly
and and i want to just briefly point out
that this graphic looked different at
the start of the tournament he has
overtaken constantine lupulesco by his
results
in this tournament
progressed him from number two uh
romanian player to number one romanian
player yeah number one in romania now
overtaking lukulesco who will also be
showing his abilities in warsaw in
warsaw not in bucharest which i think is
funny but in warsaw he'll be joining
with the rapid and blitz yeah
first of all i i really like what you're
saying there about that move queen e6
alejandra but if i could take you back
for a moment to the move castles
and bishop h6 and taking on d5 somehow
that just like ended the kind of
pressure and the tension that you've
been keeping was there anything to be
said for move h2h4
uh peter had mentioned that when you do
end up castling these ideas of h4 and g4
start would h2h4 have been uh
more tension i suspect the answer will
be it was playable but nothing special
something like rook fe-8 i guess is a
decent reply and i mean i wasn't going
to put it with those words but that
sounds pretty good that sounds really
good that sounds pretty good so rook f8
is not the engine movie
because then aren't you transposing into
the game where maybe i get a more useful
move
so what's the reply to each form maybe
rook f8 is not bad at all uh rook f8 cd5
is a better version for white but not
good enough to give white an advantage
okay uh after this move the engine
wanted to play actually e4 it's a hard
move to find the more you analyze it the
more you realize okay this has some
ideas it chucks the pawn but in a good
way for black you take on c4 not on e4
you have to take back what else can you
do and the point is that either knight
e5 or b5 is a very nice tampon this is a
very good knight in this particular
position
uh you would have to go bishop d5 but at
that point you're not really playing for
the advantage because you always have to
contend with knight takes d5 but what
else can you do you don't move the
bishop back to d3 here right and this is
this is just an issue
at this point so baby this is what
lanier didn't like about the position
very typical to give up a pawn that you
already had extra to gain the positional
advantage and you can see in this
position the knight on e5 went from a
couple of moves ago if i put it here
yeah on so many positions there where we
we didn't know what to do with the
knight right it's not really going to a
good square you give it that square
takes the problem with this sacrifice is
what do i do with this pawn on d5 right
if i have to take on e4 it's opened up
the bishop but as soon as you spot that
you can plant a knight blockading an
isolated pawn in the center this time a
king pawn well you kind of warm up to
the variations and perhaps this is what
scare lanier to be fair cd5 variations
were not that much better anyway after
rook fe-8 so
lanier wasn't as much of a fan as uh you
were of the move h4 we do have the move
queen d6 already on the board and linear
had to reply quickly why did he have to
reply quickly 13 minutes for both sides
complicated complicated position and
nowhere near move forward yet
absolutely i'd like to just turn our
attention to the other remaining game
the remaining game between actually two
players who are fighting at the moment
in last place yeah you know the the
those uh match ups tend to be pretty
worthy as well and when we left it i
really like this move knight f5 yeah the
five was uh i didn't spot it instantly
but yeah yeah that was yasser's idea and
it's a very solid one 97 is not really a
threat yet but well longing it on d6 is
yeah definitely a very sound i was
thinking that with the knight going to
f5 queen b2 was
verboten because of 97 but knight d6
especially that would be such a
brilliant night and you should just
that i thought he was going to resist
playing you don't really want to give up
the you know bishop on h3 and this also
gives life an additional tempo because
the rook on c8 is hanging so he had to
spend a tempo on rook c8 e8 here but in
this position isn't white just much
better uh
yes but uh in a very specific fashion
even though i think here i would give
you one like after queen c2 i'm giving
you zero guesses here you're
because here the best move is the sort
of the most natural one you just need to
return the queen back to g3 it's a very
good square you protect the the e2 pawn
without
moving any of your pieces away from
right good squares and after queen g3
white would have been uh would have been
better unsurprisingly because the pair
of bishops against a pair of knights yes
knight on c3 is quite active but
even when white kind of disentangles and
starts
creating ideas and threats of of his own
it will be a problematic situation for
alireza but there should be three
machines disagree with and say that this
is not nearly as good
it's funny because queen d3 i mean i
everything about that move is is good
and solid and everything else but i just
love this queen being
on the square h
f5 pardon me because i've got this
bishop h6 i think i might be drawn to
the move king f1 just to protect
yeah but i like
i like white's position but
it should be e3 makes sense
i'm sure the idea here is to keep the
queen on the five of five as a kind of a
beautiful square
protecting you two by
by playing this video it looks it looks
strange and uh
yeah still i've i'd be
very unsure what the evaluation of this
position is i i am talking with uh
relative confidence because i did cheat
a little bit and and ask and when our
producers told us that bhp3 was a
mistake i wanted to check just how much
of a mistake it was and okay
i was always impressed by uh sakura
exchange sacrifices like that uh yeah
your eye is instantly drawn to it
takes e3 right and you just kind of like
you start the position is too open for
it though king of two here but even if i
had to king f2
a tricky yeah
i mean i i've just seen um my friend ulf
anderson play these exchange sacrifices
so often he loved playing these rook
takes e3 uh
lines um
probably not though you were saying king
f1 king of follow maybe yeah probably
king f1
the the only issue for white here is
that the rook only one is extremely
passive but if it's true if it ever
frees itself up somehow that's better on
f1 yeah i thought yeah i thought rooker
but maybe knight takes c2 is not a bad
move i don't know but generally i'm just
not a huge fan of this because of how
open the position is i think
all sacrifices came in much much more
close structures and more
more stuff on the board rook e2 not
rookie three
what happens if we just take on a2 here
with the queen
it is a pawn after all why not
yeah i think that would be my sort of my
first and major question too
because i think i i gotta get rid of the
night don't i i mean that night on uh on
and then i go something like night c4
and i ask are you sure you're going to
get your going back but i guess after
bishop d4 it does look like probably the
initiative will be enough to win the
pawn back somehow i've got rook a1 okay
should be seven all kinds of threats
yeah
very difficult to imagine
why
like uh better but uh
join our conversation and we have a
tweet peter yeah let's uh let's take a
look at what the viewers are okay we
need to challenge dimitri give us a
challenge
uh so demeter stanislaw uh asks what is
the role of choosing the city where the
gst tournament will be held uh probably
many places would like to host such
events uh and greetings from poland and
greetings to you too i'm not entirely
sure i think it's to do with uh
sponsorship mainly i think this is where
i would like to delegate the answer to
you guys you probably know
the inner workings of the tour better
than i do but i i assume it's to do with
the sponsorship
we've gone from norway chess being in
part of it louvin held many wonderful
wonderful events as well and i think
those were always kind of local sponsors
for those cities and this year
and we've got uh super bet jumping in on
the first two events um and
we've got zagreb
super united which is a division
magnus carlson joins us on this the
third tour and by the way uh just keep
in mind there was this wonderful
wonderful announcement pre-tournament
that next year the grand chess tour
winners the two teams will win those two
two candidates will produce two
candidates uh for the feed a
uh
world championship for the science cycle
for the cycle which is really a great
break yeah it's it's it's good to see uh
sort of fide uh recognizing just
how big of a part of a calendar the tour
is by this point uh details still need
to be i'm sure ironed out in terms of uh
format and uh you know the cycle in
general is of a very much a classical a
series of classical tournaments whereas
the tourists split three plus two which
would bring
which brings up the idea that uh for
those um
uh tours that do
uh choose the candidates maybe we'll see
more events
more players more wild cards yeah
absolutely results if it results in the
expansion of the tour i think everybody
everybody will be welcoming welcoming
that news with open arms yeah and of
course the
1.3 million or whatever it is in prize
fund
doesn't send the best players in the
world to play so it it it's only makes
sense um let's turn it over to you
alejandro what do we have in the linear
game as uh the players get to the time
trouble uh yeah well we did expect the
move b5 coming in by deck we were
considered between queen a6 and b5 but
this is the issue right you have 16
moves to make for both sides to get to
move 40 linear at 11. book done
eight minutes and 22 seconds oh yeah
this is going to be an issue for the
players
but
who would you rather take in a practical
game yes we know the evaluation says
black's a bit better
but you have the bishops
yeah you have slightly more time i think
i think i wanted to say it's slightly
easier to play for white but honestly
this is just not an easy position to
play with either color right
yeah i was gonna say three you know
three results for sure
i'll take the palms yeah i'll take the
pawn and this after b5 especially the
inclusion of h4b5 makes me think it's
just a little bit easier i love what
alejandro was saying you know
i'm missing a light square bishop put my
light put my queen on e6
cover some light squares get ready to
play moves like knight f6 and i don't
know start i don't know either bishop
just said bishop bishop g5 is
annoying me a little bit and bishop f6
would be a nice move but i think it
takes away a very important square from
our knights so i'm not that sure if it's
a good idea so uh we do have moves after
h4 oh pardon me we don't have moves
after h4 b
5 is the current position i'm sorry i'm
wondering if linear just goes k2 here or
something and says you'll move again
it's funny that we give a speech about
queenie
i mean i'm not going to ask twice i'm
not even going to
like ask what you're well
i'm not saying it's a good move i'm just
saying that it's just so difficult to so
difficult to figure out what to do
proactively that maybe your mind is
drawn just to you know a move that kind
of
passes passes at all
yeah i mean a queen esx knight c5 looks
looks like awesome
i mean we had that moment uh two days
ago when
we saw a move that was
it didn't even rise to the level of
being bad it was so it was knight a6 i
mean what was what was shaq thinking
when he put his knight on a6
king a2
oh boy i don't think it's that big but
yeah it's definitely not the right way
to go and i wasn't really advocating for
it to be good i was just but you're
looking for a pass maybe 95. no but it
sort of passed again like it allows
knight c5 right it's uh aha because i
was eyeballing the square i'm assuming
yeah i'm guessing it's knight c5 because
you can't really allow 96 and or knight
what are the tactics here so i can't
take
e5 is hanging yeah you can you can take
but i can go i think windy 4 and bishop
takes g8 is would be my sort of default
default solution here there might be
something stronger because i don't quite
like queen e4 here or maybe even wish
before yeah
but hundred is looking at us very very
quickly
i'm not using my engine i'm just just
following enjoying the analysis
he's not perturbed by one no not yet not
yet um
okay so no knight a5 95 is definitely
like if if you want a proactive move
here it probably is knight a5 and
actually i'm kind of i've soured on
knight c5 can i go roxy8 instead and
just say that you know knight b7 was
only really an idea when it was a fork
it no longer is a fork here
uh and i want to put my rook on an open
file and and go from there
uh allowing 96 would have been would
have been bad though yeah
and
and not unexpectedly guys time is
becoming a concern especially is it
though for
nobody
yeah that's that's the other game and
quincy 5 is a very uh very decent move
there by shock we
we did see uh uh the pollen a2 being
taken in the game between sacrilege and
ereza and quincy five does appear to win
the pawn back quite comfortably
i'm not even entirely sure how to
equalize there for black currently i'm i
feel like maybe white is a bit better
and
linear chose a move that we did not
discuss but which i kind of like
because knight on b3 was very much out
of play and he is saying i would like it
on e4
you know that's one of those moves that
you
when your attention is drawn to it maybe
you're not looking at it initially but
the more you look at it the more you
kind of go
i really like that that makes perfect
yeah that makes perfect sense because
because you do see
the impactfulness that it will have once
it settles on e4
ideas of even i don't know
utilizing the c file on a good day
yeah and we're being told this is not a
great move but i i don't think white's
position was generally all that good and
i understand it very much from a human
perspective i'm guessing knight c5 is
like level one white goes white wants 94
so let's go knight c5 and not allow it
but then we go 94 anyway we take with
the bishop
and uh
there's definitely there's definitely
some compensation but queen e6 is just
such a nice move in every single
position here right yes you just
sidestep all of these ideas now before
b3 might become something that you might
want to be doing
or just stabilizing with i don't know
knight f6 yeah the other thing is
is you know
one of the things that i absolutely
appreciated by i get by vessels misoff
his 200 best games book is he had this
way of making a fantastic harmony with
all of his i feel like bishop h6
it's not it's a bit out there not
working with the rook on e1 the rook on
c1 so i'm not a big fan of this bishop
on h6 at the moment so i understand but
what would be a good square for it
though
well just because you mentioned b4 maybe
bishop on a5 uh
yeah get it all the way there to to
protect against some potential once
again we're not we're not discussing
active plans right now is not really
doing you know it doesn't perform any
kind of an attacking function it just
covers some squares uh
black is just comfortable here feels
like
can i
if i if i try to just keep all this i
was wondering if you can continue but uh
then what is the like
i play i play bishop
i'm thinking my next move might be rook
on c1 to t1 or rook on
on f1 to e1 i i i like the rooks on d1
and e1 and linear
voluntarily gave up the d-file um
i feel like he's
he's
stepping in the wrong direction
alejandro is that
is that fair yeah yeah the engines think
that he has down the pawn and the
compensation as well yeah so knight c5
is a very strong move and the point is
that after knight e4 you can go on on
your board the move not knight takes e4
which is fine but queen b6 is even
stronger wow simply asking the question
hey d3 is pretty valuable bishop i'm
going to keep my eye on it if you take
on c5 thank you for helping my
development i'll take with the bishop
and now i'm throwing things like even
bishop f2
bishop f2
but also just you know also
consolidating yeah yeah yeah yeah that
looks really good for black i i don't
disagree i like how you put it uh pawn
and compensation is in uh black's pocket
on the black side of the board certainly
not whites
agreed
um
lanier
in trouble can we just go to the game of
shaq because oh yeah the game of shock
is definitely flaking dying down uh-oh
dying down yeah it feels like the b pawn
is running quickly enough that white at
some point will start shedding bishops
just to stop it from reaching
you know shedding bishops
sounds sounds tough man
b7 b5 this guy is running so fast bla
white may be shedding bishops
by uh
taking it back
by giving them a away and taking on c3
and then you take on e2
yeah it does look like it probably will
be uh will be some kind of a mass
simplification and some kind of a three
against three at the end of it i just
haven't heard that expression shedding
bishops
you don't want to shed your bishops
as
yeah as as the saying goes you know one
of the advantages of having the bishop
perry is that he can trade one of them
that i've heard or both yeah yeah that's
as the case may be here bishops dominate
knights because of their ability to
capture the knights easier than the
knights can capture the bishops nice
shedding bishops
your first book
should be rushing towards drawing this
one
that does feel like it yeah exactly
so uh it's about the fight for first
guys uh can
if daniel were to win this game i mean
this would be just like one of the
greatest
results
of a romanian grand master and
in years yeah i mean
maybe ever
i'm thinking fl florin giorgio of the
past
had
done very well but this in modern
days this would be
this would be a fantastic result
about like 2800 2900.
he's the lowest rated player in the
field i think uh
dieter probably had some very good
tournaments yeah
thank you yes exactly
and david well not surprising yeah
dominguez and dak i've never met they
would have had to play in some kind of
random world cup pairing for these two
two grand sweets or grand swiss exactly
not that many tournaments they played
together of course completely different
parts of the world first matchup yeah
that's kind of special
i think yeah
and uh yeah knight c5 on the board
i mean bishop c2 looks awkward i think
you probably play 94 unhappily i don't
know i don't think early nearby this
point is enjoying what's happening on
the board i really like that yeah bb6 is
actually a bit of a difficult move i
think because uh i just let you guys
know that bishop c2 k7 is resigned
ah
oops that would be that would be a
problem that's another thing that about
this bishop i mean whether it whether
it's getting trapped by the move g6 g5
that's offensive and whether it's
getting
it's kind trafficking sad yeah it's
really really sad and after bishop g5 i
guess maybe even f6 is possible but you
can also just go bishop takes g5 knight
c3 check and
queen takes d2 and that end game i think
looks completely resignable as well
totally totally
no i will be grabbing this ending with
both hands yeah so there's not to have
to calculate exactly after f6 you might
be forced to calculate
sacrifices yeah no no here it feels like
you just win by with you with your hand
king h7 is is a fact it's not a it's not
a good sign for linear because i i
looked at it with the engine and it's
saying if you don't play knight e4
well
every other move basically loses to some
tactic yeah knight takes d3 most
especially that was the that's why he
played 92. i don't the surprising bit
for me is that he hasn't played 94 yet
because like you don't blunder knight c5
i'm pretty sure that was the intention
and it's also like it's the most natural
move and also the best move in the
position so yeah exactly the the thing
on knight b3 was it was keeping this
knight that's been rather passive well
at the bay yeah at bay
i only went knight a5 because i was
eyeballing the c6 and
94
was necessary that was that was not
but now is the moment of truth right
here
i wouldn't call it that far and i think
c4 is still better for black it's just
the queen b6 is a little bit more
accurate
but
but queen b6 is getting a very nice plus
yeah well they both do
oh even knight even knight
also a very nice it's also a very nice
plus just queen b6 is a let's say bigger
plus yeah
but why is 94 bishop e4 very nice plus
you just move your queen yeah i just
queen e6 queen e6 and you are up upon
yeah i mean it's a reasonably healthy
extra pawn in the center and uh yeah the
good news at least is i've got this
bishop on e4 maybe i
i don't know it's just that if you
compare this position to queen b6 it's
kind of obvious which one you take right
for sure yeah i'm just thinking that
with the bishop on e4 and if you ever
move the knight and allow me rook c6
well you know the game flares are new
right right let's take a look
yeah that destroys
a bit of his advantage i'm not going to
go with
a ton
not as easy anymore yeah and again the
clocks of the two players 5 20 for
linear and three minutes and 50 and
counting
for
bucht and daniel
and still 14 moves 50 moves to muric
by the way i mean not for nothing but
these guys when they get into time
trouble they play awesomely good yeah i
mean i've seen lanier just play
almost flawlessly in time trouble
daniel against farrugia he just
outplayed farouza actually farouza was a
piece up
yeah and by the time
yeah it was actually once he started
playing an increment that
this game improved yeah the turnaround
started basically yeah it was like what
uh these guys play really really good
under the pressure at the ticking clock
me i melted i i hated being in time
trouble and i normally ended up
giving up lots of advantages in time
trouble by the way queen e6 on the board
and i'm sitting here thinking this
bishop is misplaced and that's why i'm
playing bishop g5 is a very clever
little move because you you hate taking
because it improves the structure for
why so much but he also hate leaving
that kind of pressure unanswered
entirely so yeah i'm not even sure how i
would react to it exactly it's a i mean
rookie g1 would be my second choice but
yeah i like bishop g5
rookie d1 yeah
what one thing i am sorry too
the engine move because there's so many
possibilities of course then you can
choose any of them a move that looks so
much nicer once you put it on the board
but hard to think of bishop c2
bishop c the idea occurred to me but
very much because i like i thought is a
five playable for black and then i
realized we're pushing the bishop to a
very good square so f5 is probably not
great
f5
you you want to play king a2 and you
want to play f5 no i fight bishop f6 and
like
in in in terms of sort of spreading our
wings a little bit if the pawn gets to
f5 the bishop feels a lot more natural
on the f6 no not here i mean i
understand yeah but like some kind of a
setup like this
it is specifically because of how strong
the bishop on b3 is that i'm not
advocating
otherwise otherwise it would be
something i would be very much in
interested in because right uh we're
pushing some pieces back we're creating
a very nice square nf6 for the bishop
and if at some point we get to play five
before we are incredibly happy yes
but yeah the bishop on b3 is just a
monster so we don't want to provoke that
thought in our opponent by the way uh
what's our predictive power say about
the outcome of this game if i
you were a betting man and i'm not
saying you are not
i think right now i would take draw
probably ever ever so slightly over
bogdan winning and i don't
he's been playing way well way way it's
a way to way too good uh in this
tournament
it's in great form yeah to to to to
suspect him of misplaying this position
to a degree that leads to him losing but
i think the compensation now that he
hasn't played queen b6
uh it feels to me that the compensation
might be enough but uh yeah
still has to solve some some problems
alejandro weigh in if you will
hard to say yeah i think that draw is
favorite but
bogdan has been playing very well linear
has had his issues this tournament he's
minus one he's minus one he's not
showing the exact form that he had for
example in the american cup right
exactly he was doing very well
um were he not
uh
yeah he knocked levon
yeah from the classical yeah so that was
pretty impressive and linearity is down
to 220.
so
i don't know i think he came back he
went from 520 to 220 missing some
important stops along the way yeah
that's a three minute
and it's it's not over yet guys the
thing the the deep think it's ongoing as
we see
bishops relationships me too
um
again one of the things i've just
mentioned that these guys play so well
in time trouble bishop c2 is not
the move that you you're instantly drawn
to you you're withdrawing your bishop
you're blocking the c file you just
enjoy the fact that the bishop is much
better placed offensively into this it's
just a very good move it's just it's
just such a nice diagonal to aim for the
one the one on b3 i think the reason why
i might have discovered it is because
i'm
without it you know b5
b4 is i i'm getting really scared yeah
you don't want to be you don't want to
be allowing that i don't and uh the move
oh excuse me the move bishop c2
definitely sidesteps it as b5 b3
is not coming
instantly before probably just quite
comfortably met by a4 there and we want
to put the bishop on b3 next move
um
the idea annoys me so much that i
actually tried to calculate knight c3
check b takes c3 b3 but it never works
nice uh it just never ever works we
don't have enough attackers on the queen
side to justify doing this
and bishop a3
look at this
you know bishop takes a3 i have
completely missed that the move even
existed
you can't touch the bishop but i guess
just bishop b3 and then rookie g1 and
the beans are annoying yeah this is
actually now
a mess
black is a
one but two pawns
just took on a3 but after the fourth
move it should be through i mean what
else can you do here exactly but those
pins are nasty these are they're very
real yeah right okay
uh
we took a bond congratulations right
let's say i dropped the bishop all the
way back but even here i mean bishop g5
is interesting but let's say if i just
take and go rookie g1 how do you
preserve the material get out rook ed1
rook c5 is a threat between e4 is a
threat
not immediately but why don't i have a
check on f5
5 sorry i thought yeah i'm i'm missing
checks is that 57 you've got queen f5 25
and you want pineapple then you just
dump in everything efficiency we have
six right
but no
if if in this moment we could have maybe
a repetition but you can do it on the
previous movement start focusing seven i
apologize
yeah after rook d1 we can start yeah we
can start with this and that's
that's the song
so uh bishop fate yeah your bishop f8
you probably have to go bishop g5 bishop
g5 does but it does come at a very
opportune time because bishop b7 allows
queen e5
yeah those games would be okay that's
fine for black for a while that that
would be a a very nice rescue yeah yeah
perfectly timed by the way i i clip upon
with threats on the board and what else
do you do i mean f6 looks visually
unplayable
yeah it's just uh
i don't see an immediate refutation but
i think your hand will just not not
allow you yeah yeah yeah yeah you're not
allowed you will not be physically
capable of making that move on the board
yeah
and on a more serious note i guess
bishop takes f6 queen takes f6 rook eg1
probably wins that piece yeah also queen
e4
everything looks dangerous for black at
that point f6 bishop f6 queen for
instance and and
for 24
we're thinking that there's no way that
black will maintain
uh peter we're always impressed by your
extraordinary
knowledge of uh one minute by the way
for broke down
one minute no
one minute for for boggling and still
215 on on linear's clock but yeah we
should probably stick with this issue
we should probably stick with this i
wanted to ask uh are you familiar with
doctor strangelove
the uh i've watched the movie but it's
been a while yeah no it's just this hand
your hand physically won't let you play
that much without causing
this kind of version
yeah
bishop f8
on the board yeah i like the move bishop
g5 a lot it was very logical to play
yeah
because of this very nice trick
that alejandro mentioned bishop e7 queen
takes e5
now that the e pawn is not being
defended by the rook on e8 that comes
perfectly timed
and bishop
g5 and the clocks uh alejandro uh one
minute almost for bogdan and two minutes
12 for lanier and yeah i was looking at
bishop e7 which the angels do say is the
best move bishop e7 yeah bishop beside
queen e5 yeah queen e5
rook e5 and i was thinking why is this
so good for white because i could take
on g5 you actually think with the rook
and the funny thing is your knight is
still pinned yeah g6 because this is g6
it's hanging and if you go knight e7
you're not better no no i mean
amongst other uh goodies yeah oh my well
if you don't do this what what do you do
in the current position your work's
attacked do you have a bunch of pins on
you if you don't play bishop e7 what's
your what's your backup i was trying to
figure out if rook d7 actually loses
material and that was my question as
well i couldn't really come to any to
come to any
definitive conclusions but the issue is
let's say rookie g1 you play queen five
check even queen e4 is surprisingly
annoying he's under 10 seconds 10
seconds
six played he goes six for it the
andrews also thought rook 26 was good
uh they just thought bishop pizza was a
cleaner draw because now you do have to
find some moves okay including this like
queen e4 rookie d1 that peter was
advocating for this end games are not
always very good for black despite being
up two pawns yeah despite being two
pawns up the the one we were discussing
i mean it's
considering he is on 38 seconds we
shouldn't really uh go back and write
moves he hasn't made but yeah there are
some positions in which you know you
trade queens the knight escapes the pin
and then the rook lands on c7 and the
pressure against the f7 pawn is just so
massive that
so
two extra pawns become you know
don't say it
trifles what did you call it i did
trifles no yeah those were some
different extra pawns not these ones
sacrilege i mean this isn't amazing uh
so we're starting with queenie four are
we
queenie four is a move yeah kunifor is
one way to to go about things rookie g1
would be a very natural second attempt i
don't know which one is stronger
uh rook dwanky no it doesn't i wanted to
say it creates an idea of rook g5 from
d5 queen e4 but then uh rook g4 would be
a way to unpin yourselves nine moves
left yeah and they both they both under
a minute
you don't see lanier except for his
hands and you can feel that he's under
pressure i know but both but both
players are kind of rocking here i mean
i i don't know daniel's got some nervy
hand which is going to do one rookie d1
played
one there's absolutely only one move for
black that's pretty clear at this point
you do have to get out of the get out of
the pin yeah 25 check needs to be played
not surprisingly because nothing else
really makes any sense whatsoever the
rook on the 8th has no good squares and
yeah something will be
king a1 how does it how would you
continue peter we go knight somewhere
this would be six c7 yeah i want to go
knight b6 knight c4 this is why i chose
b6 ah of course you're gonna block me
you're just gonna try
four seconds and it turns out four
seconds and eternity
and eternity oh daniel he's just playing
it but this game is just so crazy i
can't believe he's leaving himself so
little time yeah king a1 is a movie he's
gotten up again and so he gets up but he
always goes to like the side right i
don't know if he's like a
a side chest thinker i don't think this
exists
i hate looking at a chest perfect yeah
exactly because it's impossible for me
you know i'm used to both boris
girlfriend
it's much easier to play blindfolded
than from the side exactly yeah for me
basically occasionally you get such a
huge postmortem with like the entire
lobby of the hotel analyzing analyzing
the same game and you're forced to to
occupy that kind of a weird sideways
position and you just failed like your
calculating ability fails because
everything looks weird and sort of
unnatural and natural yeah we have the
move queenie for king a1 was also an
attempt
both moves very interesting here posing
black some problems and the move queen
queen e4 still gives black a ton of
choices you could go knight b6 you could
trade on e4 you could i just says knight
b4 is also okay even though i wouldn't
actually though i would consider that
move yeah knight b4 yeah i would
consider an ip6 and returning the next
time
the issue with knight b6 is that you
allow takes takes rook c6
and then you have to play he's done it
he's done it yeah once again four
seconds and it's very important for you
here not to allow knight c4 if you allow
knight c4
you will be
unhappy
very you you're back to fighting for a
draw but by taking on the six i'm
playing rook c6 i don't know isn't there
g6 hanging
the bishop is on
one
in the way yeah we go nice 98 will be
the only move here i don't know once
again including queen e4 or not is a
above my pay grade but i had this and
here we go rook takes d6 bishop takes
rook takes e6 on the board no choice for
black bishop takes d6 yeah he clearly
doesn't want to take on e4 unless
absolutely forced to and near i think
very much would like him to improve his
structure and to take on e4 so i think
rook 6 is happening here
you can continue uh yeah playing 98 but
i'm guessing by this point you can just
simply take on a6 and say my bishops are
so strong that i'm not even remotely
wars and i think i i buy into that
argument oh we're very much mine to that
argument yeah i love the bishops in that
position after rook takes a6 so we are
expecting knight c8 since both people
there are some more forceful ideas but i
think the basics is just
i mean after knight c8 i thought maybe
it takes takes bishop c2 is something
but it allows e5 a4 i don't like
allowing you five before actually for
sure
that's not to be played it will be
played yeah i don't think there is
rook takes a6 uh reducing your deficit
to a single pawn and as you say my
bishops are prancing yeah the bishops
are really really strong here and they
are
these end games are just not better for
black at all yeah you always take how
much time yeah yeah exactly yeah i think
one minute for linear 44 seconds for
deck
six moves to make and rook takes a6
i'm not interested in any discussions
about
you know uh it's a very practical right
you just take and go from you love
playing this movie because you take a
pawn and now guess what it's your turn
yeah yeah yeah and also that yeah did
you say when i i just want to boldly
point out the obvious any bishop moves
like for example bishop jeff eight rook
takes g6 is an immediate splash which is
why you go king just seven and a half
years played king j7 you unpin the f7
pawn you hint at perhaps playing f6 or
a5 at some juncture in the future once
the queens come off because i think he
will eventually have to take on e4 i
don't think you can force linear to take
on a fight
exactly that's exactly right and the
queens will have to come off
um i'm i find myself drawn to the move
bishop c2 actually just because i
if i'm going to embrace a queen trade
i'd like to recapture with the bishop so
that i could play bishop to c6 yeah so
bishop c2 understand that you know if
you trade queens then i'm not saying
that that you're forced to this is what
draw
what my eye was was uh
drawn
to uh the c6 in the meantime don't we
don't need to show it on the screen but
i think the other game will finish in a
repetition in uh in quick time okay so
we are expecting yet another draw uh and
this one uh to continue yeah lydia goes
back to c6
basically trying to make it difficult
for bogdan to make proactive moves it
stops b7 because rook takes c8 tactics
will
be very much in play it very much
hamstrings
everything in black's position yeah not
the least of which also any bishop moves
might also invite rook c7 but i i hear
what you're saying rook takes c8 queen
takes f5 rook takes c8
it's just not a very comfortable
position eventually i think you do
something like queen takes e4 and then
either the immediate the f5 or f6
followed by five because you just need
to start giving your pieces some
breathing room exactly so and he's
reaching for his queen but he wants to
trade it whoa whoa
really daniel's playing with flyer after
this move this move does invite queen 25
25 looks very very strong i don't like
this oh boy
all of us said he probably will not lose
this but yeah after queen g7 i'm no
longer i'm no longer certain of this at
all yeah the engine says g4 is the ooh
i mean these were the ideas you were
predicting peter three hours ago and
he's gone queen d5 i don't know how
cringy five is a very natural yes
but g4
with the bishop on g5 would
also it looks really really good uh but
if you gave me this position i would
have played queen b5 myself yeah but i
think uh specifically because the e5
exists here is that the move maybe is
not the best because if e4f4 rookie five
is a very good source of
source of counterplay which i think is
very miscible
oh
you think that see that
he's gotten he's done e4 great find
there by keeping equality in the
position what really yes oh hold on hold
on i've got bishop f4
well that
that's a runaway e pawn it's kind of
amazing that the tactics don't work here
for for white they just don't seriously
okay so what happens before you just
before you simply e3 and i take a piece
yeah i take back with the knight ah i
wanted to go rookie 6 26 but queen takes
f7 is a bit strong
which is regrettable yeah it's kind of
funny here but after queen e7 why
doesn't even equalize
no
this is very cute wow the pawn is just
how much time did he have when he played
oh what a cool move though it stops
rookie five
because of bishop
d4 it repairs
oh i love this move practically speaking
i love this movie yeah and and i uh the
tension has
doubled up again yeah and this is move
38 right so yeah
they have gotten to very close to time
control but he's back to and he's taking
the pause
myself even further i think it's king h7
king h7
by the way yeah and i i lied to our
viewers about the mamijaro falireza game
because shaq chose to continue playing
he has some i guess light winning
chances it should still be possible but
i thought white couldn't be better but
he found a way to to keep the game
afloat
f6 played
wow six is a move that is very difficult
to make and i'm not sure if it's a good
one i don't think uh i think uh shaq
has a slight pull down on two seconds
and gets up from the board again
wow okay there is queen takes f3
yeah that's that's the default default
setting here is queen takes f3 but i
might be completing
i mean no way i'm trying to calculate
all kinds of bishop xf6 silliness but it
doesn't seem to work in in any kind of a
setting so yeah i guess you just default
to you know winning the pawn back it
does allow rookie one check but the king
is reasonably safe on a2 because we
control the a7 square with our bishop on
d4
sort of sort of queen of three uh check
king a2 bishop e5 might be clever
because bishop takes a5 queen e7 and a7
is actually a
bit of an issue ten seconds nine eight
and seven and ticking and ticking and
he's done it and he has played it yeah i
think rookie one check happens but if
all else fails we can actually play king
c2
yeah that's what i wanted to say peter
is there something to be such a
suggestion for king c2
and frankly we're probably not much
worse after rook c1 but we don't want to
be playing roxy one because we want to
preserve the i mean the rook on six is
very very beautiful we don't want to
trade it away
this is still a very sharp position this
is more recent
okay so linear actually made the time
control but he's still he's still at the
board to to wait for his opponent to
make a move rook cafe chosen i think
because of king c2 after the check rook
and they have gotten to move forward
now he's inviting once again queen d oh
the queen d5 you still have queen f5
jack 24 yeah yeah yeah
yeah he could bishop played queenie
queen f5 instead of rook cafe we've made
time control so this will take a while
right but queen f5 was fine for black in
this position because after take stakes
yeah the end game the structure is bad
but
i mean g3 is also hanging yeah and you
have you have currently more pawns yeah
so you have leeway to perhaps give
something up along the way
and the freaky one was also good but
rook f8
you want king c2 and then maybe
something clever but what that something
clever is i think even queen f5
no but the seat is hanging right sorry
so you can't really do that anymore this
is why he didn't play rookie one is
because he probably couldn't think of a
move in this position with f6 with f6
hanging with chip
rook takes f6 possibilities in case the
bishop moves
okay we understand the
the
time control has been reached and the
player's taking a little breather but
uh
before we do the same and take a break
uh guys
just tell me the move after queen d5
because i'm gonna look at seven maybe
queen e we don't need to unveil
ourselves it's a kind of a
yeah
oh
that i am not liking any of those that
is not yeah the engine is not liking any
of this here i'm not liking any of this
wow that's going south it's the 40th
move bogdan was the
good recipient of richard's blundering
for this it's not a blunder
it's not a blunder at all but it makes
this task very hard
because after queen d5 you are so tied
up it feels it's just so difficult to
even name a move yeah like everything is
everything is completely tied up
yeah i mean the best move by the engine
is rookie yeah i was wondering
e a returned to either ea to d8 or
something yeah wow okay that's going to
be hard it's going to be a difficult
move great compensation now for
uh linear as he's upon down but his
bishops are absolutely working this is
remember when i was saying the bishop on
h6 doesn't tie in
which square do you like and i like d4
default was not entirely available at
the time it wasn't but i like it now
we're going to take a break and we will
return shortly for more coverage of
round six as we have two
games still in progress stay tuned
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to what probably will be
the final segments of the segment of
today's round with only two games still
running after the first time control
algorithm is defending a slightly
trickier engagement against shakira and
the very very uh unusual position
potentially on the board very soon in
the other game between dominguez and
dayak and this is the standings with two
games still running uh
bogdan deck at some point was
threatening to join the leaders at uh at
four points uh a piece with wesley and
leon already there but
current position actually indicates that
he is much likelier to to lose than to
win
uh withdrawal potentially still favored
over everything but
the year made significant strides in
that game yeah it was this
time trouble
that we expected between the two players
and uh lanier came out on top
although i must say during our break as
we're as we're looking at the position
uh queen e7 we had stopped right here
after queen e6 yeah that was even before
the break you showed me
six and i started i started moaning
about not liking my position very much
yeah and then we do this but bishop
takes g3 and you try to play this ending
i have a feeling maybe you have to start
with queen take c6 i'm not sure if
there's a difference i'm kind of drawn
to ideas of giving made with bishop
takes f6 but they probably don't work
i don't have enough squares anyway you
you can take on c8 and this is the end
game i was referring to because you
don't see that particular material
balance on or imbalance on the board
very often white takes on e6 the rooks
get traded and black takes on h4
and uh
without the con without the queen side
it's probably a reasonably easy draw i
don't think the side with the three
pawns has much much in the way of
winning chances but also of course no
risk whatsoever with the pawn still left
on the queen side it becomes a very
non-standard race where you assume the
b5 pawn will eventually get picked up
perhaps even immediately with before in
bishop d7 that that would also be my
guess too
at least first
yeah yeah but on the other hand perhaps
the more relevant factor in in the
position is to bring the king closer to
where the the play is so maybe you start
with kingston king d3 and then you
re-evaluate
and the big question here is just how
quickly those do those three
run on the king side or maybe not here
there is another move though that caught
my eye
uh was the move bishop c5 because you
are threatening to grab this guy also
with a check so uh yeah this is a
different end game i go queen e6 you
basically take c6 oh you don't even take
on the faith first no i'm trying to keep
i'm trying to put the ropes that is
clever yeah this is very clever and i
don't know
with the rooks or without the rooks
alejandro it feels like lanier's for
choice well definitely for choice but
perhaps not as winning as you guys seem
to think queen e7 queen e6 is definitely
a possibility you have to take on g3 and
now let me go through both variations
because they're both dangerous for black
definitely the end the end game that you
guys were mentioning first of all yeah
the engines don't seem to be like super
clear about it i'm sure that something a
little bit stronger would but bishop d7
they think is the best move and the
engines just chuck the pawn they don't
even try to defend it with the move b4
which is not bad but they want to play
something along the lines of king f7 f5
and push them all together they're
saying it's an advantage white but it's
smaller and the more they think the
smaller it gets so very likely this
actually with proper play ends up being
a draw not guaranteeing it though the
other variation with the move queen e7
queen e6 bishop takes on g3 and then
this clever move bishop c5 i actually
like this a lot
the thing is that after take stakes rook
e8 you have to take on c8 rookie is i
think the only move in this position
well rookie chair is also moved but
let's not talk about that bishop c8
bishop h4 we have a very similar
scenario in which you have to wonder do
you prefer having the rooks on or off or
white
and it's not such an obvious choice
right i don't know yeah it's hard to say
because with the rooks better chances to
catch the uh the past pause but exactly
you also give yourself counter play as
black and in some cases an extra
body to throw at the b pawn if necessary
right in order to stop it so both end
games favorable for white neither end
game clearly winning according to the
computers now let me draw your attention
because queen e6 is not the only move in
this position the engines are thinking
you know what that's all very nice and
very good the engine is
the end games are a two result position
but why don't i just go attack
whoa start with the move h g4 if you
take just go h5 take advantage of the
fact that black is playing without any
activity and just go kill the guy uh
these bishops are beautiful the rook is
very well placed these pawns are not
queening as long as this monster on d5
is alive and you're not gonna exchange
that anytime soon and just open up that
king h takes g6 is coming the attack is
coming and black will find it very
difficult to survive now of course the
tough part of this is first of all
finding g4 i'm not going for a position
near a piece because it looks so much
better the engine is not sure which one
offers one more winning chances for
white both leave white ahead but
it's hard to make a choice here
and yeah wow i'm just done by g4 yeah i
think we will get back to the you know
horrible time travel by both
very soon in terms of moves i mean in
terms of in terms of time we know
exactly when that will happen it will
happen in in about half an hour right uh
from now but in terms of moves
really it feels to me that both of them
are and linear does have a very
difficult choice right now i mean
choosing between those two because g4 i
considered but i wasn't really sure it
was
you're attracted to it because of just
how passive the black position is right
and you you start thinking you know with
my piece is so gorgeous and black's
piece is not really going anywhere at
all
shouldn't i try sorry shouldn't i try to
exploit it in the most forceful way
possible by opening up the king side
but
you're already upon down you you
sacrifice a second one in playing g4 and
h5 doesn't even create an immediate
threat of you know anything lethal right
giving seemingly black a lot of time to
try and somehow come to grips with this
kind of new direction the game is taking
so i wasn't sure at all but yeah it's
not it doesn't surprise me that the
engines like it uh that much but
choosing choosing between uh
those end games and the position where
you're trying to give made down a number
of pawns is
not going to be easy for them here so
for me i mean i really thought it was uh
winning the piece full stop but winning
the piece with the rooks on the board or
winning the piece with just the bishops
on the board uh your knee-jerk reaction
would be to keep the rooks or to take
them off i think i'm taking them off i
that's why yeah i think it's uh the
pawns run a lot slower without the rooks
on i think it's the bishops are
extremely good the bishop player
specifically is extremely extremely good
at containing passers
uh
and uh
for you alejandro uh you would take away
without the rocks without the rooks also
uh
and
i heard you mentioning peter that maybe
you should just bring the king over to
the zone yeah i'm not sure sort of all
the way to before but just kind of give
yourself a little bit of leeway in terms
of you know not only depending on your
light pieces or on your minor pieces to
protect against let's say the h passer
running
just
i don't know if i want to you know over
overdo it with king e2 here but so g3 is
good enough for me and then we
re-evaluate then we then we actually
start attacking the b-pawn and seeing
maybe b4 or yeah before bishop d7 it's
interesting to me that but basically i
think you could the computer just gave
up the point i would kind of like hang
on to it as long as i could be seven
right i mean
i want it to be a distraction i don't
want you just to take it and then run no
but this is maybe because we allowed
king of seven and five and now b7 exists
as a move so perhaps if you want to
attack it you need to attack it straight
away and king c2 is just inaccurate i i
wouldn't be surprised at that at all
yeah because if you have to defend it
from the one square like if you play
before bishop c5 bishop b1 here i will
just go king xi king d1
uh do that we're doing
yeah i'm bringing the king closer to
where the play will be and i'm also
picking up the problem anyway
okay um
intriguing uh that this is
uh for me it's
that this type of decision-making isn't
something
you could calculate so well it's just
your instinct of like your bishops can
dominate the palms yeah and and also i
think uh it very much depends on just
how fearless you are i'm not
particularly fearless i feel i feel that
uh
we pretty much never marriage is
overrated
we pretty much never ever lose this
without the rooks on and with the rooks
on if if things start going south
south yeah they go south uh in a much
more dramatic manner also one of the
other things i really you know like we
all
when gary lost a deep blue it was sort
of like armageddon now the computers are
better than us
but one of the things that i think that
computers have really brought to chess
and proved chess is this idea that
there's so many
different possibilities that we didn't
think of and the computer's
recommendation of g4 i mean i would i
see queen e6 i stop
and then i kind of look at the other two
variations of whether or not i want to
be a rook
rook's on the board or not but g4
and the computer is just saying hey and
also maybe once again because of my
still not entirely failing eyesight
g3
after the quincy two debacle i'm not
gonna give you ten tries but
[Laughter]
i just i'm gonna take that part i've
seen what it says after g3
our computer in the studio is not
the highest the highest depth right go
backwards go back enough yeah go go back
one move yeah g3 make a move
i did i took uh
i mean i wouldn't have been asking oh
sorry you mean queen g5 or something
this allows unifor check it's a very
beautiful move but it allows 24 checks
so it doesn't do nearly enough now
okay but it might give you an idea like
if i give you this hint you will know
but it might give you an idea of the
move
just a second just second to second h6
no no no no no
if i'm telling you queen g5 24 is kind
of a hint right
oh then i go bishop c2 and mate you king
a2 it was no oh that sounds pretty
that's very pretty
that is i was thinking that i would play
bishop c2 or something but i no it just
it just stops queenie for checking
advance it goes no no no no no no it
goes bishop c2 immediately no it does
king a2 as i as i said it just goes at
once
so sidestrapping queen e4 says um a7 is
never going to be available for checks
but e1 and e4 were prior to this right
now they aren't that's make a move right
your turn yeah yeah and that's not so
easy to make it not easy to make a move
here at all yeah king a2 is a kind of a
remarkable resource here and now we
think about prophylactic
oh my gosh
that is pretty yeah i'm not sure i'm not
sure i'm not sure what the threat is but
it's just so difficult to make a move
yeah i was attracted to queen g5
but after king a2
yeah what a what what a concept
but
there's a lot more grand chest stores
coming our way as we take a look at the
schedule that we've got in store for
2022 here we go starting with
warsaw yeah coming up warsaw coming up
very much on the heels of this one so we
uh we have back to back tournaments in
may and then back-to-back tournaments in
october august september we take a break
for the candidates basically and broken
up yeah by the candidates and then a
very exciting event in zagreb where
magnus carlsen will uh will play in the
jersey ceo
coming to saint louis of course for the
uh saint louis rapid and blitz
immediately followed by the final uh
stop on the tour the sinkfield cup
uh a classical
and the players who are moving on to
warsaw include
these players many many of the current
many of the current cast but also a lot
of new faces uh you we will see
obviously the polish contingent
represented by youngsters of duda and uh
radhik voitershek
vishe comes makes an appearance and
there's also two very exciting ukrainian
players playing
uh playing in warsaw uh the the young
hiroshenko who uh impressed very much in
in 2021 and
uh you know the ever young anton korobov
who ever will we all know and love
absolutely by the way jan do that
qualifying at such an early age as well
to the candidates how do you rank his
chances in the candidates
yeah he definitely uh you know feels
like a very very uh decent kind of a
dark horse but for the whole thing
because uh
uh he has a decent uh decent result
against magnus which i mean the
candidate is not against magnus but it's
a it's a kind of a useful benchmark
in general terms and uh he's extremely
motivated
generally very very well prepared uh
he's also taking a bit of a sabbatical
due in part of course to the the
calendar not returning fully to you know
the calendar isn't isn't as busy as it
would have been in previous years due to
the the pandemic and recently he came
from behind to in the melt water
magnus that was great yeah what a photo
finish
that is a obviously a slightly different
genre of events
you know it puts wind in your sails to
know you can win such a great tournament
any tournament you win uh in front a
head of magnus is is very good for your
self-confidence no i'm a huge i'm a huge
fan of youngster i've i've been a huge
fan of his for
for quite some time but the field is
very very stacked which is why you don't
like it it feels a bit of an insult to
not even name him among i don't know the
top three favorites but the field is
way way too stacked and you you have to
choose people who have experience of
playing and perhaps even winning the
candidates i think whether they're
fabulous another one of my you know
spiels which i give every now and again
is that
uh and yeah we'll we'll maybe get back
to that or maybe not here but this is
the price fund uh as you can see 1.4
million very very nice
and the classic events getting the big
bucks at 750 sorry peter yeah and also i
wanted to point out something that we
don't really bring up uh as often is
that there is uh the tour points and the
the special tour prizes for people
uh
first second and third yeah playing the
full the full tour and there's very nice
you know additional prizes for
um
most successful players on the tour
getting that bonus money
very very nice and uh 20 years young
dude how old is dude i think he's a bit
older now but not i mean they're all
kids but they're all kids
youth is unsound what do we have
alejandro uh
after queen d5 queen e7 has lanier moved
and by the way you're not really asking
24 you're not really asking me that
question uh yeah
sorry sorry yeah then your husband made
a move of course he hasn't made it his
thing is down to nine minutes and 24
seconds meanwhile wow in the game of
shock and fusion uh frieza also thought
forever after getting into
uh this four versus four because he made
time control here after the move f5
whoops the move f5 and perhaps he
realized his position wasn't so easily
drawn i'm not sure but he spent forever
just moving his king up the board you
can see the 22 minute thing on king f6
and after rook a1 it seems like he's
going back into the thing the computers
obviously think he's completely fine uh
you do have a little bit of a weakness
on the c3 pawn you can imagine his king
coming to c2 or k3 will gobble it up and
give wide real winning chances but
there's a couple of ways to make the
draw one is to start counter play with
rook b8 rook b2 and harass the pawns on
f2 and h2 it'll give you enough counter
play even if you lose the c3 pawn as
long as you don't lose it completely for
free and the other line is to just play
the move knight e4 ask why do you
actually want to take on e4 if you don't
the knight hops are annoying knight c5
knight d2 all kind of hops are not
really that nice and if but if you take
take and you go king c2 this kind of
positions are a draw
even if you drop the c3 pawn honestly
because the king does get pretty active
you can go king g5 start threatening
king g4 king f3 rook f8 is also a threat
attacking the pawn on f2 so
it's not a hundred percent
clear cut how you make the draw you
still have a couple of weaknesses but it
is within reach to find and this is the
times here and this is the only thing
that's worrying me about alireza's
position is that he's down to six
minutes and a very very uh
uh strange decision show uh there by uh
by bogdan who after the community
more or less instantly by his standards
actually instantly playing dna
d8 which
rejected is uh not playable
okay i guess he thought maybe he has
some kind of a perpetual after rook c8
and queen takes d6 but the machine
variation would suggest that there is no
perpetual there
uh and the king can go towards the
center and avoid checks so perhaps maybe
towards the b4 square why c1 and g2
that's just king dc1 yeah yeah king c1
and rook c8 king d2 you're out of checks
already so you give a check from f1
we go king d2 queen let's say which is
just and i think we go towards just go
bishop d1
yeah that as well
yeah that was that as well i was
thinking we were going to if we landed
on b4 even better we were perfectly even
happier yeah yeah yeah and and and
quickly
right yeah
actually not that happy i i kind of
stopped myself midway there because we
go queen g to check here okay nc3 rook
c8 and if i go king before 22 check is
kind of annoying
oh no which is something that i
originally didn't appreciate because we
don't have bishop c3 blunder is the
queen so i have to take on b5 pretty
much and queen d3 check
and maybe we're still winning but
it's
sort of getting dicey yeah it's a less
it's less clear-cut than i thought we do
have the mate on the other side of the
board so as long as we blunder b3
without check we're still winning yeah
you know quote-unquote blunder but it's
nice that we're covering b8 and we're
covering ac but how do we stop yeah okay
okay check
and now we go king before queen g2 and
we have an improvement of something yeah
king b5 queen d3 and bishop c4 and the
gx have actually run out
so that was very quick you guys
calculated very quickly they only have
queen a5 instead of queen d3
yeah i'm not at your level yet ever
maybe
king c4 i was hoping rook c8 king d3
queen b5 king g2 i take probably sharp
it doesn't direct this is always made
yeah this is always made on the other
side of the board yeah so it feels like
there is maybe even leeway there for for
linear to choose because bishop d1 the
move that alejandro was suggesting a lot
earlier yeah let's finish showing the
mate and now queen g7 basically against
any move
yeah but after cleaning the function
yeah after after queen of fun check move
45
uh
we can probably just go as a hunter
indicator just go bishop g1 here rook c8
king d2
looks like cringy
looks very safe and we are we're home
and dry pretty much
yeah our bishop is really doing a great
job covering everything yeah this is
this is why the bishop bear is is just
so good around your king because it just
controls it controls every single square
our entire variation was correct
the entire thing king b4 allowing rook a
the whole thing is correct and black is
just busted but we're also correct at
the evaluation of bishop d1 which is the
confusing part to me about the move
queen d8 because it is pretty clear cut
right queen f1 bishop d1 yeah king d2
might win faster
is a stronger move wins faster better
technique but you don't have to make
that decision right now you can make
that decision down the road
but if you see bishop d1 from afar
that helps you land on this position
yeah you'll untangle at some point and
two bishops i'm picking those end games
over this yeah in a split second i'm
very confused i'm very confused by
bogdan's choice because so far in this
tournament he's been
pretty much
faultless in these types of sports
yeah and here it is just that the two
bishops are dominating the rook i mean
truly
truly
dominating and i know it probably won't
be very relevant because we just saw
queen e68 but g4 also kind of just wins
here
yeah and unsurprisingly it's just such
an improvement to those lines as well
like g4 yeah
maybe even h5 again right no queen e4
checks yeah for you yeah rookie never
works because bishop f6 also queen of
seven checked
out basically
so you can't you can't just can't make
moves you the rook is stuck because of
queen of seven the knight is stuck and
the hg we go just h5 gh and then
something yeah i guess yeah once once we
opened up everything then something like
queen of five will win or something yeah
i guess and once the checks start they
never stop
yeah
when do you appreciate this is such a
strange decision
a bad choice and lanier
now having
the luxury
of choosing between wins
rook c8 and queen d6 i i agree with you
too
uh alejandro that bishop d1 is
that's pretty good
pretty good
one win per chamber per game is all
you're going to need and the clock uh
still linear regardless of how
how good his position might be we can
counting on him to have just minutes and
seconds yeah to make his moves but i
think in particular if he takes on c8
and d6 so for such an experienced time
trouble player as he is the positions
will be simple enough
to steer them without really
too much
uh
and in the other game by the way we did
see the move i i
wanted to say that i i thought the move
94
uh made the most sense uh as opposed to
rook v8
agree it's the most human way to draw
this exactly exactly and uh
i i just had this one question for you
bishop takes pawn takes king c2 king g5
h3 rook
here i thought yes one yeah that's
correct well we can probably go h5 here
i was thinking yeah like h5 it doesn't
seem like a bad move at all to me you
guys can also just you know save your
pawn yeah but
but then i had some
nice tricky ways of maybe doing
something okay
like what
that's not very specific yes
yeah and uh
shaq has gone with f2f3 which f2 f3 yeah
okay
so trying to keep his uh
hopes alive and again as we entered the
competition for today's round we felt
that there were a few games where
victories were really required between
the players this was one of them uh both
players are so desperate it seems like
nobody is going to be winning this one
yes yeah but if anybody's going to win i
would guess it's shock
the opponent's e3 falls but the issue
here is that four versus three yeah even
if if all else fails we go knight takes
d3 we play i don't know h7 h6 h5 there
or what have you and the thing is that
if you get into those four versus three
you didn't play f5 to do so right yeah
f5 is an ugly move to play five is not
what you want in those structures for
sure yeah even though it's probably
holdable remains remains a draw i would
assume
is there a clever way to
not do any of that yeah the engine plays
knight d2 but then we get into
complications then we then we really
have to fight right
because you can give a check you can go
f4 after that
and even though the engine says 0-0
i don't know the rook and the bishop
might combine to do some magic
yeah the rook and the knight are never
going to combine to do anything right
now but the rook and the bishop i mean
they're attacking f5 c3 is weak it's not
not so easy it's not true no not at all
not easy at all no
no
and uh if there is a clever move against
four minutes in particular because it
once again gives alireza a choice and i
think you know alireza perhaps out of
the you know the modern 18 year olds he
is about as
little affected by this as uh he can be
because he i think he is a very good
technical player person to begin with
and secondly doesn't really hate dry
technical positions which is something i
personally like i would be
absolutely distraught at the idea of
playing something boring against a
player twice my age and twice my
experience
uh but yeah this is a choice where yes
he probably suspects knight have to
check knight takes d3 makes a draw but
on four minutes like perpetual time
trouble until the rest of the game kind
of annoying end game where
you can drift into problems and we have
a couple of new moves in the linear game
we can just probably take a
look on the board as
well we did go for into rooftops here
but kind of curiously deck didn't check
on yeah
checks right now so he he tried queen g8
and then he replied with queen e6 which
is a cute move if it works and it looks
like it works yeah because queen takes
d4 queen e7 even picks up the rook with
this check importantly yeah so you don't
even have to calculate any kind of
perpetuals there because you give weight
on the other side of the board pretty
much yeah but this move also sets up for
you know we've got we've got this uh d1
square covered we
it sounds also like how do you how do
you even make a move in this position
yeah i mean
right
yeah exactly and we might one day just
be terrifyingly enough threatening
bishop c5 because i mean we are we are
we are over selling bogdan's position it
is plus five and you can resign there's
just no no real movement it feels it
feels over it feels just straight up
over now because uh
and that was very very abrupt because i
i think the end game was probably
holdable honestly it would at least been
a long
interesting fight yeah yeah even if you
lose it eventually with black it was
right here when uh
daniel played the move queen d8 which
really uh take on g3 either immediately
or or after trading the games and we we
had been focused focusing all our
attention on this rather unusual i want
to say
uh three pawns versus uh the bishop but
uh
not to be uh we we are not we're not
seeing that and uh
yeah and this is one of those cases
where you can i mean definitively say
that the choice was incorrect it's not
it's not a matter of taste whether you
choose this or what he chose yeah what
he chose just straight up loses exactly
and it's even difficult to figure out
exactly what he missed because you don't
need to understand how unclear the peace
down end game is to understand this is
completely lost especially after you've
just seen this move queen e6 and you go
okay maybe this is your turn
maybe this is what he means but let's
say i go queen c5 for queen effect every
every move was winning i mean even the
end game is hopeless
yeah the end game by far the the least
the least option but even that probably
is quite comfortably winning the queen
e6
and by the way just as we go to the
shacking
alireza shaking his head
not a lot of fun huh how did and you
said something peter that kind of like
made me think 18 year old
with good technique
wow how do you get good technique as an
18 year old you play a lot of chess yeah
you you put the volume in but plus i
think you know with him i'm very safe
just saying
tremendous amounts of natural talent
you know he's one of those people
occasionally you get people who like by
sort of universally people say he just
doesn't misplace pieces very much you
know
one of those people one of those players
who just sort of innately
puts pieces on corrects like yeah you
make them drop pieces on the board they
will they will drop on good squares and
uh
famously that was what gary kasparov
said about vladimir kramnik he knows
where
the pieces go yeah
i think i think he's very much in that
category i think he yeah uh that is why
we all talk about him in such exalted
exalted tones it's not like
i remember like some of the
i've actually seen this in chat today i
have uh
kind of weird chat window open on my
screen and there's a you know somebody
somebody called him the second coming of
wei
uh and uh i mean it's kind of a funny
joke but that was sort of the issue with
wei
who was an an incredibly exciting
prospect at 15 like he was 27 30 and by
age by age 15 or something it's crazy
yeah
but
you could clearly see that there were
some things he was doing at the like
2900 level and some other things he was
clearly playing like a 15 year old right
who still has you know you know time to
grow and like it's not a criticism
you're allowed to be 15 when you're 15.
you know exactly but uh we're not really
seeing
that much of that in alireza like you
you you give him a tactical position he
will give made you give him a technical
position he will win it slowly and
precisely and right
um
i must say that uh for for me magnus was
also one of those
extraordinary talents that uh as he
started playing
against the very best at a very young
age he was his his play was very mature
i mean it was a remarkable yeah he could
play every kind of position for me the
like i've
we all were aware that this isn't
there's this norwegian keith who
everybody is telling us will be the next
world champion but
uh for me really kind of the
breakthrough moment was we were playing
in a close uh around robin in uh for us
and he won a game against alexis sheroff
where he got basically nothing out of a
catalan some kind of a very very dry
completely equal
end game position
against
arguably one of the best end game
players of the last three generations
and he just outplayed him very quietly
he was 15 at the time and i was watching
it in li like happening
before my eyes in real time not even on
the screen i was walking in the playing
hall playing my own game and i thought
something weird is happening here
because like this game is not supposed
to be there's not supposed to be any
intrigue in it right because you know
sheriff is doing this to people not
people doing it the sheriff
and i thought yeah probably there is
something something to this something is
going on here yeah
and uh you felt that uh rook c7 uh it's
funny in this position i was wondering
if i
were in black shoes whether i would be
thinking about playing the move g5 g4 to
try to get another pair of pawns traded
off the board as quickly as possible i
know that i'm going to lose this pawn
but i'm going to get a check in and
you'll have to take it with the king and
yeah i was wondering about which
structure we're aiming for exactly so
exactly so like for example let me just
put it moves down on the board so i
would go say g5 you would go say rook c1
i would hit you with a check
so stick with the king and we go g4
yeah and i was thinking okay would i go
in this direction or exactly how would i
play this if i
was and uh and shah actually cleverly is
picking up the pawn in a different
fashion you're not going rook c1 i think
precisely because of rook dji check he's
going king [ __ ] to rook a3
which allows him to
well capture the pawn in the nicest way
in a nicer way with the rook in front of
the king still already already capable
of giving checks and i'm assuming that i
want to get my king
close to the king's side prior to
making any this is annoying you're going
to have to defend four versus four and
it's not
versus three sorry four versus three but
this is not a pleasant structure right
this is not the nice yeah you put your
pawns on f7 g6 h5 and you wait if you
wait you put the king there you're gonna
you're gonna have to actively defend
yeah right and there are some it will
come down to calculation at some point
and you better calculate it properly and
they're they're i can see serious
problems for example if you play rook a7
here
and i play rook
c6 i think we give checks right we give
rookie tour and rook a3 take my pawn no
no no no no no no no you don't want it
no i go rook a3 here row k3 i provoke
rook c3 i go back to a2 okay
um i'm not saying this is easily drawn
but like i'm not i'm not biting on that
particular topic yeah yeah okay
uh yeah
obviously i don't really want to play
rook a2 i want to
more or less try to
try to take advantage of the king's
position if i could
but uh i'm not exactly sure how i'm
how i'm going to do that um
oh boy
yeah
unfortunately i really don't see
anything better at the moment than
rooksy too but yeah if you have to play
roxy looking it so it feels like it it
should be
really reasonably reasonably comfortable
i was just thinking you know like
isn't there a way to really exploit the
fact that uh
the king is only five yeah
so rook here you went rook here he's
gone roxy's six yeah yeah it's an
attractive idea in particular against
the minute just to try and do this
concretely try and uh with the king
sitting here on this kind of
awkward square right
yeah but
the double check is very very annoying
maybe we can go all the way to f1 by the
way kingitsu and then right let's let's
give that a shot again what i'm angling
for is the trade of this h2 pawn for
this g7 pawn
uh after for example but i think once
again i think rook a3 is just the move
here
because i don't think you're trading g7
for e3 that i think black holes quite
comfortably it's specifically trying to
trade g7 for h2 is what white white is
trying to exercise inside by the way the
players are going in the in our
direction yeah he's going rook a3 i mean
technique
zero
zero thought dedicated 18 years old and
plays
very very good
alejandro you're you're obviously the
coach of the national uh champions
when players come
into your charge
do you focus on in-game technique or are
the players everybody plays attacking
games and tactics very well i think
i wouldn't say that and games
i would say end games is one of the
things we look at the least the least
yeah i try to focus on what people have
problems with and it normally hasn't
been in games yet i mean i have seen a
lot of problems in end games with some
of my players but
it's something that we do work on once
in a while but there's so much else to
look at chess that recently it feels
that you analyze the end game through
the lenses of the opening
more than that you just look at random
end games
and i but i have made some of my players
redo four versus three and redo three
versus two and redo three versus three
with a past a pawn
like yes like draw it by memory stop
thinking you need to know this by memory
right
okay fair enough rook endings being the
most
common yeah and this is this is what you
normally get and uh
uh
yeah knowing knowing the patterns and
how to how to defend let's say yeah
three versus three with a beep on you
know from the yeah one of my students
lost three versus three versus i think a
b-pan or a c-pawn
and
last time that ever happens yeah
never
you would think but i mean those are
legitimately tricky yes those are
like strong players lose them uh i
defeated spielman with three horses too
yeah yeah i remember i i had it uh
on the stronger side against vladimir
kapon in
2002 european club cop i think and uh
i started the end game with like the
very very clear idea that i will never
even come close to winning because you
know i had the greatest respect for my
opponent he was sort of my elder and
clearly kind of i always felt that he
understands chess better than i do and
so on
and they just won it very easily
very disturbing yeah because it's
annoying to hold because you
legitimately at some point start facing
problems and if you make one mistake
somewhere it compounds and maybe it's
still a draw but now you like have one
very very specific way to make a draw
that involves a lot of calculations so
you also run short on time and
yeah it's just it's just no fun to it's
just no fun to defend and that's the
story of these two guys right what was
the previous game between them the one
that was decisive it was alareza with
the white pieces i believe against shock
two versus one rook and game in the
europa league championship no but that
was just legitimately a study
it was a study but he didn't have to get
to the point where it was a study right
yeah it's it's unfortunate that we can't
bring it up on the screen now because
that is a very very instructive study
for my eyes because
rook g6 could i think he wants h5 h4
right because kg1 rookie two gives him
enough count to play i think he wants h5
h4 but does he make a giant lego g4
first of all g4 secondly even rook h7
exists see i'm i'm not sure what he
wants exactly right you can start giving
checks but then yeah he goes like he
goes h5 but now did he calculate this
well enough rook takes g7 he's going to
play h4
then there's this king and pawn in game
then first of all this and secondly your
g4 move is also very very strong he's
gone king of six fights
so this is clever and this probably
limits the g4 ideas but it leaves the
rook h7 ideas on the table because we
will have to put the rook on
exactly a non-g file square because rg8
king of seven does nothing
well in that case rook g8 king have
seven and f rook g5 and the f4 but i
don't want to play f4 i'm not sure i
want to play f4
i understand i understand yeah i don't
think i want to play f4 if i can help it
but let's say we go rook i don't know g8
king of seven rook a8 exactly
and then and if you play h4 with player
chain
and now you play rook h8 but my question
is
i have a feeling h3 i still have check
and king
rookie one right
no king of two i apologize but i think
actually
simply h3 might be a draw hg i'm not
playing unless somebody tells me table
base says it's a draw right and even
then not yeah i'm not i'm not touching
that game with a barge bowl i see and we
do have rook g8 by the way i i had a a
very nice uh match with
the cla von chuck
and uh i
had four versus three in a rook ending i
had a favorable side
and i actually think that vaseline
played it brilliantly well it's like one
of the best holds i've ever
come up against draw
second game
i got rook and four versus rook and
three and again he held it just really
really really well now we had to go into
a tie breakers and
prior to the the rapid chess tie
breakers i said the seal
if i get rook and four against rook and
three i'm claiming
three game repetition and the match is
drawn
he won the tiebreaker
was it a timber
it wasn't at the world
knockout cup uh
yeah tillberg
back in the day
um do we have h3 on the board no the
king of seven played so far and uh
clearly is choosing between rook g5 and
f4 and rook somewhere right
because those are sort of the definitive
two choices here i really don't like
playing you know he's gone rk chad since
it's not a possibility anymore i checked
with the table base h4 rocket shade hg
is a draw i even that is that king upon
an end game with the extra pawn is a
draw
h3 h3 as you guys mentioned is also i'm
drawing much easier much easier than h4
takes g3
uh rook h8 on the board and by the way i
do believe that uh linear is putting the
finishing touches yeah this is just
winning yeah yeah
it's just you can you can choose you can
choose pretty much
any way to to to go about things you can
go for mating attacks you once again can
probably
choose another game you like and go for
an end game exactly exactly well it's
got one minute though yes i mean it is
about the clock and here's our
uh what a chance for young uh daniel
today
uh
it was a three result game yeah
absolutely for linear this is just what
the doctor ordered i mean yeah he was
kind of uh suffering uh five games
without a win he wins today gets back to
fifty percent exactly kind of reboots
for him with three rounds to go and uh
potentially had he converted uh what we
think was a very promising position
because he did go for the linear clearly
not in in any kind of a hurry to trade
the queens here the position is way too
good to simplify exactly yeah
and yeah you still you still need to
find a way to like one way to win this
mission would be to play like b6 c2 but
that currently is illegal but maybe we
can find a way to like well i think the
moment it's a good start bishop e6
to b3 i quite like mission b3 here it
feels to me yeah it's it's a good start
yeah because i would like to actually
just give made here i think the way the
simplest way to win this position would
be to just start start a mating attack
and
and black will just uh as usual the side
with the more pieces on the board simply
is is going to be completely dominant
that's the way chess works
it doesn't really matter what the pieces
are called like at some point the sheer
number of them kind of carries i had
more you have less you lose i win too
many enemies yeah too many enemies i
like that king a2 also not bad you know
king a2
perfectly sensible yeah queen bishop if
26 is then we go bishop b3
the bishop nicely controls the a2 g8
diagonal don't you even think about
playing queen a8 bishop f6 will hurt
your feelings um
yeah it all looks really really good uh
jumping back to the game of shaq
for a moment um
again this was a game final f4 has been
provoked where it means like that the
black public holds this very very
comfortably enough yeah i mean good luck
getting your king out of the
uh off the back
uh again this was a game that both
players needed to win yeah
it just it's not happening they're just
that they're fighting hard i'm not
saying anything about that they really
are but they're just not sometimes you
just don't have you have success other
times you have great success and you're
not playing well
uh those are yeah the times where you
really need to capitalize
exactly when things are breaking your
way things have not been breaking uh for
shaq who is our defending champion
uh returning to romania last year
he was
wonderful plus three undefeated
and uh
broadly smiling every single round
but this is this event has not been a
shaq
event what has he done wrong in your
view
alejandro
what accounts for
the big differences between this year
and last year it's just how he started
right he got an ugly position from the
very get-go he underestimated the
dangers to his position against wesley
yeah and you know how often it happens
that you play a bad game and you lose
horribly and you start the tournament
yeah you start self-doubting you start
wondering wait what happened in my
position how come i understood what i
thought was chas and the engine says
something completely different and then
he comes and plays round two where he
thinks he's completely winning is it
around two against against richie and
nothing again nothing right he had
absolutely nothing the engine said he
had nothing and then he's just confused
about the rest of the tournament like
what am i doing uh another stumbled down
the road and now he's playing ali rezaku
he just played a good game i mean shaq
tried he tried but there's
pretty strong yeah and he's putting
pressure it's about as much as you can
hope for from a non-formal ereza yep
he's at least trying to torture him in
this three versus two
yeah but uh yeah by this point with the
four provoked the king still cut off on
the on the back rank and alirez up to
two and a half minutes due to increment
yeah
yeah you don't you don't really feel
like the best you can hope for is you
you get to play four fe4 rook takes e4
without the black king activating which
even that achieving that is not
a foregone conclusion because i am i
think very interested in king of five
king g [ __ ] f3 here
no it feels feels like something i
should be it's
strong away
but even without it let's say i go just
rook a2 here or what have you even those
positions are not really all that
dangerous although people do
occasionally lose those yeah like rookie
2 king to h4 if you allow all of that it
gets a bit trickier yeah but i i
especially like your king of five here
yeah just and honestly for that i would
marry i would prefer that to have the
rook on the longer side to already start
having uh checks in reserve but it
shouldn't matter like rook a2 instead of
rook h2
from this yeah king of one just put it
put it on a longer side
the longer side yeah
e4 fee and then we go to f3
and yeah it just feels like there's
never enough there
agreed
by the way it looks like something there
screen i guess uh the lee chess is
connected with the table base there
yeah i'm just wondering what that was
right like
yeah
i saw recently on a chess base there was
an article about
the table bases and how they're growing
and they called the table bases god
chess
because it's perfect perfect play right
yeah
all of these positions the the computer
play plays it perfectly well
yeah actually an interesting little
point there because i currently played
king g6 g7 sort of unprovoked
and we're now not getting to a five
right
that's our analysis apologies i just
refresh my board yeah so we can go king
of one now rookie to e4 i mean it's
still a draw of course but
good point uh so i wonder why he didn't
because i think that's the absolute
maximum of what you can achieve
definitely right about that so why
aren't we taking it f e rookie four
maybe it's e4 h4 with some kind of an
immediate draw but like i don't know
come again what's the immediate run
e4 instead of f takes e4 we can play h4
force gh
and then do something clever after e4 go
h4 here gh rook h2 or something all
right i mean it might actually be a draw
or okay four yeah that's
very good okay i didn't like because of
king f2 and game kind of continues rook
h2 might actually legitimate at some
point we have to remember that
we know our end games and fnh as a draw
and we'll make it comfortably because
we're grand masters
how happy are you forgetting i never had
to defend that ending and i never got it
either in my entire practice yeah did
you ever get it no good no
the one time i got it i was already lost
like it was an fnh but it was like a
defensive yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm curious why uh why shaq isn't
playing e4 and i get the feeling it is
specifically because he doesn't like
allowing
uh some kind of break like this because
yeah i mean you clearly cannot get
better than those positions we were
discussing with exactly g3 and f4
against h5 if you can get the king off
the back rank in time yeah we do have
rookie seven check on the board i mean
king's going to go back to g6 or or f6 i
don't know i don't know
i don't really see what the the
difference is you know right i mean shaq
for time control reasons uh peter
is that an issue that i mean he has he
has plenty of time and he's just giving
alireza more time by doing this
yeah i'm not i'm not sure exactly why he
is doing it this way because
it's not it's not as if alireza will
struggle playing kg16 g7 for the next
for the next for you know 20 moves
exactly
only don't allow king f7 rook h6 that
would be
so painful
you know you defend it so very well and
one single slip and yeah that would be
all
your efforts
that would be unnecessary yeah
in the meantime it looks for a second as
if uh linear actually blundered the
queen but he hasn't
uh because rookie 8 bishop takes f6 is
still
still very good for white here he's down
to 40 seconds which means that he played
bishop c3 on 10 seconds
on the clock but yeah he's still very
much in control it's just that he's kind
of struggling to land the final blow and
he is basically playing on increment uh
which which does give
uh some hope to to bogdan here but it's
difficult to make moves
for black you can play something like
rook e8 but i get you get the feeling
that you know allowing queen f7
even on 40 seconds you probably
calculate how the king runs
not sure i can run as well for white
though yeah i don't know
queen h1 right
yeah i mean i i would be reluctant to
play it but
yeah so you make some kind of a waiting
move with the rook because i think the
queen needs to stay on c6
to have connection to those checks you
know the king has no moves literally
yeah
you don't want to chuck so
yeah i really okay and importantly if
you leave if you leave the sixth rank
like queen e4 here straight up allows
mate after commission takes f6 and queen
b8
kind of important
otherwise this would have been a waiting
move you could consider but
unfortunately for you you just get mated
on ba g8 h8 squares
so yeah it feels like rook g8 or e8 are
the moves to you know choose from here
and you choose whichever one you
feel appeals to you the most i think
stopping queen e7 might be a reasonable
idea to preserve the e4 square for
checks so we go rook e8 as a kind of
looks like a result of those
deliberations we go to k8 and we say
okay like do something do something
clever yeah do something king a3 maybe
but then queen d sex change signature
okay and then we go back
bishop f7 i have a feeling we can play
rook a bishop of six h7 yeah yeah and
that might cost white yeah yeah yeah
dearly dearly yeah yeah bishop so would
be very uh
sad so what do you play
i think i make a waiting move as well go
for it bishop d4
yeah we just came from there though oh
did we i'm sorry
i did see the previous moves yeah we
just we just came from there so yeah i
mean it's a decent move but i'll go look
at fate and ask you the same question
right right right right
uh anything to have he actually saves
this it will be quite remarkable after
yesterday as well like he you know no i
mean uh
you know winning the game against richie
i don't really believe it but no it was
extraordinary uh
saving no no i can't believe it
f3
yeah he knows he must not blunder bishop
takes f6 yeah rookie eight was probably
the hardest move yeah
it because definitely the hardest move
queen f3 now i guess maybe i am
interested in the idea of going king a3
i don't know uh
wow
queen because i want to prepare queen e7
and i feel like those those positions
where the king runs up the board they
will in most cases be completely winning
for me because of how many squares my
bishops control so i want to start
preparing like the king run
well he's got to make a choice in five
seconds for both that already got up
bishop e6 bishop by the way he didn't
like
quickly snap the clock it was sort of
like the bishop went there no he's very
stylish yeah he is very stylish it
pressed itself into it
it gives me hard palpitations to watch
this
zero zero
no
this move it didn't like
spoil the position because of rook e8 i
don't know if it's considering that rook
8 you cannot go bishop b3 because it's a
repetition
but
how is this rookie 8 it says 0-0
wow what the
what the what what the what
the what there's a queen d1 check what
are we looking at so rookie eight queen
f7 28
queen a-a-a
and no king b3
for you
yeah i still don't quite understand why
this is a draw because it feels to me
like it should run like what do you mean
you got queen e4 rook takes if e6 ah you
should go rookie yeah this is not mate
yeah this is not made yeah and then
bishop for some reason only country
queen is six bishops
not the move that's not the move that's
not the move and that's e4 you said
you're not supposed to chuck the pawn
but it's not a bad move
but it gives
you queen a4 mate no queen a4 mata is a
big deal now
yeah hard to play this position in 30
seconds but yeah it's so it's it's not a
fun position to to be playing on
increment obviously not at all but it's
kind of like i assume there will be
technical problems but that actually
drops to zero zero zero is shocking it's
very surprising yeah yeah no question i
i thought and i get the feeling it
really is about threefold because rookie
bishop b3 does yeah before bishop d4
queen c60
we are stalemated there it's not
actually about repetitions we're just
stalemated we can't we can't really
leave the a5 you can do the a5
we should probably
show that for a second
which moment so queen of three b6 we go
rookie eight we
sorry queen f3 yeah he plays queen of
three here in the airplane bishop b8 and
now rook e8 which was rookie no yeah and
we thought bishop b3 doesn't really
nothing has been spoiled but after
bishop b3 black goes b4
bishop d4 queen c6 no no you can't take
rook a2 bishop d4 bishop g4 and queen c6
and white can't make any progress
wow here we have rook d-a yeah but now
with the pollen before you get the
feeling that white can probably go in
for the kill with something
you know okay let me just refresh my
maybe even i don't know
okay so both of them are basically
playing
very much on increment
i mean if lanier finds the best move
good it's him queen no queen f7 will run
into it
you get kudos for that by the way
because because you said the bishop b2
you've got 18 seconds to keep coming up
with moves oh my gosh
oh my gosh they were never getting this
we're never getting this bishop c4 queen
there's some fire
yesterday's on fire the only winning
move and lanier finds it these guys
these guys are very good yes yes
incredible bishops before i don't even
get the point on that move i think we
are preparing b3 yeah exactly
i loved your idea
awesome victory was losing
which is why we're securing the bishop
first and we are preparing b3 bishop
nice yeah this is quite remarkable yeah
bishop c4 what a great move on six
seconds
that's amazing
he's good he's good at this yeah and now
and now bogdan is down he's uh singing
back he almost forgot where the clock
was yeah you see he was reaching over
there it's like the the old double slope
but now no queen is seven and no greens
are still okay no yeah yeah yeah sorry
no actually that's made it huh yeah
so what is the the big idea no you you
got your idea
b3 yeah but why is it so good like okay
i get the three bishop b2 but then what
my progress is is unclear to me i don't
know
maybe then i can actually swing my it's
going back to e6 yeah he has at least
one repetition
it will yeah it will give him some time
rg8 will be
you know if you know with any sense you
just play rook g8 instantly it's not a
repetition yet you just played before
you can't claim anything so yeah you
just make this move as quickly as
possible to give yourself leeway exactly
and to put as much pressure as possible
in your opponent yeah
yeah
but lanier will be very happy to gain
the 30 seconds that he needs it's only a
gain if you play it quickly
he hasn't played enough in uh i guess in
televised events right
you know you you learn to you learn to
recognize where the cameras are right
bishop c4 yeah rook of fate will be
played very quickly and then it's back
on linear to find the move and the b3
move it's really bizarre that linear got
himself into this spot because uh the
conversion seemed to have been going
very very swimmingly and now we're back
on
yeah but the question is is after the
move b three followers will have to play
but also i don't quite understand what
the threat is like well
my understanding is you go b3 bishop b2
yes then you go bishop to b5 to a4 and
then well you can't play you can't play
bishop b5 because rook 8 will win our
queen right so no there's always bishop
f6 yeah but it's not mate anymore
because i'll have king g8 right
if you play bishop before bishop c4 is
still made like bishops come back to c4
it goes g7 f7
oh my oh
oh you should we don't have time really
we should show this and he's gonna hang
on a second
now he has bishop a7 there he wants
bishop a7 wow
what that is a brave brave decision does
it work though also queen of two
wins the bishop
what
what did he do
it's good according to the engines rook
a8 because
that is pretty oh
you see the move queen f2 you think the
puzzle rush is is over no no no it's not
queen puzzle rush continues yeah in the
end
horribly hopeless yeah yeah yeah
with the people i'm so close to dropping
yeah you just yeah bishop a7 and yeah
bogdan sees this but is there a better
move is the question well that's the
problem yeah it's funny how this turned
out to be rather interesting dramatic
yeah like what i mean
i thought we were going to have to talk
about that rook ending and i was kind of
dredging that but we have this thing
dismissive of
wow
what am
what tricks that we're seeing in this
this is queen f8 yeah this short story
turned into a novel
17 16 with three acts
what's the [ __ ] time it's hard
it's under 10.
and
queen
he goes six because he sees queen of two
queen of fate of course he is very sharp
tactically but now i guess queen b3
queen takes before just wins honestly
king b3 king b3 just don't be in
ourselves yeah and if you if you give a
check from f3 i just very happily munch
on
yes and he's done it
suggest no checks
yes there is no checks and we are
finally making progress and pinning our
staff yes
and coming back to the re reasonably
comfortable comfortable conversion
queen e7 bishop a7 is
wow yeah
but i did like concepts i i did like the
b3 bishop b2 bishop b5 should be five
yeah a8 and bishop f6 once this is over
we do want to show that that
rook c8 on the board threatening queen
take c4 yeah i think you'll see that one
queen is 166 is pretty straightforward
straightforward the most cynical the
most cynical way of yeah going about
things here just protect everything
and he there are more yeah maybe there
is something faster but at this point
you don't realize i
i don't want to test anymore
yeah and also they gained some time
because he is in an incredibly luxurious
position he started with more than a
minute apparently wow
because he's been thinking for a bit and
there's there's still 44 42 seconds on
the clock well bishop a7 and king b3
were those were two moves that did come
rather quickly and you just played with
six
wow yeah
that's it and there is move 60 as you
can see by them switching to different
scoresheets but no extra time for the
60th
move
none whatsoever
yeah and this is where like yo your king
side is so soft that you basically have
to trade queens and and then yeah you
just know the end game is completely
hopeless and uh queen f3 checked
out just like before
no checks the bishop on a7 actually
serves a a very very useful purpose and
with this trade of queens the b pawn is
toast serving a youthful purpose
the b-pawn is uh really toast and well
the two bishops on an open board
you know
easily winning i'm going to check in
with the redreaded rook ending and guess
what
shaq has sometimes managed to achieve
his ultimate i mean it will keep us here
yeah it may still not be enough but uh
i'm amazed he's gotten
the best he
he could by by a long shot in fact
rook d8 uh in the game of yeah we can
take if we want three should be eight
preserves the pawn on g3 you get the
feeling that even if the pawn on g3
drops we're still winning because the b
pawn just runs so quickly yeah but we
also have absolutely no necessity of
giving it up
exactly uh we've got bishop b8 in the
pocket whenever the rook activate gets
active
king takes b4 as a is a near certainty
just pick it up and go from there
yep
and as we're saying that and and
if you if you watch closely enough you
can see uh bogdan actually filling out
the scoresheet he was filling in the
names there at the top while while
lanier was thinking very diligent
i like this
you know
things things need to look properly he
played rook d3 instead of really but it
doesn't really change very much we
should b8 is still quite good
yeah
in the in the rare case i mean in my
case right because my games tend to end
around move 40 but you probably played
more in games of a lifetime than i have
i played enormous number of adjourned
games too so my question to you is yes
if you get the second score [ __ ] up to
move 16. yes and it normally like nobody
really goes to the trouble of printing
special squashes for this so it says one
right yeah or for you for your 61st move
do you actually manually add the sixes
and the sevens and the i did i did yeah
i always i always do yeah yeah i i did i
did
just
i don't know what it was but uh
i wanted to know it was the 61st move
right now
move number one nobody nobody's going to
penalize you're not doing it but you
still do it right it feels right yeah
yeah exactly
alejandro there shaking his head anyway
no that was an
where i had like 180 moves you should
have seen my like four score sheets
we've been there at some point with
three or four score sheets but
but numbering them and numbered yes
correct very good peter i'm so happy
that
good habits will rub off on you and then
i'm already like i'm already taking too
many puns like i've seen myself
i see myself on like chess.com
like i take a phone and then it destroys
my position like i don't even think of
this
yeah please please yeah you know
no charge
because the pond essentially the pawn is
just marching yeah there's nothing
there's nothing to talk about yeah this
is basically a rook there on bit to a
full rook yes
all right we'll turn
over to our game between uh shaq
and uh
well well this is the unfortunately he's
achieved the most he can and it's a draw
and unfortunately for us this is the two
versus one where you don't give the draw
because this is you know once in a while
loseable yeah loseable let's say your
opponent forgets that he has to have a
rook on a1 when when he king is on g2
right and you get to play king h3 and
not be met by rook h1 check so you get
the king to h4 and at that point it
might be lost in some cases so
let's try to set that up okay by the way
i think
he's already tried that is to say shaq
is already true knows that it needs to
be it needs to be available mm-hmm
but yeah like somewhere here uh
okay he's played rookie one i don't know
what that does but well i think his
intention is to go rook to
i think i've seen this on my screen
and the issue is you get the king to h4
with the rook on h1 and then you can't
move it so you're still right you're
still very stuck unfortunately so
doesn't really help as much as you think
it does
all right
spike workpick too no
i don't think it matters no as we as we
see on our screen where basically table
base is very much in effect on on
leaches where we're watching and
and then yeah as expected has won that
game what uh what a crazy game this was
with chances for both sides love the
struggle
i really do and i just got a salute
linear i mean
what a game i mean yeah yeah
wow uh he kept it together he kept it
together for a very very long time in
very very trying circumstances he did
once given a chance he did not let it go
i mean wow machine says he did for a bit
but
he got himself into a tricky position in
30 seconds there not not hard to see why
you start making mistakes there
wow
uh
great fight a great fight and for uh and
bogdan's fans i mean i'm serious i think
daniel was playing at a 2800 clip coming
into today's round and
wow he nearly uh
well he had a three result game yeah
absolutely very very very exciting game
but yeah so
just breaking against him remind
everybody we've four four games are
under our belt we have two wins two
draws and one game remaining and this is
the if this one as expected ends in a
draw we will be uh entering sort of uh
uncharted waters yeah where we get to
win yeah we've not had we've not had a
two result day yet exactly exactly we
won't know what to do with ourselves
i can't
i'm pretty sure i have
gotten this position in my practice
but strangely enough i think i had the
pawns on f3 and g2
which for some reasons i'm not even sure
of actually gave me more chances
i think i still drew it by the way but
uh
yeah i don't have a particularly good
record of even pressing in these
positions which are supposed to be very
pressable i i wanted to ask you i mean
because you
well i mean you've been in the in the
top for so long peter uh who
who for you were like the great end game
players
the from the from the people i've
watched i mean i i named sheriff and i
was entirely underrunning there i think
sheriff is a name that many people will
name very very
close to to the top i mean magnus
obviously even though and i think also
you could sort of see where thought has
gone into it because like he famously
lost a very very well known end game to
live on in one of the early time
memorials where i was going to say lavon
as well i mean uh levon for sure but
there was this this end game where uh
magnus failed to defend and i mean many
people have lost it over the years it's
a kind of a famous end game for very
strong players to make mistakes in
uh
but it it it kind of i think sort of
very clearly
signifies a breaking point where he he
he had that happen to him
uh using the passive voice there
and
clearly it's
somewhere around that point he he told
himself this should not happen again
right
and it sort of stopped happening after
that like
he very much is in the business of
winning drone positions but he doesn't
really lose drone positions anymore uh
so yeah magnus um
how about vishy
i'm like vicious
god you know he is good at everything
the problem the problem with you know at
least like this is that it will be a
list of people who are just sort of
generally good at chess it's difficult
and and this is why like you start with
sheriff is because
just starting every answer with with
carlson is
maybe correct but not that interesting
you know
and alex say even though he's you know
was a tremendously uh strong player in
his prime he was you know definitely
like the world top five slash three
slash whatever you want to choose but
right but he hasn't you know actually
won the world championship and is uh but
yeah i i rate him as a very very uh you
know special end game player
but generally it will be at least very
closely resembling your you know
top list of players of all time
[Music]
all together because i think you know
nobody
starts with gary in this list because
you know because you you feel like for
instance you know his
uh
[Music]
influence in how people approach opening
theory is just sort of so much more
important than his end game skills right
but he wasn't a better game
and let's jump to bucharest says
christian is with lanier
thank you yasser linear uh marathon game
for you uh great victory uh you needed a
lot of energy for this one five hours
what did you do yesterday during the
rest day to gain all this energy well i
was resting indeed
i slept well and i felt uh felt quite
good today uh but yeah it was a very
tense game i think he played extremely
well especially the first part of the
game i think he got a just a better
position at some point but okay i i had
my my chances and we were both long time
and i think uh the last part of the
first time control he he played
quite badly and
just on rule 40 i was i had a promising
position again
and then yeah let's take it from the
beginning uh you guys had a very
interesting discussion in the opening in
this neighborhood variation so i play a
little bit about this i played a3 which
is so unusual here maybe it's a novelty
and the idea is just to make a useful
move and see where
black is going so queen c7 g3 rook d8 i
think black can also play with long
castle
and now
uh yeah it's supposed to be of course
compensation because the kin
black skin is always a bit uh
weak even if
black plays castle short then i'll have
some some attack with g4 at some point
but this is some long-term compensation
yeah it's it's long-term of course uh
there are no immediate uh
um
there are no immediate ways for for
white to to to get back to pawn or
something like that it's just to play
with the two bishops and and try to
break with f4 at some point
so i thought that now that black doesn't
have long castle anymore i i should uh
play bishop d3 i wasn't sure i mean
i mean it looks weird to play g3 and
then play bishop d3 because
you can also put the bishop on g2 but i
was considered in video i was
considering f4 knight instead of fishing
d3 f4
uh knight b6 and
bishop d2 i thought knight c4
and i didn't like it because the knight
on c4 is hard to
to go to kick out you know black and
played b5 later and even castle shorts
so
um that's why i play bishop d3
and
yeah
knight b6 i thought it's very principle
to play d5 for p1
uh yeah maybe rookie one was not correct
here maybe f4 i should play immediately
it seems like um just the engine is
trying to just get f5 breakthrough and
try to activate the bishop somehow yeah
i mean i thought about this position but
i thought that black can play e4 here
and if bishop takes f6 then takes takes
and there is knight c4 so i cannot go
for this
so after e4
um black will
follow up with d5
and
yes and
i wasn't sure
because i mean yeah some compensation
but i
during the game it didn't feel clear to
me and uh okay i played rookie one and
then black goes d5
i was very happy with this queen e2 move
because i thought that uh if knight bd7
c4 i overestimated this idea for for
white uh but there was there were some
lines here instead of knight bd7 i have
d7
i thought some interesting lines
uh i was going to take on e7 king takes
and then play f4
and if e4 i was thinking about bishop
takes sacrifice yeah yeah this position
takes king f8
uh queenstown and now king d7 loses i
think 294
seems like king g8 oh yeah
yeah equal i was thinking that i can't
go for this but maybe it's it's likely
not equal as we can see right now yeah
f5
after f5 it's hard to understand i
thought that king g8 instead of k7 but
then anyway f5 and
uh
yeah lots of compensation yeah or yeah
group d6 was also possible uh so uh yeah
and then uh and perhaps this is what he
saw as well and maybe yeah got scared a
bit so a good reason yeah i thought the
knight bd7 allowed c4 but after castle i
didn't i mean i couldn't find a
promising way here to play
so i thought that uh
yeah i will play uh just for
try to keep the two bishops and
attention keep the tension but uh yeah
basically
at this point black is obviously
much better and i was just hoping for
um
maybe but maybe in time troll i can just
turn it around somehow
and as you guys got closer to the time
control situation you uh the position
changed
some pawns got traded off you managed to
penetrate with the rook on c6 were you
feeling more comfortable at this point
yeah basically i felt that white is now
well
just
completely
out of danger here because
black's pieces are so passive now that
there's no way i mean i was actually
thinking that i'm much better but maybe
maybe it's not the case i thought it's
very strange to play queen b7 i mean
this is the move that surprised
everybody in the studio
i mean after queen of five you're
supposed to get rid of the queens and
then at least uh
uh hope for something i mean try to
defend this end game which is maybe even
not that difficult to defend objectively
but yeah i was very surprised by queen
d7 i was very happy to to have the
queens on and uh i guess here the last
few moves were probably not uh not great
did you spot this move e4 this idea yeah
initially i thought that i can just take
but i missed the rookie five wins the
rook so
uh or i don't know i mean i was i i
briefly thought about bishop before here
but uh
i didn't want to allow this pawn yeah he
has three takes three takes on d6 and
okay i have two there's bishop e5 but uh
yeah win d4
but uh instead of f2 takes yeah i i
imagine that something will happen with
this pawn even queen f5
and then takes and the pawns there's no
way to stop it so i and you were very
much right about that and you found this
super classy move we really liked this
bishop to e3 move
yeah this was the
the other move that fell natural with
with uh with less than 30 seconds keep
the tension and also keep this
point at bay right but i thought that uh
after something like uh dating on f3
which is what he played and then yeah
king idea f6 so i was also surprised by
the move i thought that it's weakening
but maybe i mean i thought that
something like
um
or you know or even after f6 but again
queen of five i thought of showing
should play and then
uh in this end game i mean i thought it
so it should be a draw somehow with
definitely
much better than than
the position that regarding
and just to interrupt you for a second
this one is indeed over the game between
ali reza and mamedyarov and it seemed
that it finished in a draw
we're going to continue with the
analysis
and he played this move rook to f8 a bit
passive i believe this was the 40th move
yeah it was uh it was a mistake as well
yeah this was the last move and now you
got a chance to uh pile on the pressure
queen to d5 queen to e7 yeah how you
found this great move queen to e6 yeah i
was i was very close a lot of times i
was very yeah after spending a lot of
time i was uh
very close to play queen takes b5 which
i think loses to queenie for check
after i saw this i just played queen e6
immediately because i thought that uh
what black once was to play uh to go for
the same game with three pawns so take
on e6
and then group c8 rook c8 bishop c8 and
bishop h4 and maybe there are some some
chances here because
three bombs and black can put the bishop
on g3 or something and even if he loses
the bomb on b5 then
try to push and maybe bring the king to
the queen side in in some cases or just
try to just push with g5 team g6f5 i
thought that
i felt that it should be a draw but i i
had to try this i didn't see any other
way i was very surprised we could like
by the move queen v8 again
and this was a big mistake uh it it did
seem like it was a big mistake
yeah so i i mean he played it extremely
fast so i thought that uh yeah maybe
rook takes c8 doesn't work then because
if you play if you play if you could
play the move uh that fast but then
yeah perhaps he missed that after queen
to f5 you can just go king to c1 yeah
that's why
i was of course
intending to do now he he's just simply
going to run out of chats you can't yeah
yeah
bishops i mean his king is so weak and
uh
basically
i think bishop c3 also orders even
kingdom i think we should be one kingdom
is even easier
so now he played this move queen to d8
and yeah and here it's of course
completely winning but somehow i managed
to yeah to create some chances for black
which was something things got
interesting after this move bishop to b3
allowed queen to c6 which he played yes
and now queen yeah before i was thinking
that yeah queen of free i i didn't see
but uh but king 283 forget about it
because no humans oh i i had 23 yeah
i mean i was i was thinking of course
yeah because i need to get out but uh
but i was very surprised by queen of
three i was thinking that he would play
before and
and bishop b4 would be eight something
like this and here it is
with the idea of a checkmate on h6 oh so
maybe it's always winning but i just
made it it is made it more difficult it
is it is indeed always yeah i was i was
worried that at some point so at this
point it was actually equal oh
if he does start so the idea is the same
with before the move that he played but
the ball if i don't have the bishop c4
idea yes so you just start with rook 38
and it seems to me well it seems to the
engine that
this one is uh yeah yeah i mean i
managed to put the pieces in just the
right way for for black to
to get uh to get counter play still he
with 30 seconds on the clock for both of
uh the players it's impossible to play a
perfect game
big victory for you uh how do you assess
your performance so far linear and
what's the plan for the last three
rounds yeah well first of all it's very
nice to get back to
uh to 50 to win a game
um i think
my play hasn't been that great but also
not bad i think i
i have i've played reasonable games
so yeah for the last games um uh
i'll try to just uh continue with the
same strategy just to try to play my
best and and
try to get to exploit
the chances that i might get lanier
congratulations once again and we'll see
in the next few rounds thank you
back to you guys
you christian as we go to our standings
with uh
round six in the history books peter and
these are the completed standings with
uh now a very nice separation of uh
players at the top there are two people
on plus two wesleyan the one who won
this very
short quick game yeah yeah short game
against uh
mvl and then a bunch of people on 50
percent
uh two players in minus one uh alireza
and richard rapport there are two
candidates still in minus one and shocks
still in minus two uh bringing up the
rear
and just looking ahead uh look at our
the road ahead for our leaders that
peter wesley's got uh white against uh
bogdan dayak tomorrow black against
euroja and white against the air having
the two whites is quite
sorry the other way around all right
actually yeah sorry yeah okay
still it's it's nice to kick somebody
when they're down
uh in this case baghdan
has come in after last year
and forever
yeah one we have uh white against fabi
and white against shah in the last round
and uh breaking up with those two white
games uh black against nippon machine
rendez murders roe for sure
well everything is everywhere yeah yeah
tournament
through that through that uh i just be
before we
get set up to leave i wanted to show
that one
very high issue
you can bring it up because it's it's
extremely beautiful it's very study-like
uh how did we get it uh let me yes let
me handle this for a sec so if we play
b3 somewhere probably here is good yeah
instead of queen e7 so the point here
would be i don't know exactly how to set
this up
but let's say we make two waiting moves
here right and we go back to f3 yes and
we thought the plan was to actually get
the bishop to a4 and then there's no
counter play so play bishop and i
pointed out to yesterday this is a
blunder because now we can play rk8
allowing bishop to xf6 but the king
quote unquote runs away but it does not
actually run away the queen a7 is doomed
but it can still support some checks on
the seventh by the laws of chess king
takes g7 is not a legal move despite
this queen being very very pinned so you
go king e8 bishop seven once again
bishop f6 here going through the square
which is seemingly attacked by the queen
but we will then pick up the g8 and if
you go king c8 which is a bit of a
mistake you allow
bishop e6 mate and yeah this is a very
unusual kind of a ladder construction
which you don't see you don't see very
often with the queen
with the queen pinned in a absolute pin
as well yes so it was like you're losing
your queen but the bishops deliver made
very unusual very beautiful
and uh
again uh we were treated to some really
great chess
alejandra
and let's take a look at our predictions
see how we're doing after today's round
a certain var is the one that actually
asked to have the predictions i put it
myself yeah i was certainly not asking
bobby is not the one the player who won
the american cup he's getting the
slightly worse positions with white yeah
i mean there's a lot of sad faces and
exactly exactly
i see anastasia's
really really upset with her choice
i mean this has been a rough running
guys
we don't look good here
let let's jump to bucharest for final
thoughts
christian anastasia
what a day guys what are they two
decisive results uh i have to say that
game between mvl and aronian just
strikes me as odd mvl with the white
pieces losing in that fashion well
that's just simply a gift to levon and
it's great to see finally uh lanier
getting his first victory with the white
pieces i have to say he took the
necessary risks in this one and he got
handsomely repaid for that anastasia how
about yourself yes i agree christian
with you that fortune actually favors
the brave right so he took some risks
but he finally won the game which was so
important for the standings now he joins
wesley saw on the first
place and it's i think it's really great
feeling for levon right now and of
course this this is the game i picked up
by the way at the very beginning of the
round and i was hoping it's going to be
some action and it was and of course the
second game which linear one was also
quite very interesting there were many
ups and downs and in the end finally
linear scored his first victory in this
tournament and actually i'm very glad
that two the most experienced players
managed to win today so which shows you
know
that experience still sometimes wins
against
not experienced players absolutely
absolutely and we do have uh well two
big players fighting it off for the
championship going into the final
stretch of the event the last three
rounds is going to be a fun exciting
sharp ending to this tournament and uh
we're coming back tomorrow with round
seven guys back to you in st louis thank
you both it is amazing that two-thirds
of the tournament's gonna we still have
a lot of chests yeah
there's still
plenty uh
everything uh up for grabs but uh
your final thoughts alejandro i think
christian set up pretty well it was a
fighting round uh pretty surprised about
the levon game but i'm happy to see some
pressure build up on wesley i'm tired of
him going plus two and then cruising
towards the finish line i wanna see
somebody push him i wanna see somebody
get to plus three to win this event the
way that shock did it last year this
plus two stuff it's not enough i wanna
see more fights we have three more
rounds i wanna see more wins there at
the top
well said yeah you can't add anything
wish list announced yes exactly uh peter
it was it it was a good it was a good
product
despite despite you know technically the
the decisive game percentage probably
not being the highest ever in history uh
we really don't have very many quiet
games we have just about one per round
i think that where you can say that not
much was happening and yeah i've been
really enjoying the tournament so far i
think it's been a very very uh
interesting tournament to watch and and
talk about and uh yeah it looks like a
little bit of a two horse race at the
moment but you know things could change
you know it's clearly hitting 50 could
easily uh take a stab join us tomorrow
for a round seven same time same channel
good night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited